Aus welchen Themen setzt sich die heutige Freak Show zusammen?
Und jetzt haben wir noch zehn Sekunden. Der Countdown läuft bis zur Prognose Punkt 18 Uhr.
Tio Koll. Wir warten auf den Gong. Und hier kommt unsere Prognose für die Freak Show.
Die Apple-Schlüsselnote. Kommt auf 42,5.
Sehr starke Gewinne zuletzt vor 20. Über 40 Prozent. 26,5. Deutlich verbessert. 4,5. Massive Verluste. Nicht mehr. Wenn das so bleibt, erstmalig in der Geschichte der Freak Show. 8,5 mit Verlusten. Podcast. 8,0. Ebenfalls Verluste.
Und die Wikipedia.
Kommt auf 4,8. Es ist unsicher, ob es noch reicht für die Freak Show. Die andere zusammen 5,2. Ja, die Spannung steigt.
Worum wird es wohl gehen?
In gewisser Hinsicht ist das sozusagen eigentlich die ideale Beschreibung unserer Vorbereitungsphase.
Nur jetzt mal neu mit Zahlen.
Wir haben Vorbereitungsphasen?
Zwischen Pizza und Eis.
Burger, Eis, Nachdenken, welches Getränk man haben will, all diese ganzen Sachen und dann so fünf Minuten vorher immer der Blick auf die Outline. Haben wir überhaupt Themen?
Das ist eine Frage, die nur Tim stellt eigentlich.
Ja, ich bin sozusagen der fragende Geist. Das ist eigentlich eine ganz gute Strategie, weil wenn man immer fragt, muss man nicht so viel erklären und auch nicht so viel wissen. Und das ist für jemanden, der davon lebt, vom gesunden Halbwissen. Das ist eigentlich eine ganz gute Überlebensstrategie. Das hat bisher nicht ganz gut funktioniert. Ja, Pause ist vorbei, Freak Show ist wieder da. Wir schreiben die 174. Sendung. 174. Und wir haben Verluste zu beklagen, Abgänge. Da ist mal angekündigterweise der Clemens, der befindet sich auf einer Lustreise.
Hallo Clemens.
Oder der ist doch wieder im Internetland. Der ist doch wieder da, wo nur IP gesprochen wird.
Sagt er.
Sagt er. Danach erzählt er irgendwas von Vulkanen und so. Ja, was er alles so erlebt. Wusstet ihr übrigens, dass IP jetzt irgendwie, ich hab jetzt gerade gelesen, IP ist jetzt nur noch IPv6? Ja, so überhaupt so. Die IETF scheißt jetzt auf IPv4 und meint, der ganze alte Kack wird jetzt überhaupt nicht mehr angefasst, wird überhaupt nicht mehr... Genau. Genau.
Vintage.
Wir machen da auch nichts mehr mit den Protokollen. Das bleibt jetzt alles so, wie es ist. Und wenn wir jetzt IP sagen, machen wir v6. Und wer das nicht verstanden hat, der muss regelmäßig Freak Showen hören.
Sagst du an einem Tag, wo bei uns im Office das IPv6-Announcement den ganzen Tag nicht funktioniert hat. Und der Admin erst um 19 Uhr wiederkommt, um das zu reparieren. Und öffentliche Kollegen schälte die anderen drei IT-Mitarbeiter halt nichts mit dem Netzwerk zu tun haben wollen, was ich persönlich ja mal vorsichtig dünn finde.
Freigkeit vor dem Feind ist das.
Ja, also ich meine, man will doch mal im eigenen Office wenigstens das Netz... das Netz geht. Aber das ist halt genau das Problem von IPv6 immer noch im 21. Jahrhundert. Das wird halt nicht als Core-Infrastruktur angesehen. Da ist einfach der ganze Tag ist das IPv6 aus und...
Kein kümmerts.
Ja, wie denn hier, YouPorn geht alles. Was wollt ihr eigentlich?
Ja, aber meine Anwendungen gehen halt nicht. Also ich kann mich nicht mit V6 auf meinen Servern einloggen, geht mal gar nicht.
Die sollten alle, um arbeiten zu können, irgendeinen einzigen Dienst haben, der nur über V6 erreichbar ist. Damit würde man das dann relativ schnell gefixt bekommen.
Zweiter... Porno.
Was?
Porno. Porno und IPv6.
Oder Google. Google nur noch auf V6.
Google nur noch auf V6, gute Idee.
Nee, Google, also auf V6 normal und auf IPv4 mit einer Gedenksekunde. Eine reicht schon, die Leute werden verrückt.
Die IPv6-Gedenksekunde.
Vor vier eigentlich.
Na ja, soll man ja an V6 denken, also ist es sozusagen die V6-Gedenksekunde.
Könnte man so sagen.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Und dann so in einem Jahr zwei Sekunden. Und das dann so langsam erhöhen. Exponential.
Naja, zweiter Abgang, Roddi. Es ist noch so ein bisschen unklar, das war jetzt, er hat sich sozusagen beim Aufwärmen verletzt. Eigentlich sollte er ja spielen heute, aber ich liebe ja Fußballanalogien, das funktioniert immer so gut. Wir haben jetzt noch keine genauen Daten, aber wir haben gerade so den Eindruck, er ist jetzt irgendwo horizontalisiert und sein Brummschädel klingt langsam ab. Nein, er hat sich nicht über den Durst gesoffen, sondern er ist mit etwas zusammengestoßen. Weiß ich auch nicht so genau.
Er hat sich aufgewärmt wie eine Flasche leer.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall gute Besserung, Roddi, so du uns überhaupt noch hören kannst. Ich hoffe, es ist...
Aber es ist schon so, nicht bei Freak Show dabei sein können, Ausrede Nummer eins, oder? Also das toppt bisher niemand. Ich meine, das Land extra verlassen ist auch schon nicht so schlecht.
Naja, gut, aber Dennis ist ja da, ne? Dennis, hallo. Und du bist auch schon eingeloggt. Das ist sehr schön.
Ich hab auch schon meine ersten Krisen hinter mir. So, Window resize, da kommen mehrere Gedenksekunden, bevor da was passiert. Hast du das sicher auch schon gemerkt.
Da können wir gleich drüber reden. Keine Gedenksekunden.
Also ich hatte heute Gedenkstunden, das reicht.
Stunden?
Na ja, das ging ja den ganzen Tag nicht.
Da war einer schneller als ich mit seinen Ideen.
Und eine besondere Freude ist es uns, dass wir auch noch einen Gasser zu bekommen haben.
Einfach wild von der Straße gekriegt.
Unerhört. Es ist eigentlich gerade zufällig vorbeigelaufen am Fenster. Und wir haben gesagt, hier, komm mal gleich rein.
So läuft das.
Ja, so ist das.
Das ist immer eigentlich.
Ja, sonst wehderst du das geht nicht. Das darf nur ich.
Na ja, also, ja, willkommen bei der Freak Show, Letty. Freut mich sehr. Wir hatten dich ja schon ganz lange auf der Liste, aber du wolltest ja immer nicht.
Ich hab immer eine gute Ausrede gehabt, aber heute...
Hat sich nicht geklappt.
Heute hatte Tim mehr Schnaufe.
Ich wurde schon misstrauisch, als jemand aus dem Fenster gestiegen kam. Ich dachte mir so, da, schlechte Idee, Mittwoch.
Schnell auf der anderen Straßplatte. Nein, sie haben mich gesehen.
Du kannst ja auch nicht weg, ne?
Ne, das ist ungünstig. Wir brauchen einen Hintereingang.
Na ja, gut. Ich denke, weder du noch alle anderen werden das bereuen, dass du hier bist.
Das werden wir sehen.
Ja, ein bisschen müssen wir dich schon vorstellen, Letty. Du warst ja noch nicht da.
Ne, ich war noch nicht da.
Genau.
Was möchtet ihr denn wissen?
Na ja, also ich würde jetzt mal sagen, du bist Nerd.
Schwer zu übersehen, mit einem Camp-Shirt-Kleid, ja.
Genau, und noch mehr Aufkleber auf dem Rechner als ich.
Ja, ja.
Ist noch alles dabei.
Na, auf jeden Fall der Dildo-Generator. Entschuldigung, also ich finde für jedes offizielle Meeting einfach der Hammer, so einen Dildo-Generator-Aufkleber auf dem Rechner zu haben.
Was ist denn der Dildo-Generator?
Man kann sich einen Dildo generieren und dann wird er in 3D gedruckt. Wo? Auf Dildo-Generator dort kommen. Ich glaube, das sind doch auch Berliner, soweit ich weiß.
Ich falle aus allen Worten.
Weißt du natürlich noch nicht, weil hast du ja nicht gemacht, ne?
Nee, natürlich nicht.
Dildo-Generator.
Aber ich hab den besten Aufkleber nicht hier drauf. Der ist auf dem anderen Rechner. Ich habe einen LessPensMoreScience-Aufkleber von...
dildogenerator.com? Auf den Schirm.
Wir haben ja sonst keine Themen.
Aber ganz schön viel Porn auf deinem Deckel. Dildo-Generator, we make data love, we make metadata porn. Dann war noch irgendwas mit Porn, hab ich verloren. Na doch, da war noch irgendwo, ich hab's mir noch eingesehen.
Das sind nur zwei.
Doch, da we like Porn ist noch. Da ist er, siehst du genau. Mit dem Dildo zusammen sind's schon vier.
Den hab ich gänzlich übersehen. Der ist einfach zu klein.
Das ist ein richtiges Pornolaptop. Wow, Dildo-Generator, adjust your lust. Na das ist ja...
Natürlich.
Dann generiert er doch mal ein, Tim.
Wood, Holz oder Silikon?
Die können Silikon 3D drucken mittlerweile?
Das wird dann gedreht, nehme ich an.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die den dann herstellen. Also ich weiß, dass du Silikon ja auch selber formen kannst.
Ach, wie geil. Jetzt kann man hier so richtig so eine Bezié-Kurve da bewegen und sozusagen genau die...
Nach den Bedürfnissen einstellen.
Also da kommen dann so Durchmesser und Längen.
Aber du kannst den Punkt jetzt nicht in der Höhe verschieben, sondern nur links, rechts, ne?
Ins Spiel. Und dann kann man auch noch die Farbe bewegen.
Das bedarf mehr Handarbeit wahrscheinlich.
Was? Wieso können die nicht...
Also 3D gedruckt wird das Holz dann wahrscheinlich auch nicht, nehme ich mal an.
Ich dachte, der wäre 3D gedruckt, ja.
Ja, aber was kann man denn dann überhaupt?
Was könnte denn dann überhaupt?
Ja, die Presets finde ich ja jetzt ganz lustig.
Ja, ist ein bisschen Standard, aber ja.
Das ist aber mehr so Popostöpsel hier, was ich jetzt hier gerade klicke.
Du kennst dich ja auch aus.
Hoffentlich kriegt man das daraus. Naja, ich habe ja auch mal in der Pornoindustrie gearbeitet.
Nee, weiß ich nicht.
Wie, das weißt du nicht.
Wer ist das?
Das habe ich doch bestimmt schon x-mal erzählt hier.
Also das, ich kenne dich ja schon eine Weile, aber das ist mir neu.
Also ich habe das auf jeden Fall schon mehrmals zum Besten gegeben. Vielleicht habe ich das noch nicht in der Freak Show erzählt.
Also ich, kein Bild, kein Ton.
Ich hatte mal so eine Zeit, da war ich, sagen wir mal, in, wurde ich quasi, also indirekt bezahlt von Beat Use. Und das war eine sehr lehrreiche Zeit, kann ich dir sagen.
Hast du Produkte in den Webshop eingepflegt, oder was?
Ne, ne, ne. Ne, das war...
Ne, du Model.
Nein, nein. Das hatte eigentlich mehr mit dem zu tun, was ich heute mache, als irgendwas anderes. Aber du wirst auch sicherlich mal was von der Villa gehört haben.
So, die war von Beat Use, ja stimmt, da war irgendwas.
Genau. Also das waren ja so die frühen 90er, so, als es noch kein Internet gab, so, aber es gab halt 190er-Nummern. Beziehungsweise es gab auch noch keine 190er-Nummern, sondern es sollte 190er-Nummern geben. Ich glaube, die sind dann vier, Anfang 94, glaube ich.
Dafür bin ich zu jung.
Ja, aber du weißt ja, was 190er-Nummern sind. Die heißen jetzt 100, 00, 900er-Nummern, aber damals war es halt 00, 190, ne? Wo dann immer so abends im Fernsehen dann irgendwie so diese ganzen, was früher Sendeschluss hieß, wo war ja dann nur noch so diese Orgien an, ah, wie ich an den ganzen Ohrmaster vorfahre. Ja, wahrscheinlich. Also, keine Ahnung. Ich nehme ja an Fernseher.
Doch, kein Fernseher mehr.
Ja, ich auch nicht.
Ich auch nicht.
Ne, und du auch nicht, ne?
Ne, auf Netflix läuft ja sowas nicht, oder?
Das ist dann auch die Lücke.
Shame on you. Na ja, auf jeden Fall. Soll ich das mal erzählen jetzt, oder nicht?
Wir sind ein ganzes Ohr.
Ich muss das erstmal gerade mal da rauskrabbeln. Ich muss das erstmal gerade mal da rauskrabbeln. Ich habe halt irgendwie was mit Modems gemacht, also im Sinne von ich habe welche besessen und betrieben. Damals hieß das ja noch DFÜ, weil so Netz oder so, den Begriff so in der Form gab es jetzt nicht. Und ich wurde so von so Hamburger CCC-Kreisen zusammengefegt, weil die halt irgendwie Leute suchten. Und die Geschichte war halt, dass Use wollte halt in diesen Markt rein, klar, weil so 190er-Nummern kann man Geld verdienen. Und die sind ja, also man kann ja über die Pornoindustrie sagen, was man will, aber die sind mehrere Sachen, die die anderen so nicht sind. Erstens sind sie pfiffig, zweitens sind sie extrem innovationsfreudig, also sie akzeptieren Neues, also sie sind extrem neophil, im Gegensatz zum Rest, der ja tendenziell, wie wir ja mehrfach beklagen, eher neophobe eingestellt ist. Und was das geilste ist an der Pornoindustrie, die sind so, was ist denn überhaupt das richtige Wort dafür? Die sind so, die kratzt nix mehr. Siehste, die wissen einfach, welchen Ruf sie haben. Wenn die auf einer Party sagen, wo sie arbeiten, die haben schon alle Antworten gehört. Da stehen die komplett drüber und machen den einfach nisch. Die lächeln dann einfach nur und sagen so, sagen sich so. Wir wissen, was euch fehlt und damit verdienen wir unser Geld. Das ist auch so ein Aspekt, der mir dann halt erst sehr spät klar geworden ist, oder sagen wir mal in diesem Prozess dann klar geworden ist, was einfach so Porno-Läden so für Krawall-Potenzial binden. Stell dir mal vor, du würdest jetzt alle Porn-Shops, so wie dich, machen. Ist jetzt auch Internet, DuPorn und so weiter, ist jetzt anders. Aber denk dir mal einfach mal, ohne Internet, 90er Jahre, du machst einfach alle Sex-Shops zu. Das dauert doch einfach keine drei Tage und dann brennen die Mülltonnen und dann drehen einfach alle komplett frei, wenn die sich irgendwie nicht mehr weggebumst bekommen. Und darum kümmert sich irgendwie diese Porn-Industrie. Klar, da gibt es auch Ausreißer und man muss auch nicht alles geil finden, aber ich finde jetzt erst mal die Dienstleistung an sich einfach überhaupt nicht verwerflich, sondern die tut der Gesellschaft was Gutes. Und das hat dann eben auch zur Folge, dass wenn du jetzt mit denen über so Projekte redest, dass die halt einfach erstmal für alles offen sind. Weil die wollen genau das, was es noch nicht gibt. Die suchen nicht nach den ausgetretenen Pfaden, sondern die suchen nach hochstehendem Gras, wo man mal ordentlich mit der Machete durchgehen kann. Und da war das natürlich so für unsere kleine Nerd-Runde einfach fantastisch. Dann saßen wir da so in einer Kneipe mit so einem Vorstand von Use, der so für die neuen Technologien zuständig war. Die waren ja auch schon allerlei Sachen unterwegs, das war jetzt nicht komplett neu. Und haben halt erstmal rumgesponnen. Du kannst dir vorstellen, so Nerds, 90er Jahre, die wollten halt irgendwie Telefondienst haben. Was ist das erste, was einem einfällt? Na? Also es ging ja dann nicht drunter. Verstehst du, du machst ja nicht einfach so eine Willkommen auf dem Porno-Server, drücken sie eins, um irgendwie hier hinzugehen. So nein, wir haben dir dann gleich so richtig einen vom Pferd erzählt. Und Leute, wir bauen euch das geilste Ding hier. Rebabahn live und dann rennst du hier über die Straße und wirst irgendwie angesprochen und reingezogen. Und es geht einfach wild ab. Und Cyberspace und Räume und VR und irgendwie das volle Programm. Und die so, geil, mach mal. Kohle auf den Tisch gelegt, irgendwie die Firma gegründet. Wir konnten uns irgendwie dicke Rechnerkofen hinsetzen, abgehängt so. Und erst mal ein Jahr lang nur geforscht und nur Kram gekauft, Technologien eingekauft. Irgendwie in Usis Privatjet durch Europa geflogen, irgendwie die ganzen Firmen besucht. Es war einfach, war, ging, also, ich hätte eine schlechtere Zeit gehabt.
Das war schon wirklich ziemlich lustig. War das dot.com, wie heißt das, Blase 05 oder was?
Ja, das war, gab es nicht. Also, das war, also im Prinzip war das ein Start-up. Heute würde man das Start-up nennen. Die haben da halt irgendwie so einen 6-stelligen Betrag investiert. Also für heutige Verhältnisse noch verhältnismäßig moderat, weil wir waren dann immerhin so, was weiß ich, 10, 12, 15 Leute so. Und haben uns da halt so eine kleine, kleine 2-Etagen-Firma dahingebaut mit eigenem Turnstudio. Wo dann lustigerweise, um dann sozusagen während dieser ganzen Burn, Money-Burn-Phase, um so ein bisschen Kohle reinzuholen, liefen dann halt auch immer so Porno-Produktionen da drin. Das war natürlich besonders lustig, weil wir saßen dann immer so in dem einen Raum daneben und programmierten uns da irgendwie so was, so weißt du, so vom Halbcomputer sitze ich hier, programmiere die Zukunft mir. War aber Sommer, Fenster auf, irgendwie im Turnstudio auch, so aus dem Dachbarraum und... Ah, ja, ah, ja, und jetzt noch mal. Und ich saß da und dachte mir so, ich hatte schon schlechtere Jobs. Also, das hat mir alles total Spaß gemacht und es war einfach voll locker und du kannst halt mit diesen Leuten irgendwie auch ordentlich reden. Ja, worüber wollten wir eigentlich reden? Ach ja, über Pornindustrie. Das war halt so mein Ding. So, und dann haben wir natürlich nicht Reeperbahn live gemacht, sondern kam halt die Villa daraus, war noch viel lustiger und eigentlich waren sich die ganzen Pornogramme ja auch ziemlich egal, weil auf Dauer ist das dann halt auch ein bisschen, fehlt da so ein bisschen die intellektuelle Herausforderung. Aber am Ende haben wir ja diesen Cyberspace auch gebaut. Und im Prinzip, das ist mir dann so später klar geworden, so die Villa, war im Prinzip Facebook über Telefon. Also da gab es alles, was du bei Facebook auch hast. Ja, es gab so Foren und es gab Mail und es gab Instant-Messaging. Das war alles da. Also es fehlte eigentlich an nichts. Du konntest irgendwie offline sein, hast dich eingeloggt, kriegst jetzt deine Nachrichten präsentiert. Das System hat sogar Push-Notifications, weil du konntest irgendwie mit dem Fahrstuhl in den Keller fahren. Und dann war irgendwie in dem einen Kellerraum stand noch eine Telefonzelle. Und wenn du irgendwie so einen gewissen User-Level erreicht hast, dann konntest du in diese Telefonzelle gehen, die benutzen dort eine Telefonnummer von jemandem wählen und dann hat das System denjenigen zuhause angerufen, so mit Hallo, hier ist die Villa, heute kommst du kostenlos rein. Ich könnte da noch stundenlang drüber reden, aber das machen wir jetzt nicht.
Wir waren eigentlich bei Letty.
Also jetzt kennt mich die Welt, Letty, Porn, neu.
Ich hab doch jetzt hier Porn gemacht, du hast das doch hier nur angedeutet. Du bist ja eigentlich in ganz anständigen Tätigkeiten unterwegs.
Ja, ganz anständig bin ich ja. Das ist richtig.
Du bist ja so eine Visualisierung.
Tante, genau. Ich finde Tante auch völlig in Ordnung. Also es ist nicht abwertend, finde ich.
Okay, dann bist du eine Visualisierungstante. Was heißt das genau?
Ja, eigentlich gar nichts. Was heißt das? Das, womit ich mich hauptsächlich beschäftige, sind eigentlich Daten. Und was sagen mir Daten oder was sagen uns Daten? Wie kann ich das, was in Daten steckt, versteckt in Zahlen und Zusammenhänge untereinander, in irgendeiner Weise repräsentieren, ich nenne es mal einfach in einem Diagramm? Wie kann ich diese Zusammenhänge so bereitstellen, dass der nächste mit den Zusammenhängen wieder arbeiten kann, als Beispiel? Da bin ich so tätig. Es geht von langweiligen Sachen an Daten, wo man sich erst denkt, ey, das hört sich spannend an und dann ist nichts drin. Das geht aber auch in den Medizinbereich. Ich habe früher mal ein bisschen für Medizinsachen was gemacht, Zusammenhänge mit Diabetes.
Also mehr so Analyse?
Ja, Visualisierung kann mehr sein als nur die Analyse. Es kann Analyse sein, es kann der Weg zur Analyse sein für so einen Wissenschaftler, dass es ein bisschen wie so ein Explorationstool ist.
Um sozusagen aus der Visualisierung überhaupt erst zu sehen, wo sind die interessanten Bereiche, wo man mal reingucken will und da dann genauer nachgeschaut wird.
Wo kann man gezielt auch Thesen dann aufstellen, um noch mal Sachen zu prüfen in seinen Daten, wenn man medizinische Studien als Beispiel macht.
Was war da so?
Ich krieg das nicht mehr zusammen. Ich hab in meiner Masterarbeit, glaube ich, es ging um den Zusammenhang von Diabetes-Menschen mit, ich weiß nicht mehr, was das zweite war. Da gab es einen Zusammenhang mit Diabetes und einer anderen Krankheit. Man hat im Prinzip bei der Visualisierung dann gesehen, es gibt zwei Gruppen und wie unterscheiden sich diese zwei Gruppen, Personengruppen voneinander und worin sind sie sich ähnlich? Das hab ich in der Masterarbeit größtenteils gemacht. Dass man Gruppen hat, die geclustert sind als Beispiel, also Clustering oder Klassifizierung ist ja so ein typisches Szenario in Daten, um, ich sag mal, in Gruppen aufzuteilen. Einmal Clustering wirklich mit einem Algorithmus und Klassifizierung ist meistens mehr so durch Fachwissen von einem Arzt, wo du das mitbestimmen kannst. Ich habe das dann so ein bisschen untersucht, wie kann man so Eigenschaften von Gruppen visualisieren. Also ganz banal, wo ist denn der Schwerpunkt der Gruppe, in welchem Bereich liegt der? Und wenn du dann mehrere Merkmale in einem Datensatz hast, kannst du eben halt zum Beispiel sehen, okay, Merkmal 1 und Merkmal 2 gehen so stark von den anderen Gruppen weg, also dass man wirklich sagen kann, okay, diese Merkmale sind so Alleinstellungsmerkmale für zum Beispiel eine Krankheit. Das kann man so sehen. Ja, Medizin ist ein Bereich, also eigentlich hat man das ja überall, dass man so visualisieren kann. Das klassische ist ja auch irgendwie eine Karte, ist ja auch irgendwie eine Visualisierung, die Repräsentation der Welt auf einem Stück Papier oder im Internet. Maps, genau.
Eine Tortendiagramme ist ja auch schon eine Visualisierung, oder?
Ist auch schon eine Visualisierung.
Da fängt es ja ganz unten an, wo die Leute verstehen wollen.
Balkendiagramme, klassisch. Punktwolken gehen auch schon ein bisschen ins Abstraktere bei vielen Balkendiagramme und Tortendiagramme sind so wirklich der Standard. Womit viele Leute schon so die meisten Anforderungen gefüllt abgedeckt haben, weil es natürlich auch immer so ein bisschen drauf ankommt, wer ist denn die Zielgruppe für deine Visualisierung. Also so einen typischen Arzt kannst du mit ein paar Sachen mehr überfordern als jetzt den geneigten Zeitungsleser, wo du so ein bisschen einfacher einfach eine Visualisierung aufarbeiten musst und vielleicht am Anfang einfach und danach gehst du in einen Abstraktionslevel, nimmst die aber mit, indem du es fortlaufend irgendwie erklärst, warum du das jetzt so abstrahierst. Ja, Hoke hat eine schöne Visualisierung offen. Die liebe ich ja sehr.
Ja, die liebe ich auch. Da dachte ich mir nämlich gerade, dass du wahrscheinlich da auch Fan von bist. Da gibt es nämlich ja so den Gott der Visualisierung, etwa Tafti. Ich pack mal den Link in den Slack-Chat, den du gerade nicht am scrollen hast.
Ja, scrollt der überhaupt irgendwie?
Ja, da unten scrollt es. Klickt mal da drauf. Das hatte ich bestimmt ja auch schon mal aufgemacht. Der Edward Tafti, der hat so ein paar coole Visualisierungen gemacht. Das ist zum Beispiel eine Visualisierung von Napoleons Russland-Feldzug, der zum einen die Truppenstärke auf dem Hinweg und auf dem Rückweg mit Zeitachse und sozusagen geografischen Merkmalen in eine Grafik, die leicht zu überschauen ist, sozusagen verbindet oder ist. Die wird nicht größer, glaube ich. Die Grafik leider. Ich habe gerade das erste genommen, was ich auf Google gefunden habe.
Die gibt es leider nicht in wirklich richtig groß und schön aufgelöst. Das ist echt schade.
Ja, außer im Buch wahrscheinlich, aber da dann auch nur schön aufgelöst und nicht groß. Und er hat halt so ein paar fette Bücher gemacht, wo er halt so ganz viel über so Informationsdesign schreibt und so Beispiel. Da gibt es zum Beispiel eine Sache von ihm, fände ich auch richtig gut, so ein Fahrplan, so ein Zugfahrplan, wo man halt alle möglichen Dimensionen von einem Zugnetz sieht. Ich probiere das mal zu finden. Ja, genau, der ist halt auch der Klassiker hier. Warte mal, da gibt es ein relativ großes, ich glaube, das hatte ich ja auch schon mal erwähnt, aber ich packe es auch noch mal in Slack. Der sieht halt, guck mal, da Tim links unten gerade war, auf dem Schirm. Der sieht halt erstmal auf dem ersten Blick total, hä, aus. Was soll das denn für ein Zeitplan sein?
Sieht so ein bisschen aus wie ein Schnittmusterbogen.
Genau, aber du hast halt sozusagen die Station und du hast die Zeiten und dann mit den Linien sozusagen kannst du sehen, welcher Zug wann in welche Richtung fährt und wann er wo ist sozusagen. Und das halt einmal in einem Rechteck visualisiert.
Wow, wie cool ist denn das? Das heißt, du siehst auch schon an der schräge Linie, wie schnell er ist und so.
Der hat wirklich so einige Diagramme, wo man so draufhängt und sagt, wow. Da hat man nachgedacht. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob das jetzt von ihm ist oder ob er das einfach nur in diesem Buch zitiert, aber ich habe das aus dem Buch sozusagen. Es kann auch sein, dass er das als Beispiel sozusagen für seine Informationsvisualisierungstheorie sozusagen mit hernimmt. Auf jeden Fall gibt es von diesem Edward Tufty oder Tuft gibt es ein Buch, das ist so mit diesen ganzen Knallern drin. Das heißt, das kann ich auch noch schnell rauswählen für die, die so was interessiert. Edward Tuft ist aber auch nicht ganz billig.
Wenn man gerade in den USA ist, sollte man sie sich daholen.
Ich glaube, genau hier Visual Display of Quantitive Information.
Man kann ja auch sehr viel schummeln, wenn man so Sachen visualisiert, oder? Wenn man zum Beispiel, also jetzt so ganz simple Sachen, damit man versteht, wenn man so Balkendiagramme benutzt, dann sieht man ja zum Beispiel nicht, wie die Verteilung ist, was man bei einer Torte viel besser sehen würde. Und da kann man ja halt schon auch manipulieren. Wenn man nicht möchte, dass man dieses Verteilung gut sieht, nimmt man halt eben Balkendiagramme. Und der Leser sieht gar nicht, wie die Verteilung ist. Und man kann es halt auch eben genau andersrum machen.
Ja, genau. Es kommt immer so ein bisschen drauf an, ja auch mit dem Schwerpunkt. Verteilung sieht man, kann man schon sehen beim Balkendiagramm. Aber, also Histogramm ist ja auch eigentlich nur ein Balkendiagramm. Und da kann man auch eine Verteilung von Klassen irgendwie ganz gut sehen. Aber was natürlich ein großer Fakt ist, wenn man bei einem Rechteck bleibt, worauf beziehst du den Wert eines Merkmals, also das Value, ziehst du das in die Höhe? Also du musst halt diesen Flächeninhalt immer mit berücksichtigen. Du kannst halt mit dem Flächeninhalt ganz schnell lügen. Das gibt es in der Werbung häufiger.
Manchmal zeigen die ja auch nur die Spitze oben und lassen den nicht bei Null und Anfang. Sondern die alle Werte im Bereich zwischen 80 und 100 irgendwie bewegen. Aber bei 70 erst das Anfang, weil sie halt nicht den langen Balken zeigen wollen. Und dann ist auch nicht so richtig klar, dass sie eigentlich ganz dicht beieinander liegen, weil die liegen dann natürlich weit auseinander, weil sie nur den Bereich zeigen.
Ja, nein, da ist es halt so, wenn man so einen Achsencut macht, kann es schon sinnvoll sein, wenn es wirklich um diese minimalen Unterschiede geht, dass man sie mit rein nimmt. Aber man muss halt diesen Achsencut immer mit berücksichtigen. Und das ist halt superschwer, einem Nutzer das klarzumachen, dass, ey, ich hab grad die Achse so manipuliert, dass es so aussieht, als wäre da ein riesen Unterschied dabei. Eigentlich will ich dir nur zeigen, dieser riesen Unterschied. Genau, es ist eigentlich nur nah rangezoomt. Es ist von den Werten her vielleicht kein großer Unterschied, aber ich weiß nicht, wenn du irgendwie im Physikbereich bist oder Chemiebereich bist und Reaktionszeiten siehst, sind diese kleinen Unterschiede schon interessant.
Ja, aber wenn jetzt der normale User draußen guckt sich ja nicht Physik oder sonst was ein, sondern dann geht es ja meistens um Wahlen oder um Marktgrößen oder Verkaufszahlen oder weiß nicht, was man sich so anguckt.
Der Klassiker ist halt auch so, dass diese Skalierung halt nicht wirklich proportional zu einer anderen ist. Man nennt das Live-Faktor, wenn du das dann quasi ausrechnest, wie groß der Flächeninhalt von zwei Kreisen ist. Und die sagen halt so, ja, das ist doppelt so groß wie der andere. Und dabei ist es aber nicht doppelt so groß, sondern die haben es erst mal so drei, viermal so groß gemacht. Damit kann man dann auch so lügen, ja.
Oder halt Werbung, die wahrscheinlich auch ganz viel in den Sachen visualisieren, die so gar nicht so richtig stimmen, die vielleicht stimmen, aber die optisch gesehen einen ganz anderen Eindruck hinterlassen.
Da ist mir noch was aufgefallen, welche Visualisierung ich ja ganz großartig fand. Und es ist auch so ein bisschen der Einstieg gewesen ist, warum ich Visualisierung wunderbar finde. Es wird morbide. Nein, es wird morbide. Es geht um tote Menschen. Ich mag ja tote Menschen. Sind sie mir auch am liebsten?
Die quatschen nicht immer dazwischen, ne?
Die quatschen nicht dazwischen. Sie kann man auch ins Regal stehen und gut dekorieren.
Da könnte ja Facebook irgendwann noch mal interessant werden, weil es mehr Profile von toten Leuten gibt, als von Lebenden. Das wäre natürlich eine Schweinerei.
Es gibt eine Visualisierung von Hamburg über die Cholera. In Hamburg gab es 1892 die letzte größere Cholera-Epidemie. Sie haben die Cholera-Toten auf einer Karte lokalisiert, weil sie nicht wussten. Sie dachten, warum sterben so viele weg? Die haben den Grund nicht rausgefunden und haben das auf einer Karte dargestellt. Sie sind dann zu dem Schuss gekommen, dass die Trinkwasserquelle war. Da haben sie sich noch nicht so drum geschert, mal die Filterung für Wasser einzuführen. Die haben direkt das Wasser aus der Elbe genommen. Das war dann der Grund. Sie haben das auf einer Karte dargestellt. Auf einmal hat man gesehen, die sind nicht ohne Grund hops gegangen, sondern mit Wasser. Das war mein Einstieg in die Visualisierung. Ich finde leider, das Internet ist hier irgendwie so ein bisschen...
Fragwürdig.
Fragwürdig, ja. Das ist leider nur eine wahnsinnig kleine Visualisierung, aber ich sollte vielleicht in dieses Slack-Ding benutzen, damit ich Sachen reinpush.
Ja, das solltest du. Wir können ja auch gleich mal drüber reden. Jetzt wollte ich dich das erst mal so ein bisschen einführen hier.
Ja, Letty von Datenvisualisierung.
Also ich bin noch nicht bereit, das Thema aufzugeben.
Du kannst doch hier die URL eintippen.
Du kannst ja einfach mal sagen, wo sie da draufklicken muss, dann kannst du dir da selber eine Invitation klicken. Wann hast du eigentlich angefangen damit?
Zu coden oder zu visualisieren?
Sowohl.
Coden weiß ich gar nicht so richtig genau. Irgendwann kurz vor dem Abi so ein bisschen intensiver, also so mit 16. Mein Bruder hat mir das halt wahnsinnig zeitig irgendwie schon mal gezeigt. So mit 14 meinte er irgendwie, man kann mit so einem Hefter nach Hause, wo noch so Code irgendwie geschrieben auf Papier, das sah man halt dann früher mal so, gezeigt hat. Und ich meinte so, hey, was ist das denn? Das sieht ja etwas strange aus. Und er so, ey, damit kannst du dem Rechner sagen, was er tun soll. Genau, das war so der erste Einstieg. Hab's dann aber nie wirklich so selber lernt, weiterverfolgt. Hab's so systematisch, würde ich sagen, erst so richtig im Studium gelernt. Da hatte ich eine ziemlich coole Professore und die hat so Basics gemacht. Ein Jahr war zwei Semester lang, also ein Semester. Das war ziemlich gut. Da war ein guter Einstieg, um alles dann doch mal im Detail genauer zu verstehen, als wenn man sich selbst lernt, die Sachen beizubringen, was irgendwie geht. Es war aber, ich find, irgendwann bist du an so einem Punkt, du brauchst so ein bisschen Input von jemanden, der das wirklich auf einem höheren Level kann als du. Und das war halt an der Uni. Ah, okay, als erstes war ich an der Fachhochschule, muss man dazu sagen. Was ich für Informatik natürlich, wenn man, sage ich mal, mehr Richtung, ich will in die Wirtschaft eh gehen will, total cool finde, weil du an der Uni wirklich Projekte hast. Du musst coden, du musst es ständig anwenden und wirst auch, wenn du eine gute Professorin, einen guten Professor hast, auch ständig dafür bestraft, wenn du Scheiße baust. Also wirklich mit Punktabzug wie du. Hast du das nicht alles schön formatiert? Da kannst du das noch mal machen. Das war eigentlich richtig streng bei meiner Professorin, aber ich fand das ziemlich gut. Das ist halt so ein bisschen die Besonderheit, glaube ich, an der Fachhochschule, weil ich kenne andere, die an der Uni am Anfang waren. Was die so manchmal auch wegprogrammieren, da wird die Angst und Bange. Das ist dann nicht so schön.
Das haben wir ja auch, oder stelle ich eigentlich auch immer wieder fest, also Informatik an der Uni studieren, das ist, wenn man den akademischen Pfad gehen will. Und Fachhochschule ist auf jeden Fall schon deutlich praxisnah. Naja, ich habe ganz oft, hatte ich ja schon mal erzählt, ganz oft den Eindruck, dass ganz viele Informatik studieren, weil sie sonst vielleicht nicht wissen, was sie tun sollen, und Computer und so ist ja zukunftssicher. Wir machen das jetzt mal. Ich habe so viele Bewerber da schon in der Firma gehabt, die nichts weiter gemacht haben, außer die Uni-Aufgaben, und da hast du so gefragt, wie ist euer GitHub-Account? Oder so. Was? Ja, machst du irgendetwas außerhalb der Uni mit dem Computer? So, äh, nee. Und dann weißt du halt einfach, das kann nix werden, ne? Das kann nix werden.
Das ist echt schlimm.
Ich finde das total furchtbar, dass Leute Informatik studieren, weil sie sonst nichts besseres wissen.
Das war ja früher so, wo die ganzen Nerds halt dann irgendwie sich dachten, na ist klar, ich bin Nerd, also studiere ich Informatik.
Ja, also mein Bruder hat mir zum Beispiel, ich mein halt auch irgendwann nicht so, hey, ich werd Informatik studieren, er guckt mich halt echt so an und meint so, du weißt schon, dass da ganz andere dran gescheitert sind. Und das hat er mir halt clip und klar von Anfang gesagt, dass das nichts irgendwie ist, was du im Vorbeigehen machst, sondern hinsetzen, coden. Das ist ja der Vorteil an der Pharroschule. Ich hab vom Mathe immer so tierische Angst gehabt. In der Pharroschule, ich, mich da auch echt durchkämpfen müssen. Ich hatte nur zwei Semester, also das, was Uni wahrscheinlich ein Semester ist. Und fand das sehr, sehr schwierig, weil ich, ich verstehe die Notation nicht. Zeigt mir Pseudo-Code, was dieses Ding, sie da darstellt, diese Formel. Und ich kann damit was anfangen. Zeigt mir die Formel und ich denk mir so, das sieht gut aus. Das ist nicht meine Notation.
Das ist auch wirklich, zum Beispiel, immer wenn man mal glücklicherweise so zur Abwechslung mal ein Paper lesen darf, weil man jetzt zum Beispiel unseren Schlumpfbeeren spielen im Backend, da kommt das halt selten vor, dass man wirklich ein komplexes Problem lösen muss. Aber hin und wieder gibt es so Sachen, wo man so denkt, das hat bestimmt schon mal jemand. Und wir haben in Teams, habe ich zum Beispiel auch einen Kollegen, der studiert gerade Informatik und der ist irgendwie total drin und irgendwie auch theoretische Informatik und so weiter. Und ich denke mir immer so, kannst du mal kurz auf dieses Paper gucken, was die da schreiben und wie die diesen Algorithmus beschreiben. Also ich schalte ab einfach. Das ist so, das ist immer so hochtrabend formuliert. Und wir hatten zum Beispiel einen Algorithmus zum nearest neighbor-finder, also für Matchmaking. Also gegen wen soll ich jetzt spielen als nächstes und wer ist so am nächsten an mir dran levelmäßig und verschiedene Kategorien. So und dann ein Paper gefunden von 1900 Schieß mich tot 69 oder so, was das halt alles total effizient und performant löst. Aber die Beschreibung, keine Ahnung, ich hab echt so das gelesen, ich hab schon viel gehackt und dachte mir so, ich weiß nicht mal, wo ich anfangen soll. Hab dann direkt gesucht, ob es irgendeine C oder sonst was Implementierung gibt. Dann hat der Kollege auch drauf geguckt und meinte auch so, er hat so richtig dann auch erst mal abgeflucht über diese Akademiker, ey. Pass auf, also hier, guck mal, dieser Zellcode, das sind am Ende 20 Zeilen und in R lang schreiben, haben wir das dann im Ende wirklich in 15 Zeilen geschrieben. Und das ist halt so zwei Seiten, dichtestes Element Gamma, wenn P gleich eins, und hast du nicht gesehen, dann wird aber geredet und geredet und geredet und geredet. Und mir geht's wirklich ganz ähnlich. Also ganz oft sind so diese hochtrabenden akademischen Formulierungen, was auch immer und so weiter. Ich komm da nicht mit. Sei froh, dass du nichts anderes nimmst.
Ja, ich hab, ich hab...
Deine Dedogenerator-Library.
Und ja, meine Seite ist an der Construction seit mehreren Jahren. Ja, wer eine fertige Webseite hat, der hat einfach keine Hobbys.
Auf jeden Fall, ja, Pseudocode ist geiler.
Ja, hab jetzt aber witzigerweise irgendwann einen Paper gelesen von Finkelstein. Wie ist der so? Ah, irgendwie sowas. Ja, der hat, ähm, der hat, ähm... War er das? Der hat so ein bisschen Vordenken für Curry geleistet, für diese Curry-Programmierung auch so. Und ich hab mir das nochmal durchgelesen über, ähm... Es war so auch mehr theoretische Informatik, aber auch so Mathematik-Bausteine. Und das hab ich dann in der Tat verstanden, weil ich mir halt viele Sachen, zum Beispiel aus der Funktional- oder Programmierung in JavaScript halt weiß, was das bedeutet. Ja, weiß einfach, was das bedeutet, wenn da irgendwie diese Funktions-Aufrufe und so weiter stehen und konnte ich mir das dann so ein bisschen herleiten. War ich aber ein bisschen stolz, dass ich dann doch irgendwann mal angefangen hab, die Mathematik zu verstehen.
Genau. Also es geht halt auch, je öfter man es macht, desto mehr bleibt dann halt jedes Mal hängen. Aber die Lernkurve, also wenn man so denkt, ach, geil, ein Paper, was genau mein Problem beschreibt und dann liest man so die ersten drei Absätze und denkt so, äh... Ja, im besten Fall schläft man ein, ja.
Nicht ein Händchen für.
Aber das ist halt das Schöne am Internet. Früher hat man halt in irgendwelchen Bibliotheken oder so vielleicht noch irgendwie so eine Beschreibung gefunden oder sich die RFCs oder was auch immer bestellt. Oder den Standard. Und jetzt kann man halt auf GitHub einfach nach genau diesem Ding suchen und findet halt dann zumindest mal eine Java oder C-Implementierung, wo man sich ein bisschen was abspicken kann. Ja, Vortragen ist auch eine heiße Übung. Für mich als High-Level-Spracheprogrammierer in den alten Papers ist ja dann ganz oft so Vortragen noch drin. Das ist auch kein einfaches Stück Arbeit. Naja, aber kann man trotzdem empfehlen, diese Papers zu studieren.
Ja, es gibt sehr gute Papers. Ich glaube, das mit dem Slack funktioniert nicht oder das Internet will nicht.
Wir können ja mal auf das Thema zu sprechen kommen, weil eigentlich wollten wir das sowieso ziemlich am Anfang bedingsen.
Das Internet bedingsen?
Ja, also wir haben die Meta-Ebene hier am Start, wie ihr ja alle wisst, und wir machen Freak Show live, und es gibt irgendwie NSFW live, und ab und zu gibt es vielleicht auch mal irgendwas anderes live, aber derzeit halt nicht. Und das Ganze wurde ja immer sehr gewogen begleitet, vor allem im IRC, also im Internet Relay Chat, der alte, der gute alte IRC, den es schon seit gefühlt, ich weiß nicht, seit wann gibt es einen IRC eigentlich? Ja, aber immer gab es das nicht, Anfang der 90er oder so.
Als ich im Internet war, und das war so 1996, 97, 97 vielleicht eher, da gab es das alles schon, ja.
Ja, aber das ist ja schon...
Das ist ja schon die Postmoderne des Internets.
Ja, da war ja schon alles gelaufen.
Stand das? Das RFC ist von 1993.
Ja, genau.
Und bis das rauskommt, dauert es auch eine Weile.
Ja, also Anfang der 90er Jahre. Also ich kenne auf jeden Fall noch die Zeit ohne. Und dann lief das halt irgendwie alles auf Mailboxen ab. Aber auch da waren Chats eigentlich schon immer eigentlich das Ding, weil die halt einfach am wenigsten Overhead hatten für Leute, die reden miteinander. Also so Mail gab es zwar auch, aber das war irgendwie alles noch so eine zähe Nummer. Und man wollte ja auch relativ schnell zu rande kommen in so einer Mailbox. Bevor man sich dann durch diese ganzen Foren durchgelesen hat und also stundenlang online war und so einen Port belegt hat. Weil die Mailbox ja vielleicht nur einen Modem hatte oder zwei. Also ab dem Moment, wo dann überhaupt quasi die Realität so war, dass mehrere Leute gleichzeitig online sein konnten an einem System, fing das irgendwie relativ schnell an mit der ganzen Chatterei. Auch unter Unix, da war das ja dann mit diesem Multi-User eigentlich von Anfang an irgendwie dabei. Und damals hat man ja auch so auf Security noch soweit geschissen, dass man einfach so, gab es dieses geile Kommando, Talk. Ist das Talk noch? Oder einfach im Prinzip dem anderen so aufs Terminal schreibt. Und dann macht der da so das Blitz-Screen und oben schreibt der eine und unten schreibt der andere. Und das ist natürlich total Tüfte gewesen, weil das halt einfach... Ja, es war halt einfach immediate so. Und man merkte einfach, dass das irgendwie... dass das irgendwie zog. Und dann gab es halt so verschiedenste Auswüchse davon und das eine war halt IRC und das andere war ja dann relativ bald auch ICQ und dann AEM und diese ganzen Geschichten. Ich find das immer so lustig, diese Messenger sind so für meinen Geschmack... Also Chat und Messenger sind für meinen Geschmack irgendwie immer unterbewertet. Also man tendierte dazu, das immer nicht so ernst zu nehmen und dann war eine große Mehrheit dann später immer total überrascht, wie das so abging. Also ICQ zum Beispiel auch. Ist ja so ein israelisches Start-up gewesen, die das gestartet haben. Ich suche dich, ICQ. Und brach irgendwie alle Rekorde im Netz. Alle haben das irgendwie benutzt. Auf einmal so Instant Messaging was the thing. Und dann ist ja dann AOL da eingestiegen mit ihrem Instant Messager, also AEM. Und dann war erstmal wieder so ein bisschen Ruhe da drum. Hattest du den Eindruck?
Gab noch den MSN-Messager?
Die MSN kam dann auch noch mal ins Boot. Also alle haben dann so sein Ding gemacht. Genau, Yahoo auch noch. Also jeder hat so seinen eigenen Scheiß gemacht mit dem üblichen Problem, dass dann wieder nicht über die Grenzen hinweg konnte. Da hat man auch schon diesen Network-Effekt schon mal früh miterleben können. Und dann mit Mobile gab es ja dann noch mal so diese zweite Explosion mit WhatsApp und mit, wie sie alle heißen.
In der Zwischenzeit war aber schon noch Jabba kam ja dann.
Ja, aber Jabba war dann halt wieder so Slow Response der Nerds. Ich meine, Jabba hat es einfach nie geschafft, wirklich so... Da hast du einfach keine kreischenden Teenager gehabt. Die sich irgendwie ihre Jabba crowns.
Ja, einerseits, andererseits.
Aber von durchschlagendem Erfolg kann man da an der Stelle nicht sprechen. Das hast du ja auch gesehen, dass Google zum Beispiel anfangs ja durchaus auch auf diesen Jabba-Zug aufgesprungen ist, auf Facebook und das alle wieder verlassen haben. Schlicht und ergreifend.
Apple auch eigentlich, oder? War ja auch Jabba-based oder nicht?
Richtig, auch iChat war mal Jabba-based.
Dass das so verteilt ist, ist ja eigentlich schon cool, weil es eben jetzt nicht mehr irgendwie gehört und die das abschalten können, sondern die ganzen Server arbeiten halt zusammen.
Ja gut, das ist der Traum der Föderation, dieser ganzen Dienste, die aber einfach das Problem hat, dass du dann einfach dieses Standards und die Anforderungen einfach nicht schnell genug weiterentwickelt bekommst, weil im Prinzip die komplette Föderation mitmarschieren muss und du kriegst dann halt einfach keine Features rein. Und die Feature-Welle war natürlich enorm. Also die Nachfrage nach Features in Chat war groß. Wie man das jetzt auch sieht, hier mit Gruppenchats und Verstößlungen.
Ob das immer so gut ist, Featuretis zu betreiben, ich bin mir nicht...
Ja, Featuretis ist das eine, aber bestimmte Features eröffnen ja überhaupt erst die nächste Welle im Markt. Also dann kriegst du halt auch erst mal wieder eine Nachfrage. Also allein, wie lange das jetzt gedauert hat, bis diese ganzen Messenger auch mal mit Gruppen ordentlich umgehen können und dann mit Offline umgehen konnten. Und mit irgendwie wann speicherst du was, wann überträgst du das mit Notifications und so weiter. Also ich hab so das Gefühl, jetzt sind wir... Pfeiltransfer.
So was wie ein Whiteboard auch zu haben, das hatte der MSN Chat zum Schluss relativ gut. So eine Art Whiteboard gehabt, du konntest dann kollaborativ...
Rummalen.
Rummalen. Ich meine, das ist ziemlich praktisch, wenn man ein Meeting hat, wo zwei Leute nicht am selben Platz sitzen.
Genau, und daran kann man eigentlich schön absehen, dass eigentlich der Chat irgendwie extrem gut dafür geeignet ist, um die Basis zu bilden, und darauf setzt du dann Dinge auf. Also man hat ja über verschiedenste Sachen immer versucht, Sachen zu integrieren. Ich erinnere nur hier Google Wave und so weiter, die dann halt wieder alles im Browser machen wollten. Aber der Browser hat so mit Kollaboration und so, da hat sich auch noch nie so richtig was durchgesetzt. Jetzt geht das wieder los mit WebRTC und Videokonferencing. Und auch da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob das wirklich diese kritische Masse erreichen wird. Oder ob sich das nicht dann doch lieber wieder in anderen Apps abspielt. Und vor allem, ob es sich nicht in Apps abspielt, deren Kernfunktion erstmal der Chat ist. Das ist immer die Frage, so machst du was? Und dann ist der Chat noch so dabei. Skype zum Beispiel ist ja im Prinzip als Telefonie-App in den Markt getreten. Das war das Kernfeature. Aber der Skype-Chat hat das Ding eigentlich erst so richtig nützlich gemacht. Viele benutzen Skype dann auch, oder haben zumindest bis vor kurzem Skype, vor allem als Chat benutzt. Ich auch. Ich bin auch sehr oft gewechselt. Vor gar nicht so langer Zeit war auch Skype so ein bisschen das Zentrum der ganzen Diskussion. Ich hab ja gerade das Problem, wenn ich so alleine arbeite und immer so, wie wir das hier halt, gut, hocke ich jetzt gerade nicht so, aber Dennis, du auch Letty, wir sind immer so in Netzwerken. Wir haben so ganz viele Projekte, wo wir irgendwie irgendeine Rolle spielen und wo wir so lose Mitleuten in Verbindung bleiben müssen und wo, wenn die Kommunikation stattfindet, dann soll sie auch schnell und effizient sein und mit möglichst wenig Reibungsenergie und soll nicht verloren gehen und soll irgendwie suchbar sein, soll irgendwie sinnvoll zu benutzen sein, muss sich irgendwie integrieren. Und da sind halt einfach solche Chats wunderbar. Und vor allem so Chats, die eben auch solche Team-Modelle gut abbilden, sind da eben auch sehr praktisch. Und da ist es dann wieder so bei Skype schon wieder auch irgendwie komisch gewesen, weil dann machst du deine Kanäle und dann weißt du wieder nicht, wo muss jetzt noch ein Client laufen, damit deine Nachrichten nicht irgendwie im Nirwana landen oder doch wieder zurückgesynkt werden und dann geht es irgendwie nicht und weißt nicht, wer hat das jetzt wie wann. Also all diese ganze Klumpatsch. Und auch die ganzen anderen Messenger, die sich jetzt so weiterentwickeln, man merkt einfach, wie die sich alle gegenseitig so die Features rauben, um irgendwie in diesem Bereich voranzukommen. Naja, so. Und ich hab natürlich dieses Problem hier denn auch. Also was heißt Problem? Wenn man so einen Podcast macht, dann ist es ja wichtig, das sozusagen nicht alleine zu machen, indem man einfach irgendwo reinspricht und irgendwo fällt es im Internet raus und das war's. Sondern das ist ja ein extrem dialogischer und interaktiver Prozess. Und auch da fand ich halt Chat irgendwie eigentlich ganz interessant, aber es hat halt bisher immer nur so auf wenige Leute skaliert, weil wenn ich jetzt irgendwie anfange mit, ja, chat mit mir auf Skype oder so, dann wirst du ja bekloppt bei. Du kriegst das einfach irgendwie nicht gebündelt. Na ja, da hatte ich ja jetzt vor einiger Zeit, das ist jetzt ein paar Monate her, glaube ich, dass wir Slack hier glaube ich schon mal als Thema hatten, dann habe ich das einfach mal so vorgestellt, weil mir das eben sehr gut gefiel und ich habe das irgendwie nicht nur nicht aus dem Auge verloren, sondern ich habe extrem viel mit Slack gemacht. Ich habe also wirklich diverse Projekte, wo das zum Einsatz kam und dann dachte ich mir so dieses Irr, das ist auch irgendwie, ich meine, das ist zwar alles gut gemeint, aber das entwickelt sich einfach mal echt nicht vorwärts. Das ist eigentlich das, was mir so am meisten daran stört. Das ist gerade so bei diesen Internet-Standards, das siehst du auch bei E-Mail, auch bei Java, das ist dann mal irgendwann so auf so einen bestimmten Scope hin spezifiziert worden und standardisiert worden und auch irgendwie implementiert worden und danach hast du einfach nur so naja, jedes Jahr wird es um 1% besser. Gefühlt, wenn überhaupt. Und dann stehst du da und denkst dir so.
Auch wenn ein bisschen Usability-Kompromisse in Kauf zu nehmen, um vielleicht andere Werte, also du hast halt immer so wie beim Cap Theoremen hier bei den Datenbanken, es gibt so ein Dreieck mit so drei Properties und du kannst dir nur zwei davon aussuchen. Und es gibt durchaus Fälle, zum Beispiel hier gerade im Uni-Kontext, ist immer die Frage, ja, wir können zwar im Prinzip alles mit Google machen, aber wir wollen politisch und auch aus innerer Überzeugung nicht unsere personenbezogene Daten aus unserem Uni-Betrieb usw. bei Google in Amerika abgeben. Und dann sagt man denen halt auch so, ja, okay, das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal eine korrekte Ansage, aber dann müsste er halt in den Apfel-Kommasauer beißen und kriegt halt jetzt ein bisschen schlechtere Usability. Aber das nehmen die dann in dem Fall auch gerne in Kauf. Und prinzipiell, wenn man immer nur sagen würde, ja, ist mir zu viel anstrengend und ich will mich jetzt nicht mit diesen Problemen da rumschlagen müssen, dann würden wir halt alle jetzt nur so...
Übrigens, der alte Irk Channel ist noch voll. Ja, da geht es auch noch voll ab. Wir hören mit, es ist so es nicht.
Ja, gut, ist ja auch in Ordnung, kann man nur machen. Nur ich habe halt jetzt, ich hatte aber das mit dem Irk Channel einfach mehrere Probleme, so mal jetzt so von...
Aber ich finde, weil sonst kann ich schlecht Kritik anbringen, wenn du dein neues Tool nicht vorstellst, dann kann ich schlecht meckern. Wenn du dein Slack jetzt nicht vorstellst, muss ich mich die ganze Zeit zurückhalten, weil ich ja noch nicht meckere. Also wir vergleichen ja gerade alle zwischen Neudatum und Inzidenz. Wir wollen ja das sehr gegenüber stellen. Das eine hat ja Vorteile, das andere hat Vorteile und da muss man ja abwägen. Das ist ja nicht so... Ich kann das nicht machen, wenn du dein Slack jetzt nicht mal vorstellst. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt gleich wieder über Irk anfängst, was wir schon seit Jahren haben, dann kommen wir nie dazu dem.
Ja genau, gut, dann komme ich da jetzt mal dazu. Also Slack ist halt aus mehreren Gesichtspunkten ziemlich interessant. Also erst mal dieses Team-Konzept, du setzt halt für ein Projekt irgendwie ein Slack auf, da hast du dann eigene Accounts. Also es gibt so ein bisschen die Wahrnehmung, dass man so einen Slack-Account hat und das ist dann für alles. Dem ist nicht so, sondern man hat sozusagen immer für jedes Team eine eigene Userbase und eigene Passwörter und so weiter. Ein Team ist so quasi ein Chat-Server unter einem Namen, in dem dann mehrere Kanäle sein können.
Also bei dir kann man jetzt ja mal sagen, ist ja alles public, ne?
Genau.
Dein Team ist jetzt hier die Meta-Ebene oder wie und ein Channel davon ist jetzt die Freak Show und wenn du morgen mit Holger wieder eine Sendung machen würdest, hättest du dann natürlich dann in der Meta-Ebene einen eigenen NSFW-Channel.
Genau, den gibt es halt auch. Es gibt jetzt überhaupt für jede Sendung der Meta-Ebene gibt es einen eigenen Kanal. Das heißt, man kann in den Kanal reingehen und damit Leute, die sich für die Sendung interessieren, unter welchen Gesichtspunkten auch immer reden.
Ich kann also in alle Channels, wo ich Member in deinem Team bin.
Genau, und du bist aber, genau, du bist in diesem einen Team. Also es gibt metaebene.slack.com. Das ist halt die Meta-Ebene-Community. Und wenn du da einen Account hast, und da kann sich ja jeder selber einladen. Also ich hab so ein kleines Widget auf Meta-Ebene. Der ist an sich Closed. Du musst nur eine Einladung bekommen. Und ich hab halt nur so ein Tool genommen. Das gibt's auf GitHub. Das heißt Slack In. Und das ist so ein Widget. Dem gibst du einmal so einen AP-Key. Du kannst ja halt so, wenn du ein Team eingerichtet hast, kriegst du halt einen Zugang. Und dann ist es halt so ein Widget. Da trägst du deine E-Mail-Adresse ein. Und dann ist ja quasi autorisiert, einen Inwalt rauszuschicken. Und damit habe ich das quasi geöffnet. Und ich muss jetzt nicht jede einzelne Person einzeln selber eine Mail schicken. Und damit ist das so quasi offen.
Und dass es metaebene.slack.com heißt, das ist, weil du noch bei denen einen Server betreibst. Du könntest aber auch das selber machen.
Nein, Slack ist nur bei Slack.
Also man kann sich da nicht freikaufen?
Nein, man kann sich da nicht freikaufen.
Das war dann diese Meta-Maus, wo das geht?
Genau, also Slack ist ein reiner Start-up. Du hast zu tun, was wir dir hier hinstellen und was anderes gibt es nicht.
Wir haben dich also bei den Eiern.
Ja, mich bei den Eiern, genau so ist das. Also das ist mir natürlich auch alles wohl bewusst, was die potenziellen Gefährdungen und Einschränkungen sind. Und wenn die halt irgendwann total evil und doof sind, dann muss man es halt wieder sein lassen.
Und sie von Facebook gekauft werden?
Solange sie nicht von Microsoft gekauft werden und das gleiche Ende passiert wie mit Skype. Also ich meine, das wurde ja immer schlimmer von der Bedienbarkeit alleine her.
Kann alles passieren? Haben wir alles schon?
Wir würden noch jetzt gerade von irgendeinem Venture-Kapitalisten auf so und so viel Billions, auf Dollar gevalued.
Sieben Billionen US-Dollar Value und fahren sich jetzt ihre dreistelligen Millionen Investitionen ein, um halt weiter auszubauen. Weil es halt auch gut ist. Also man kann das jetzt im Einzelnen hier und da nicht mögen oder so, aber es funktioniert ja offenbar für sehr viele Leute sehr gut. Und ich verstehe das auch, warum das so ist. Weil ich finde, sie haben einfach eine Menge gelernt. Also es ist erstmal sehr chatty. Wenn man, sagen wir mal, auch nur Irk gewohnt ist, dann fühlt man sich hier nicht gleich komplett fehl am Platz. Du kannst ja sogar das Look and Feel in so einen Irkmodus setzen, wo dann sozusagen keine Avatare mehr dabei sind, wenn du das irgendwie geiler findest. Und es gibt so kleine Hacks, du kannst, wenn du einen Account hast, kannst du ja tatsächlich in deinen Settings dir auch Zugangsdaten für ein Irk-Client holen. Also wenn du unbedingt das totale Irk-Feeling haben willst, kannst du auch mit dem Irk-Client in den Slack reingehen.
Ist aber, sagen wir mal, eine suboptimale Erfahrung?
Ja, das ist dann so ein bisschen wie ein Maß Bier bestellen und einen kleinen Strohhalm dazu nehmen. Also das kann ich jetzt nicht so nachvollziehen, aber, sagen wir mal, für Leute, die jetzt, sagen wir mal, generell ihren Chat-Workflow über ein oder mehrere Irkserver machen und wo das dann so nur ein weiterer Chat-Kanal ist, wo man jetzt keinen Bock hat, noch einen eigenen Kleinvier zu verwenden, ist das ja auch völlig in Ordnung. Also du kannst ja dann Settings immer noch im Web machen und so den normalen Messageflow machst du halt da drüber.
Und dann mal das jetzt mal wieder mit dem Irk vergleicht, weil darum geht's ja. Das ersetzt ja das, was wir vorher im Irk hatten. Was kann das dann mehr? Also es hat verschiedene Kanäle, die kannst du im Irk auch haben. Dir gehört es auch nicht, wie Irk auch. Also es ist ja nicht dein Server. Du kannst halt nur die Kanäle da ein bisschen verwalten.
Ich bin hier schon mal mehr Admin, als ich es jetzt im Irk wäre.
Ja, aber das könnte man im Irk aber auch entgegennehmen.
Ja, wenn man sich anstrengt. Aber es ist mir noch nie gelungen, einen von meinen Kanälen wirklich zu ornen.
Aber wenn man da mal mit den richtigen Leuten redet, dann geht das.
Ja, dann legst du da den an, dann denkst du nicht dran, dann lockst du dich aus.
Das würden aber die Jungs ja sogar für uns übernehmen. Unser Plaket hat man noch nie wirklich.
Das ist zum Beispiel so eine Sache, da hab ich einfach keinen Bock, da zu irgendwelchen Predigern von so einem Irknetzwerk zu gehen und sagen, ja, hier, ich bin auf eurem Irknetzwerk für Developer und mach hier meinen Community-Chat. Klar, mag alles irgendwie gehen, ging auch schon mal alles, aber it's not the same.
Okay, ist aber nicht noch der einzige Vorteil. Was kann da denn mehr als Irk dann? Auch, dass da Bilder direkt drin kommen können?
Pfeiltransfer kann's.
Pfeiltransfer, ja, du kannst auch.
Auch als eine Pfeilablage, ne?
Und man kann halt sozusagen, sagen wir mal, semantisch da so Content noch reinkippen wie Codeschnipsel und sagen, hier ist Erlangcode und dann hast du halt gleich so ein Snippet. Kannst du das irgendwie pinnen, dass die Leute, alle die in den Kanal kommen, die sehen dann als erstes irgendwie diesen Schnipsel oder diesen Bug oder was auch immer?
Okay, man könnte zum Beispiel, also wenn das jetzt auch wohl viele Firmen benutzen und Programmierer und so weiter, also halt die Nerd-Arbeiter und dann können sie ein Channel aufmachen für so bestimmtes Bug. Da ist dann auch gleich die Lösung drin, nämlich so ein Codesnippet und dann können alle noch einmal Reveal machen und alle sagen ja, ja, okay, okay, okay, irgendwie so könnte man arbeiten mit dem Slag oder so.
Wir haben zum Beispiel bei Vuga haben wir halt so, was es halt von denen auch angeboten gibt, weswegen es halt so populär ist. Du hast halt sehr viel so APN-Punkte und Interoperabilität, vor allem, also wir haben zum Beispiel einen Service, wo wir unsere Log-Files von den Servern alle aggregieren. Und halt durchsuchen können und so weiter. Und so Alerts schicken, wenn bestimmte Log-Messages da durchscrollen und so. Und das kannst du halt dann sagen, bei diesem Service kannst du sagen, ok, schick eine Notification an den Channel im Slack und dann sind alle Developer im Production Log Slack-Channel und dann kommen halt da die Notifications als Messages rein. Also du kannst sehr viel AP-Integration sowohl raus, als auch rein machen und das ist halt...
Also das, was sich die coolen Buden irgendwie schon mit Erk irgendwie alles automatisch gebaut haben, auch dass die ganzen Commitze automatisch gepostet werden und wer jetzt irgendwie schuld ist, weil es mal wieder nicht baut, das wird ja dann von den Bots und Erk gepostet.
Genau, Jenkins, Integration.
Jetzt gibt es das ganze Zeug und so, das ist sozusagen, haben die Slack-Jungs sich jetzt mal ein bisschen ordentlich gemacht und ohne Erk.
Genau, das ist wirklich extrem easy, sich so zu klicken.
Verstehe.
Weil halt auch eben die ganzen größeren Services da entsprechend eben auch schon die Interoperabilität quasi anbieten. Was auch relativ easy geht im Vergleich zum Irg ist, da gibt es halt so diesen Slack-Bot, sozusagen so deinen Channel-Bot sozusagen schon built in und den lässt gehen, den kann man halt auch super trivial erstmal so auf ganz einfache Sachen konfigurieren. Du musst dich halt nicht damit rumschlagen, ja, welchen Irg-Bot nehmen, also Pest oder Cholera, weil dieses Irg-Bot-Thema, das ist halt auch schon immer einfach so.
Ja, weil es halt so viele gibt.
Ja, und es ist halt auch immer so, du fühlst dich einfach nie gut so richtig, weil das ist einfach so, will ich diesem Stück Software jetzt obgeben? Ich weiß nicht. Ich hab mich da nie gut beigefühlt. Und wenn die dann irgendwann nochmal frei gedreht sind und so, ich denk mal, das ist jetzt bei Freenote und so seit Jahren auch bestimmt im Griff das Thema, aber das ist auf jeden Fall auch sehr elegant gemacht, sag ich mal. Und halt spontan eine Subgruppe oder einen Subkanal aufzumachen. Also ich kann hier einfach sofort irgendwie sagen, mach mal einen neuen, neuen Direct Message Editor, auch ein paar Leute dazu, hast du deinen eigenen privaten Kanal oder du kannst irgendwie einfach schnell Subkanäle machen ohne irgendjemanden zu fragen und so weiter. Ich meine, beim IRG, wenn du deinen eigenen Server betreibst oder bei Freenote, kannst du ja auch Kanäle so einfach aufmachen, aber...
Wobei man das administrativ einschränken kann, das hab ich auch gemacht, also die öffentlichen Kanäle, die hab ich jetzt hier begrenzt, damit das nicht unübersichtlich wird, aber private Kanäle zum Beispiel kann man hier aufmachen. Und natürlich Direct Messages, ne? Und in der freien Version, also wenn du Geld zahlst, kriegst du noch mal sehr viel mehr Features, dann hast du auch noch so Gruppen und allen möglichen...
Ach so, genau, das haben wir dann halt, ja.
Das habt ihr alles, das gibt's jetzt hier so nicht. Sie haben ja mittlerweile auch Voice-over-IP mit drin, das geht hier tatsächlich auch, aber das geht hier nur über One-to-One-Direct-Messages. Also wenn man sozusagen hier so ein One-to-One-Chat mit jemanden hat, dann kann man da auch sozusagen Skype-mäßig anrufen. Und es gibt halt auch Gruppencalls gleich in so Kanälen, was jetzt glaube ich hier auch kein Feature wäre, was ich unbedingt einschalten wollen würde. Dann würden wir wahrscheinlich auch gleich die Slack-Server hier irgendwie kochen, weil ich muss ja zugeben, ich habe das Ding jetzt vor neun Tagen freigeschaltet und bin jetzt schon ein bisschen überrascht, wie viel Zuspruch das jetzt gefunden hat. Also wir haben jetzt hier vorhin gerade den 1000. Account, den 1000. Account sind wir schon bei 1027 begrüßt.
Eine Sache, die ist in irk so in der Form gar nicht gibt, außer halt wieder über extra Services und dann je nachdem, wie toll man sich das einrichtet, ist halt die Suche. Kannst halt da ziemlich schnell in allen möglichen Kanälen, wir haben wirklich viele Kanäle bei VUGA, kannst halt sagen, also ich weiß, dass in dem Kanal die Nachricht kam und dann nur in dem Kanal suchen oder du kannst sozusagen in unserer gesamten öffentlichen Firmchat-Historie halt suchen und eben so Filter ganz einfach machen, wie zum Beispiel hier, wie Tim das gerade schon so macht, quasi von User Letty in dem Kanal, Freak Show und solche Sachen. Und das ist halt auch, wenn du gerade in so einer Firma bist, wo halt viel internes Wissen so über Chats kommuniziert wird, so ja, übrigens, hier ist der Link zu dem Admin-Tool oder was auch immer, das dann halt wiederzufinden. Also diese Chat-Historie ist, glaube ich, für VUGA oder für so Firmen halt mit das aller, aller wertvollste, weil das ist bei Slack, äh, bei Skype, was wir vorher so als Firmen-Kommunikations-Chat benutzt haben, komplett unmöglich und alle anderen Messenger haben das im Wesentlichen eigentlich auch nicht, dass du sagen kannst, alle öffentlichen Kanäle, alles, was ich persönlich jemals mit irgendjemanden geschrieben habe, durchsucht das jetzt nach. Admin Tool und es war von User Florian, weiß ich auch noch, und hast dann in drei Sekunden halt deine Antwort. Das ist für uns, glaube ich, so mit der größte Usability-Faktor.
Vor allem, du musst halt nicht die ganze Zeit mit der Kaffeetasse von Etage zu Etage rennen und mal gucken, ob irgendjemand irgendwas weiß, sondern die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das schon mal irgendwo da reingeschrieben wurde, ist relativ hoch.
Aber wie gesagt, das gibt es ja auch bei Irk, dass Leute dann eben so wieder irgendeinen Bot da reinklinken, der das in Elasticsearch füttert, und dann gibt es dann auch eine tolle und so weiter, aber ja, muss man halt wieder adminisieren.
Muss man sich halt alles erst bauen, brauchst einen Admin, muss funktionieren, geht dann schief. Das ist halt das Ding hier, ist es halt mal so eben zum Klicken, und es funktioniert und es sieht vor allem auch ordentlich aus. Die Apps sind auch ziemlich gut. Und was natürlich auch noch so ein Nebeneffekt dieser ganzen Historie ist, du hast halt auch ein hervorragendes Offline-Verhalten. Das heißt, wenn du mal nicht irgendeinen Slack-Kanal geöffnet hast, keine App laufen hast, etc., pp., und steigst ein, du machst halt da weiter, wo du aufgehört hast. Du hast halt einfach immer die komplette Historie, und das hat mich halt bei Slack, äh, Entschuldigung, das hat mich bei Irk auch immer gestört. Ich weiß, da kann man sich dann auch wieder irgendeinen Bot aufsetzen, der das dann für einen speichert und synchronisiert, und es gibt da alle möglichen Tools. Aber es ist halt einfach mal echt schwierig, da für sich so ein Multiclient-Setup hinzubekommen, was das auch noch mit den Notifications ordentlich bekommt. Ich finde es auch sehr schön, wie man hier unterscheiden kann, zum Beispiel die Push-Notifications, die man bekommt für den Desktop und Mobil, kannst du separat pro Kanal einstellen. So, das heißt so Busy-Kanal, wie jetzt der Freak Show-Kanal, da habe ich jetzt einfach mal eben Mobile-Notifications ausgemacht für jede Nachricht, weil...
Das habe ich auch als erstes.
Ist das eine richtige iOS-App?
Es gibt auch eine richtige iOS-App. Das sieht hier auch auf der Watch ordentlich aus. Ich kriege hier also...
Aber die Desktop-App überzeugt mir jetzt noch nicht so.
Ja, ich muss...
Ich muss super auf die Nerven, weil ich brauche nur Resize machen und das rokelt hier im Fünf-Sekunden-Takt hinterher.
Das ist auf jeden Fall...
Das ist halt alles so React-Kram.
Ja, das ist auch eigentlich mein größter Kritikpunkt an diesem Slack, dass das alles Webviews sind und das merkt man halt an jeder Ecke. Das turnt mich nicht so wahnsinnig an.
Ja, aber wir wissen auch, warum das so ist. Dadurch haben sie natürlich einen extremen Turnaround. Na ja klar, wenn die halt irgendwie neue Optik irgendwie irgendwas einführen, dann haben sie das nur kommunizieren in allen kleinen. Das kann ich auch nachvollziehen. Aber ich muss sagen, wenn das jetzt echt das ganze Problem ist, das nehme ich jetzt echt gerne in Kauf. Also vor allem ist es halt nicht so, dass es nicht funktionieren würde oder so. Bisher hat das für mich zumindest immer funktioniert. Das ist extrem stabil, es sieht ordentlich aus, man versteht es auch.
Na ja, du benutzt das jetzt natürlich nicht so lange. Wir haben das jetzt ja schon ein bisschen länger in Benutzung. Es gab da durchaus schon, na ich würde sagen mindestens ein Jahr oder länger. Also ich meine halt so, mit voller Mannschaft und alle Features on. Und es gab da halt schon auch Versionen, die sie rausgeschoben haben, wo halt einfach nichts ging. Also einfach Latenz bis eine Tasse Tee gemacht und schon wieder kalt geworden. Und wenn dann halt deine ganze Firma da einmal so draufgedübelt hast, und dann der ganze Service halt mal schlafen geht, ist wirklich...
Was solltet ihr jetzt eines Tages sagen, wir wollen jetzt mal richtig, richtig fett Geld haben?
Du, die nehmen jetzt schon richtig, richtig fett Geld. Also es kostet 5 Dollar pro User, pro Monat.
Das ist doch nicht richtig fett Geld.
Also wenn ich jetzt die Metaebene-Community fahre, würde mich jetzt 5000 Euro im Monat kosten.
Das ist schon für so ein bisschen chatten so am Ende.
Wenn ihr da 500 angestellt habt, mal 5 Euro, ist das halt 2500 Dollar im Monat, dafür, dass das irgendwie ganz schön viel Infrastruktur bei euch irgendwie abdeckt, ist das noch nicht viel. Wenn die das einfach mal verdoppeln und verdreifachen und so weiter.
Ja, sie könnten es natürlich noch teurer machen, klar, ohne Frage. Aber ich würde mal sagen, die machen auch jetzt schon...
Ich denke, dass sie es tendenziell auch eher billiger werden lassen.
Um noch mehr Leute anzulocken.
Ja, das finde ich auch.
Erstmal wachsen immer, bis zum, wie sagt man, abwinken.
Ja, ich meine, sie hätten ja auch sagen können, es ist alles generell irgendwie kostenlos. Und irgendwann schalten wir dann mal das Geld ein und dann geht es nach hinten los. Und das haben sie halt nicht getan, sondern sie haben einfach gesagt, hier ist das, was ihr kriegt, wenn es frei ist. Und frei heißt im Wesentlichen ein paar extra Features wie Gruppen und jetzt halt auch neue, diese Gruppen-Voice-Calls, die gibt es halt gar nicht. Und das Log-File ist halt begrenzt auf 10.000 Einträge. Und das wird wahrscheinlich jetzt hier bei so einer Mega-Aktivität wie jetzt gerade während der Sendung dazu führen, dass das Ding sich wahrscheinlich in einer Woche komplett durchfaltet. Das heißt, die Information hier ist jetzt relativ volatil. Also, was ich jetzt hier drin suchen kann, kann ich wahrscheinlich in einer Woche dann nicht mehr suchen. Das ist aber für meinen Workflow vollkommen in Ordnung, weil ich vor allem immer das Problem hatte, dass ich, ja, ich hatte bei Irk dann einfach schon manchmal einfach Probleme. Weißt du, dann hab ich irgendwie mal bei Accident meinen Client gekillt und irgendwie keinen Lockfile gemacht oder es war aus meinem Scrollbuffer raus oder ja, klar, weiß ich, kann man alles irgendwie machen, geht irgendwie, Optionen hier, da, in diesem Client so, aber dann ist jeder Client auch irgendwie anders und nicht so gut.
Du könntest ja hier voll den Show Notes-Channel eigentlich noch haben, ne?
Naja, das ist ja im Prinzip jetzt hier, dieser Freak Show-Kanal.
Aber ist ja noch mit...
Was?
Ist ja noch mit ein bisschen mehr Noise. Also du könntest ja deine Show-Noten quasi direkt...
Klar, also das Ding ist jetzt am Anfang. Ich will das einfach mal ausprobieren. Das kann auch sein, dass das alles scheitert. Ich weiß es nicht. Probieren geht über Studieren, wie man so schön sagt. Und ich versuch das halt jetzt so langsam auszurollen und schrittweise, um Features zu ergänzen und auch unter Umständen um Kanäle. Jetzt wollte ich überhaupt erstmal sehen, gibt es überhaupt ein Interesse da dran? Offensichtlich ist dieses Interesse da, weil ich hätte jetzt nicht damit gewettet, dass sich jetzt hier 1000 Leute einen Account anlegen.
Eine Sache, die mir jetzt gerade fehlt, weil bisher benutze ich Slack ja nur in geschlossenen Benutzergruppen. Zum Beispiel unser Minecraft-Server hat auch einen eigenen Slack. Das ist ganz wichtig zur Koordination. Weil in Minecraft gibt es ja kein Lock. Aber jetzt hier so, da gibt es ja gelegentlich auch mal, also beim Irrkanal gibt es das ja auch gelegentlich, so den Bedarf, entweder zu ignorern, zu blocken oder zu kicken. Also mir reicht ja meistens ein Ignore. Das gibt es, ja, aber Ignore für den Autonomal-Normal-User, der halt keine besonderen Rechte hat, gibt es halt nicht. Und das ist, das finde ich dann in so einer offenen Chat-Wolke, wo sich allerlei...
Fußvolk sammelt.
Ja, auch Handvolk, was auch immer Volk. Also manchmal will man halt vielleicht den ein oder anderen Chat-Bytepark nicht sehen. Nee, darum geht es gar nicht.
Ja, das verstehe ich, aber ganz ehrlich, wenn jetzt hier einer irgendwie nervt, und zweimal auch noch nervt, dann...
Jetzt wo du ob hast, ne?
Ja, dann sorry. Weil dafür ist es nicht gedacht. Man muss sich hier schon ein bisschen benehmen. Ich denke nicht, dass man jetzt hier einem besonders unangemessenen Kodex gerecht werden muss, um hier seinen Account durchzubringen. Aber klar, wer jetzt hier irgendwie der Meinung ist, er müsste jetzt hier Gamergate in Chat tragen, ist halt schnell wieder draußen. Und ja, mit Show Notes, ich meine, ich verspreche mir, ihr habt so ein paar Hoffnungen oder so ein paar Vorstellungen, was vielleicht hier funktionieren könnte. Abgesehen jetzt von diesen Kanälen für die einzelnen Sendungen, kann ich mir zum Beispiel auch vorstellen, dass wenn jetzt so viele Leute hier sind, dass man unter Umständen auch Regionalität noch mal ein Forum bietet. Dass man einfach sagt, was weiß ich, Postleitzahl 1xx, 2xx oder Region Berlin oder so. Na ja, ich meine, ich hab bei den Hörer-Treffen, das ist immer so lustig, ich treffe ja dann Hörer, aber eigentlich treffen sich die Hörer ja sich und merken dann so, okay, ihr habt ähnliche Interessen und ihr wohnt sogar in der selben Stadt, lass mal quatschen. Das war eigentlich immer ein sehr interessanter Effekt und das könnte ich mir halt hier auch durchaus vorstellen. Jetzt bin ich natürlich vor allem erstmal auf der Suche nach Leuten, die Bock haben, mit dieser API zu arbeiten. Weil hier ist halt Integration relativ einfach und die, ähm, ich weiß nicht, hast du mit dieser API schon gearbeitet?
Wie soll man so voll ernst bleiben?
Hier postet Bilder, Netz.
Dieses Bild wurde in, äh, resenziert von der, äh, die Partei. Ja, das ist halt so ein Schwarz-Weiß-Poto so mit RF-Logo im Hintergrund von einer Geisel, die ein Schild hoch hält, seit 20 Tagen gefangen mit der GEZ und im Hintergrund steht halt auch auf dem Sternen statt der RF-GEZ, aber es ist einfach die Partei ist einfach.
Weiß ich, Storch oder Von Storch? Ja, okay, also wir kommen mit meinem Thema.
Ja, warte mal, ich muss den Link noch in die Show-Notes packen, sonst wissen die Leute ja am Ende dann, die die Sendung nachhören. Nicht, was uns gerade abgeschossen hat. In den Workflow wollte ich's machen jetzt.
Nein, du pinst den Link. Und ich geh dann nachher die Pins durch. Darauf wollte ich nämlich jetzt eigentlich gerade hinaus. Also es war ja schon immer meine Hoffnung, dass man diesen Chat eben benutzen kann, um auch so ein bisschen automatisierter diese ganze Show-Note-Link-Sammelproblematik zu machen. Und da es jetzt noch keine dedizierten Bots gibt, die jetzt hier konkret für das Thema Live-Podcasting Unterstützung bieten, versuche ich es halt jetzt erstmal mit den eingebauten Methoden. Aber das wird seine Grenzen haben. Aber jetzt braucht man sozusagen nur pinnen. Und jeder kann ja hier etwas pinnen, was sozusagen relevant ist. Das sollte nicht alles Mögliche sein, sondern eben, was man halt so meint, in den Show Notes zu sehen. Und dann werde ich da nachher mal durchgehen und mal gucken, ob das ist in Brauchbarkeit. Das ist wirklich schlimm.
Ja, und du fragtest ja, ob ich mit der Abi schon mal gearbeitet hätte. Ne, so direkt habe ich das nicht. Wie gesagt, wir benutzen halt hier bei VUGA halt GitHub-Integration, Paper Trail Integration, irgendwie alles Mögliche wird halt hier sozusagen in einzelne Kanäle noch reinsortiert und gefiltert. Ich glaube, andersrum benutzen wir es jetzt auch gar nicht, dass vom Slack irgendwas in andere Tools fließen würde. Insofern habe ich mich mit der Abi noch nicht auseinandergesetzt.
Ja genau, aber es gibt schon ein paar Leute, die sich hier gemeldet haben, die damit auch schon in ihren Companies das ein oder andere gemacht haben, mit rein und mit raus. Ich denke, hier könnte man eine Menge tun. Also was, sagen wir mal, jetzt für den ersten Schritt ganz interessant wäre, ist, wenn man es schafft, was weiß ich, wir sagen mal, in Freak Show während der Sendung gepinnte URLs werden eingesammelt und dann in irgendeiner Form als Outline rausgeballert, so dass man damit irgendwie arbeiten kann oder in irgendein anderes Format oder Online-Dokument überführt. Das wäre schon mal ganz hilfreich. Also wenn man das allein in das Show Notes Format zum Beispiel konvertieren würde, dass man einfach hier was beitragen kann und dann kann man halt gucken, macht es Sinn hier irgendwie die Zeit noch mit zu berücksichtigen oder denkt man sich noch ein paar andere Kommandos aus, mit denen man hier irgendwas steuern kann. Also da habe ich so lose Hoffnung und wenn ihr schon damit mal was gemacht habt oder einfach Bock habt, damit was zu machen und hier irgendwie so in dem Kontext Ideen habt für eine gute Integration von irgendetwas, was so dem Podcasting und dem Livestreaming insbesondere helfen kann, dann kommt auf mich zu, sprecht mich an, ihr wisst jetzt auch, wo ihr mich zu finden habt, nämlich in diesem Slack. Das finde ich auch sehr schön, dass man jetzt auch schnell mal Zugriff hat. Was mich so ein bisschen wahnsinnig gemacht hat in letzter Zeit war so dieses dann läuft das hier irgendwie über Twitter, da irgendwas über Facebook auf ein zu und dann kommt das wieder über andere Kanäle und ab dort net meldet sich auch noch ab und zu mal jemand und per Mail und irgendwie weiß ich dann immer schon gar nicht mehr, wie ich diese ganzen Usernames zusammenbringen soll, denn jetzt gibt es irgendwie so ein Nickname, den ich mir merken kann und die ganze Kommunikation kann darüber laufen. Aber vielleicht funktioniert das Ganze auch nicht, weil wir sind jetzt nämlich auch schon in sofern in einer kritischen Größe, dass ab 1000 User glaube ich auch Slack schon so langsam ein bisschen nervös wird, weil ich bin jetzt leider nicht der Erste, der versucht halt so eine Community zusammenzuholen. Das haben schon ein paar Projekte gemacht und ich habe auch jetzt gerade gehört, dass eine, die so bei 7500 Usern gelandet ist, von Slack auch schon so ein bisschen das Kopfschütteln entgegengeworfen bekommen hat. Ich weiß noch nicht ganz genau, was die Konsequenz ist, aber die finden das dann auch irgendwann nicht mehr lustig, weil es ja kostenlos ist.
Wie macht das eigentlich 99% Invisible?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Er macht jedes Mal ja schließlich auch Werbung für die. Also vielleicht hat er einen bezahlten Plan von denen gesponsert bekommen, aber der macht immer für Slack Werbung, immer.
Achso, ja, na dann würde ich mich nicht wundern.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass der auch eine ziemlich große Community hat.
Ja, wir machen ja seit einer halben Stunde schon Werbung für Slack. Also liebe Mitarbeiter bei Slack, her mit dem Account.
Lass schlackern.
Aber ich finde das auch in der Tat so zum Team, also als Teamüberblick so ein Slack. Also wir haben nicht Slack, wir nutzen MetaMouse.
Ist das auch kommerziell mit Freikaufkarte oder ist das?
Nope, das ist komplett Open Source.
Das ist die Open Source-Allernte. Die habe ich auch natürlich evaluiert. Ich habe mir das angeschaut. Wird ja auch gerade so im Club auch gerade an vielen Orten getestet. Das Problem mit MetaMouse ist, dass da einfach die Apps-Ballade noch nicht so weit sind.
Nee, das sind sie ja noch nicht.
Also die auch noch nicht so weit, also.
Die ist sogar noch weiter.
Also wenn ich kurz eine Sache einwerfen darf und mein Telefon inspielen darf, sogar Slack hat einen Account für Blackberry, eine App für Blackberry.
Ja, aber es ist ja auch nicht schwer, weil es eben am Ende nur ein Webview ist.
Aber sie haben es.
Aber sie haben es, genau. Also das haben wir dann doch nicht.
Das war das dicke Ding, was da voll so einen Krach gemacht hat, wo diese Riesentastatur dran klebt.
Ich weiß, das hörst du wahrscheinlich tausendmal am Tag, aber...
Ich hab auch noch nie eins in der Hand gehabt.
Also wenn man wirklich auf der Party nichts zu reden hat, dann holen wir das Telefon raus.
Das ist ja die Quadratur des Smartphones quasi.
Und du als Nerd hast natürlich nie zu reden auf einer Party, weil du sitzt auch immer auf der Couch und bist mit deinem Blackberry beschäftigt.
Ja, natürlich. So muss man nicht mit Menschen reden. Also ich hab's wie gesagt eher so mit Toten. Die sind einfacher zu bedienen, aber...
Und mit denen kannst du auch nicht chatten.
Nee, aber sie sagen auch nichts.
Jetzt musst du schon noch mal ein bisschen genauer erzählen, was das für ein Gerät ist, weil jetzt hast du es angesprochen.
Ich dachte, es geht jetzt über die Toten.
Naja, ist ja das Gleiche eigentlich.
Na hallo. Ja, in der Tat, das ist so ein bisschen tot. Ja, ich hatte ein Blackberry Passport. Es heißt nicht umsonst Passport. Es ist wirklich so groß wie ein Reisepass.
Also größer, würde ich sagen.
Nein, es ist genauso groß wie ein Reisepass.
Es ist wirklich so groß wie ein Reisepass.
Böser Klopper und die Batterie hält auch so lange, wie sich das hier anfühlt von dem Gewicht?
Mindestens zwei Tage. Ich war mit dem Telefon unterwegs auf einer Tracking-Tour und da brauchst du das ja nicht so häufig und bin auf drei oder vier Tage sogar gekommen.
Wow.
Das ist, ja.
Also ich muss meinen, also Tim legt ja sein Telefon mehrmals täglich.
Ja, ich glaube, Tim, der hat auch irgendein Special-Pay mit seinem Telefon.
Ich hab jetzt wieder einen neuen Akku. Der ist kaputt. Ich hab jetzt einen neuen.
Und der hält jetzt wie lange?
Länger.
Zwei Stunden.
Das Telefon, was bei meiner Usage einen ganzen Tag durchhält, das wird wahrscheinlich in zwei, drei Jahren noch nicht erschienen sein.
Aber mal ganz ehrlich, wenn wir zu diesem Telefon-Thema gerade überkommen und ich bei Apple letztens erst wieder gesehen hab, dass die immer noch diese 16-Gigabyte-Telefone verkaufen? Also es ist ja wirklich ein bisschen traurig. Die Cloud ist auch nur ein Computer von jemand anderem.
Ja, aber der hat mal Speicher.
Hey, das ist doch aber, da sind wir wieder bei der Pornoindustrie. Wenn der ganze hochgeladene Porn-Content aus den Clouds einfach direkt in die Pornindustrie fließen würde, würde es vielleicht auch besser einen Porn geben. Egal. Ich sehe eure Gesichter. Und die RAF geht jetzt.
Nee, ich muss das gerade nochmal vertwittern, damit das auch alle außerhalb von Facebook und Slack sehen.
Wie? Bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei dem Blackberry. Ich meine, du bist wahrscheinlich irgendwie...
Natürlich, Erdgeist.
Ich hab Erdgeist überzeugt.
Allerdings, ja, ich glaub, Erdgeist hat ein paar Probleme mit seinem Telefon, aber der hat halt einfach das Falsche. Der hat das Kleine davon.
Ach, das gibt's auch noch ein Kleine.
Ja, das gibt's ein Kleine.
Das heißt aber nicht Passport, sondern Perso oder was?
Mein Telefon hat auch einen geilen Namen. Es heißt Schnittchen. Also Schnittenbrett ist so die eine Sache. Und ich weiß nicht, ob ihr Schnittchen versteht. Also da, wo ich herkomme, sagt man, auch zu einem schönen Männchen ist aber ein Schnittchen.
Auch Typen oder nur Frauen?
Beides.
Oder auch Sahne Schnittchen?
Nee, noch ein bisschen fast vor Polen. Naja, also echt gefühlt aus Polen.
Blackberry, was ist denn so geil in dem Teil?
Die Testatur.
Und das Schwarze.
Ja, natürlich.
Schwarzes meint es auch.
Ehrlich gesagt, diese ganze Hub-Geschichte, die Blackberry hat, wo du so eine, was die Mitteilungszentrale irgendwo versteckt beim iPhone ist als Beispiel. Hast du ja an einem wirklich zentralen Ort und du siehst all deine Nachrichten, all deine SMS, whatever, E-Mails. Und das finde ich ziemlich schnieke. Also, es ist ein cooles Konzept.
Was ich ja ganz fancy fand, ist, dass man kann über der Tastatur sweichen.
Ah ja, genau. Also ich habe eine sensitive Tastatur.
Diese silbernen Stege zwischen den Taschen.
Man streichelt die ganze Zeit seine Tastatur.
Das ist total nordgerechte Haltung. Es ist rausgekommen. Natürlich. Nein, es ist anderthalb Jahre alt. Ich habe es mir gekauft vor dem Kongress 2014.
Ich meine, von Blackberry hat man jetzt schon länger nichts mehr gehört, aber die machen immer noch Hardware und auch immer noch mit Tastatur.
Die haben ein neues Telefon raus. Du kannst hier schon Android-Apps drauflaufen lassen. Auf der 10er-Betriebssystemversion. Und das neue Telefon von denen ist ein Priv, oder so was heißt das, keine Ahnung. Ist ein bisschen ein hässlicherer Schinken. Und das soll wohl komplett so ein Android-Teil sein mit den Hauptfunktionalitäten von Blackberry. Also so eine interessante Mischung. Ich hab's aber noch nie gesehen.
Mit Tastatur auch wieder.
Mit Tastatur, also du hast theoretisch eher so ein iPhone und schiebst dann so ein Stück hoch und hast eine Tastatur. Na ja, will ich ja hoffen. Also ich mein, das ist das einzige, womit sie überleben können. Ja, ich hab letztens, also die Kamera ist halt wirklich schlecht von den Blackberry. Und ich hab letztens schon so ein bisschen als Reisehandy so ein billiges iPhone mal überlegt, aber... So ein Zweit-Handy als Reisehandy nur wegen der, eigentlich nur wegen der Kamera ist auch so ein bisschen strange. Mit einer einfachen Kamera mit? Ja, wenn es eine kleine handliche ist, so oder hier, ich kann euch das mal mit dem...
Mit dem Hub zeigen?
Nee, nicht mit dem Hub, sondern mit dem scrollen.
Aber es fühlt sich schon so ein bisschen. Also it's on its way out. Ich meine, hat Blackberry nicht mittlerweile das OS selber jetzt offiziell sogar schon frustriert gegeben?
Aber du stehst doch auf tot.
Ja, ich stehe auf totes. Ja, genau, genau, genau.
Was muss ich jetzt machen bei dem Bild? Ist das der Tesla?
Würd ich jetzt mal auf Windows-Ton umsteigen?
Hab doch gleich erkannt.
Swipen auf der Tastatur. Also nicht auf Tastatur nach oben oder nach unten.
Ach so, der erkennt es an den Dreien. Ich dachte aber, dass das für links, rechts irgendwie wäre.
Kannste auch nutzen.
Jetzt bin ich irgendwo drin und der will nicht mehr. Der hat jetzt hier so einen Clipboard-Dinger hochgeholt. Ja, keine Ahnung. Ich habe da wahrscheinlich außersehen gedrückt beim Swipen.
Du hast die Suchleiste gefunden und man kann es also wirklich so.
Gratuliere, sie haben die Suchleiste gefunden.
Ja, schon wieder. Ich weiß darum, weil ich immer gleich ein bisschen höher mache und dann den unteren Teil vom Bildschirm berühre. Das muss man wirklich sehr sensitiv da machen, da unten. Das ist halt Übungssache.
Das kann halt nicht jeder bedienen.
Wenn ich dir ein iPhone gebe, bekommst du das ja auch nicht gleich sofort.
Ich bin ja vom iPhone gewechselt und es war einfach nur großartig, hier eine Tastatur zu haben. Ich möchte nicht mein Telefon irgendwo hinstellen und dann davor so eine dicke Bluetooth-Tastatur haben.
Nein, ich meine, Tastatur, also da kommt ja eine. Das ist ja nicht so, dass da keine ist.
Ah.
Genau.
Letty ist ja eine richtige Hackerin und für die ist eine Tastatur halt was.
Es muss klacklacklack machen, wenn ich drücke.
Ja, aber dafür musst du aber auch da so einen Kohleklotz mit dir rumschleppen. Also ich meine, ich war schon fürs Wochenende einkaufen, hatte nie gedacht, bitte.
Echt, aber eine Bierflasche, die ist größer. Eine Weinflasche auch, Whisky absinnt auch.
Nee, Wochenendeinkauf ist 100 Gramm Schoki zum Beispiel. Nein, aber ich meine, das ist schon ein ganz schöner Klopper.
Was kostet denn für Schoki, wenn du nur so wenig?
Wahnsinn Spaß, aber das ist doch schon ein ganz schöner Klopper. Und ich meine, zeig mal noch mal kurz. Also die Tastatur ist ja, geht eigentlich noch, aber es ist schon ein Viertel von dem ganzen Gerät, da unten ist Tastatur. Also ich meine, es ist auch Screen Space, der da verloren geht. Und dein Screen ist jetzt schon größer noch als bei diesem iPhone, aber es ist auch wirklich ein Riesenteil.
Quadratisch praktisch gut.
Also in deine Arschtasche kannst du das nicht machen, weil dann kannst du den nämlich nicht mehr hinsetzen, dann bricht das Ding ja durch.
Nee, aber ich bin auch nicht so der Arschtaschen-Handyfreund.
Ja und Vornetasche zum Beispiel geht auch gar nicht, weil auch viel zu fett ist.
Ich hab einen Sport-BH, wo es reinpasste.
Was, wieso kann ich mir auch kaufen? Dann kannst du auf deine Wunschliste setzen.
Du hast wahrscheinlich morgens schon einen.
Toll, in rosa. Nee, aber zum Beispiel gibt es auch so Handytaschen in der Jacke. Zum Beispiel meine Motorradjacke hat so was. Und da muss ich jetzt mit dem iPhone 6 schon kämpfen, dass das da reingeht, weil es ist gerade so. Und das Ding da, ich wüsste gar nicht, wo ich das dann transportieren sollte.
Also ich hab, das ist, ja, mir war es noch nie irgendwie eine Belästigung.
Nee, man kann das schon mit sich rumschleppen, aber ich finde, das ist schon von der Größe ja nicht mehr so easy. Man muss schon so mehr in den Kopf machen, wie man das jetzt so transportiert oder aufhebt oder wo man das jetzt nun irgendwie unterbringt.
Tim hat mich ja mit seinen Taschen warnen, nicht Handtaschen, diese Aufbewahrungstaschen. Die Mashbags, so ein bisschen infiziert. Also ich war vor kurzem auf Reise und hab meine gesamten Klamotten in Packsäcken und diesen Mashbags drin gehabt und da fliegt jetzt halt auch immer mein Telefon rein. Und da ich als Frau häufiger Handtasche trage, einfach irgendwo reingeschmissen.
Verstehe.
Du brauchst auch mal die Man-Purse.
Kannst du voll vergessen.
Ach so, schlecht ist das nicht?
Ja, ich weiß, du bist ja auch so ein Fan davon, aber du bist ja auch schon älter.
Das kommt nur aufs Design an.
Herrenhandtaschen sind wieder am Kommen. Man muss die halt cool machen.
Wenn du dir gewisse Kreise anguckst, die haben wir dann hier, diese Bauchtaschen da, die sie dann am Rücken tragen oder so.
Diese furchtbaren Hipster-Linger.
Nee, das geht gar nicht.
Hipster, die sind doch schon noch älter. Das ist auch in den 90ern so aufgekommen, weil man ja bei den Technoparties nicht viel anhatte. Und dann waren halt diese Taschen irgendwie so ganz praktisch, um die sich noch so um seinen Bauch freien umzuschneiden bei den Mädels.
Weiß ich nicht.
Da kamen die zum ersten Mal auf.
Wobei ich aber auch so eine Gürteltasche hab. Also nicht Gürteltasche, es ist so eine Militärtasche, die ich irgendwo mal bekommen habe. So eine Seitentasche. Und da passt zum Beispiel, also Kongress ist so das beste Beispiel. Was brauchst du beim Kongress? Also wenn du nicht so einen weiten Weg hast, nur deinen Telefon und irgendwie was zu trinken. Aber das passt halt alles nur mit dieser Tasche rein. Und dann, ich hab nur diese kleine Militärtasche, die ich an mir trage.
Ich denke im Accessory-Markt für Nerds ist noch eine Menge zu holen. Da ist noch lange nicht für alles eine Lösung gefunden. Und gerade dieses Taschenkonzept ist wirklich, also ich hab ja auch eine ganze Weile lang, vor zwei Jahren, anderthalb Jahren hab ich das Konzept Gürteltasche wirklich noch mal so bis der Arzt kommt durchgespielt, aber die haben dann alle irgendwie nicht durchgehalten. Und irgendwie sieht es auch ein bisschen aulig aus. Jetzt bin ich irgendwie tatsächlich komischerweise bei, wie nennt man diese Taschen? Dann hier eigentlich noch mal diese hipster...
Schultertaschen. Was die offizielle Aus-LKW-Planne?
Ist das Shoulderbag?
Nennt man das so?
Wieso guckst du mich an und fragst mich?
Keine Ahnung. Du siehst aus, als hättest du Ahnung von Kultur.
Also ich würde sagen, das ist eine Schulterbag oder so ein Messengerbag halt, ne?
Ja genau, Messengerbag ist was.
Aber Messengerbags sind ja riesiger.
Das ist halt so eine typische Berlin-Hipster-Tasche, die ich nur habe, weil die irgendjemand mal auf meinem Geburtstag vergessen hat und sich bis heute nie einer gemeldet hat. Und dann hatte ich die halt einfach.
Ich gehörte dem Besitzer der Bar.
Nee, nee, bei mir zu Hause. Und ich hab die irgendwie lange überhaupt nicht mit dem Arsch angeguckt, bis ich dann irgendwann mal so Taschenbedarf hatte. Und dann bin ich so ein bisschen mehr darum herumgelaufen. Dann hab ich irgendwie erst gemerkt, so wie geil das eigentlich ist. Aber, ja, weiß nicht, ob wir jetzt über Taschen unterhalten wollen. Man muss da variieren und...
Hast du da nicht auch so eine lustige Tasche? Ja, da sind wir wieder bei. Ich pinne da mal was ins...
Das hast du schon wieder ausgemacht, wie es aussieht.
Hast du?
Du bist im Web.
Ich bin im Web, ja. Hattest du nicht auch so eine lustige Tasche, wo du so viel Stuff drin hattest? Ich weiß nicht mehr.
So eine lustige Tasche, wo du viel Stuff drin hattest.
Verstehst du das nicht, was ich meine?
Erzähl mehr von dieser Tasche.
Ich bilde mir ein, du wärst diejenige, die auch sowas hatte. Tickst du da bitte mal drauf, Tim?
Da muss man ja nicht drauf.
So was?
War hier so eine Handwerkertasche, oder wie?
Ja, sowas in der Art. Warst du das nicht?
Ja, war ich, aber da hab ich ja gerade gesagt, also diese Gürteltaschen, das hab ich irgendwie bis der Arzt kommt ausprobiert, verschiedene. Da sind einige geklaut worden. Da hatte ich eine andere, die war besser, ja, das ist, aber die reißen immer aus.
Ich hab eine mit Gurt um das Bein drumrum. Also mir sagte man danach so was wie Lera Trotz.
Also mindestens das muss ja wohl sein.
Ja, also ich find, genau, also Gürteltaschen, das Problem ist, du musst sie, also ich finde, die muss vor allem eine gewisse Breite haben. Also Taschen, die so in die Länge gehen, die, erstens schlackern sie rum, zweitens hast du schnell dieses Problem, dass du Dinge und übereinander hast und dann kommst du in so einen Kram-Modus und hast aber nicht genug Öffnungen, so. Das heißt, was ich eigentlich relativ bewährt hat, sind Taschen, die eher ein bisschen breiter sind, wobei dann hast du natürlich irgendwann das Problem, dass du nicht genau weißt, wo willst du die anbringen, dann musst du irgendwie um dich herumgehen, dann ist sie so ein bisschen gebogen, auch schwierig. Und wo die Tasche auf der vollen Breite ausklappt, aber wo dann so an der Seite so quasi so Schwimmhäutchen rauskommen, sodass nichts seitlich rausfallen kann. Viele machen auch sehr viele Taschen, dass sie zwar aufgehen, aber dann fällt im Prinzip alles raus. Wenn die halt so links und rechts solche...
Die Sport-Show ist leider nicht so gut hier, weil sowas ist halt echt geil.
Wenn die Leute halt so da so richtige Schwimmhäute eingebaut haben, dann...
Dann musst du da auf den Link klicken.
Dann muss ich auf den Link klicken, ja, okay, mach ich mal. Aber ich erzähl das mal kurz zu Ende.
Dieses Pinterest ist auch immer furchtbar, um irgendwas wiederzufinden oder zu linken. Das ist... Da krischiert das mal, die Krise. Nee, ich hab das ja selber nicht. Ich klicke immer nur bei anderen und dann ist der Content, der verlinkt wurde, schon längst wieder irgendwie weg oder...
Ja, ich find mir mittlerweile halt alles, was ich als wichtig finde, was ich für irgendwas brauche.
Ja, ich seh ja auch, dass das Leute benutzen, aber das ist so ein Service, den hab ich bis heute irgendwie noch nicht verstanden.
Ich wollte kurz sagen, was meiner Meinung nach ein guter Ansatz ist für eine Gürteltasche. Sie muss halt eine gewisse Breite haben, sodass man sie auch auf der vollen Breite öffnen kann. Sie muss natürlich Reißverschluss haben. Sie muss einen guten Reißverschluss haben, der nicht so dünn ist, sondern der richtig was aushält, weil da will man dran reißen, mit ordentlichen Schlappis dran, dass man die gut greifen kann, die aber natürlich irgendwie aus Leder sein sollten, damit sie einerseits nicht so schnell reißen, andererseits nicht irgendwie rumklappern. Und vor allem brauchst du einen bidirektionalen Reißverschluss, dass du sozusagen sowohl nach vorne als auch nach hinten jederzeit schließen kannst und nicht immer dich entscheiden musst, nicht mal den anderen so rüber auf die eine Seite hast, wo er zugeht. Weil mal willst du von vorne, mal willst du von hinten ran, mal willst du auch nur so einen kleinen Bereich offen lassen.
Ich frage mich gerade, wie die Tasche aussieht.
Das ist echt...
Im Wesentlichen so etwas kleiner als den A5, wie so ein 7 Zoll Android Tablet, diese Größenordnung quer. Ist ja die korrekte Methode, das an den Gürtel ranzubringen. Da sind die auch alle relativ schlecht. Das verstehe ich überhaupt nicht, dass die nicht schneiden, dass man das einfach stabil an mehreren Stellen des Gürtels befestigen muss, damit es irgendwie nicht abgeht, aber dann eben auch eine Methode finden, wie man sie schnell abnehmen kann. Weil wenn man sie mal nicht braucht, dann muss sie sich auch gut lösen können, muss aber auch so zu befestigen sein, dass sie auf gar keinen Fall abgeht, wenn man sie trägt, so dass sie nicht abgerissen werden kann oder dass man sie verliert.
Weil alle Features gehen in ein Produkt rein?
Ja, auf jeden Fall, klar. Und was ich noch nie gefunden habe, aber was ich richtig geil fände, ist noch ein magnetischer Verschluss. Weil ganz oft will ich die Tasche im Zugriff, im schnellen Zugriff haben und nicht immer wieder einen Reißverschluss aufmachen müssen. Aber ich will, dass sie zumindest zu ist, dass sie nicht so aufgeklappt an einem herumhängt. Weil man macht sie manchmal nur deshalb zu, also man macht nur deshalb den Reißverschluss komplett zu, damit sie nicht aufgeklappt ist. Aber es würde vollkommen reichen, wenn sozusagen oben, wenn die nicht ganz so voll ist, einfach noch genug Magnete sind, dass du sie einfach so zu drückst und dann ist sie schon mal zu, im Sinne von hängt nicht runter. Und wenn du sie halt so richtig zu haben willst, dann kommst du mit dem Reißverschluss hinterher. Also was hat noch keiner gebaut?
Magnete sind auch nicht so praktisch. Was ich zum Beispiel habe, ist dieser Tunnelzug, dieser typische an meiner Tasche oben. Tunnelzug? Na, wer heißt das denn? Weißt du, dieser typische, kannst du mal kurz hochscrollen zu dem ollen Turnbeutel da? Ein Stück höher, ein Stück höher, ein Stück höher, halt ein Stück wieder runter. Und zwar dieses da, genau diese Öffnung. Das hab ich zum Beispiel in der Gürteltasche, wo du aber unten noch diesen Stopper hast, also dass du dann wirklich zumachen kannst mit dem Stopper, sodass du auch den Stopper lösen musst, als wieder reinzukommen. Oder aber wenn du den Stopper nicht runter ziehst, dass du den zwar zu hast, aber wenn du halt mit der Hand irgendwie schnell reinfährst, ist das Ding wieder auf. Hab aber allerdings auch noch so eine Klappe drüber.
Weil da hast du natürlich auch immer diese Bänder, die da so rumbammeln und so, ne?
Ja, naja nicht, wenn du sie kurz oben umklappst und dann, ich hab da ja so ein Deckel noch drüber. Aber das ist, ja es ist schwer so was zu kaufen, ist halt, da ist man schnell bei, musst du selber machen. Deswegen hab ich Pinterest eigentlich auch nur, damit ich mir all die Ideen aus den idealen Taschen so zusammen glauben kann, dass ich sie nachschneidern kann.
Es gibt übrigens von Bobelby hier, der favorisierten Nerd-Rucksack-Firma der Herzen, gibt es auch eine Mini-Hardschalen-Gürteltasche, finde ich, ist bestimmt super bequem zu tragen. Ja, pass auf, ich pack's einfach nur mal aus Spaß, da musst du mal scrollen im Chat. Find ich auf jeden Fall mal ganz witzig, dass sie auch an diese Produktkategorie gedacht haben, aber so richtig bequem, musst du mal den Link klicken, das ist jetzt ohne direkt Bild.
Wieso denn das nicht?
Weiß ich nicht.
So um den Bauch machen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ach so, das ist im Prinzip die mini Variante von ihrem komischen Rucksack.
Ja, genau, und kannst du die halt aber so zum An-die-Hüfte-Schnallen. Also da gibt's irgendwie so ein Bild mit dem kleinen Gurt dann so.
Gibt's das auch mit Mensch dran? Ach, das ist ja ein Riesenteil.
Naja, im Vergleich zu dem großen Bubble-Bean natürlich klein, aber das ist immer noch ziemliches Monster, ja.
Hilfe, wie schwer ist denn das Ding? 1,2 Kilo?
Steht auf der Seite, ja.
Das ist ja, da kannst du...
Ja, ich weiß, das ist halt wahrscheinlich auch zertifizierter Hüftenprotektor.
Nee, so Hüftprothesen sind ja nicht mehr.
Die weitere Sendung verzögert sich um 30 Minuten.
Angrund von Handtaschen. Oder Hüfttaschen.
Ja, okay, Digitalkameras, Videorekorder. Das ist halt das Ding, dass viele dieser Taschen sind so für Kamerabedarf gemacht. Und das ist halt nicht mein Bedarf, sondern ich will da halt Sachen drin haben wie Geld, Tonstudio, Schlüsse, Stifte, Handy, sowas. Mit verschiedenen Modi. Party Mode ist halt anders als General Nerd Mode.
Ich zeig dir mal meine Tasche. Die ist Gold wert.
Du machst ja sowieso irgendwie dein Kleid. Welches? Das vom Camp, das selbstgemachte.
Das Camp-Kleid.
Was hast du gerade an?
Soll ich mal kurz aufstehen? Für den Chat mal aufstehen. Also ich muss wohl dazu sagen, auch die Schlapperhose, die ich gerade trage, ist meiner Eigenproduktion.
Was war das XXL?
Das ist ein XXL-Shirt, ja.
Ah ja, und das hast du dir umgenäht.
Genau. Der wollte mir das erst nicht rausrücken. Ich meinte, ey, gib mir mal das Camp-Shirt. Hey, nee, das ist ein XXL, damit kannst du eh nichts anfangen. Ich so, logisch, gib's halt. Ja, der dachte echt, ich würde ihn verarschen. Und ich so, nee, mach mal, ich hätt gern ein Kleid. Und dann hab ich mich ein bisschen komisch angeguckt.
Bist du eigentlich auch so in diesem automatisierten?
Nee, das, was, ich, das kannste nicht automatisieren. Ich arbeite gerade darauf hinaus, meine gesamte Reiseklamotte selber zu herzustellen. Also wirklich so Merino-Klamotte in Eigenproduktion, weil Merino ist ja so ein bisschen preisintensiv zu kaufen. Merino-Wolle? Das ist so ziemlich scharf. Genau, das Schaf hat spezielle Eigenschaften, beziehungsweise die Wolle, die ist ganz, ganz dünn.
Das ist der Schafe von der Kobi-Rinder, oder wie sagt man?
Das ist eine markteregte Wolle.
Genau, ursprünglich kam die, glaube ich, mal aus Spanien. Und jetzt die größte Produktion ist, glaube ich, so in Neuseeland. Das sind knufflig-flauschige Tierchen, so sie denn Wolle tragen gerade. Die Eigenschaften sind halt super. Das ist halt A, ein natürliches Produkt. Du stinkst da drin nicht. Also du schwitzt, ja, schwitzt natürlich, aber das A trocknet das ganz schnell wieder. Aber der Geschweiß kann sich da eigentlich nicht dran festsetzen, weil die Struktur des Gewebes so fein ist, dass Bakterien da keinen Halt finden. Und halt auf der einen Seite.
Ich hab mit gesagt, der Dennis kennt nur Tiere zum Essen.
Die kann man sicherlich auch essen. Wobei ich hätte gerne einen Toten, egal, einen Kopf davon.
Bleiben wir beim Schneidern.
Ja, genau, also es ist halt ein super schönes Material, was viel für Outdoor-Bekleidung benutzt wird derzeit. Also es hält halt warm, es kühlt dich aber auch genauso. Und wenn es nass ist, wärmt es dich irgendwie noch und trocknet total schnell. Icebreaker ist da so eine sehr, sehr bekannte Firma und lässt sich da die gute Produktion auch sehr viel bezahlen.
Und sind die Preise so, um mal Vergleich zu haben?
Also nur mal so um den Vergleich. Wenn ich normalen Jersey-Stoff kaufe zum Nähen, da kostet so der Meter, lass es ein teurer sein, vielleicht 15, 20 Euro. Und bei 20 Euro, dann bist du schon gefühlt bei der Bio-Wolle wieder. Und wenn du bei Merino bist, kostet dich die günstigste Variante, die dann sehr, sehr dünn ist, meistens so für die erste Schicht so Winterbekleidung gedacht hast oder T-Shirts im Sommer. Ich glaube 34, 35 Euro der Meter. Na ja, es gibt auch Stoff in der Tat für 10 Euro oder 5 Euro der Meter.
Also es ist halt schon am oberen Ende von Stoff.
Wir hatten ja mal vor einiger Zeit die Fabienne zu Gast. Kennst du die eigentlich?
Nee, ich hab sie nie kennengelernt.
Ich kenne den Podcast. Die hat ja hier erzählt von ihren ganzen automatisierten Strick-Experimenten. Vier Maschen pro Pixel. Wer diesen Podcast noch nicht gehört hat von uns, das ist definitiv einer der höheren Wertesten. Und sie hat ja, ich weiß gar nicht, hatte sie damals schon diese Crowdfunding-Geschichte erläutert? Das kam, glaube ich, dann danach. Und ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir das, doch wir hatten das mal erwähnt. Sie wollte ja mit der Crowdfunding-Kampagne genug Geld zusammenbekommen, um sich so eine richtig schöne deutsche Maschine zu kaufen. Und da müssen wir jetzt mal der Chronisten-Pflicht gerecht werden, weil das hat ja auch alles geklappt. Also die Kohle kam problemlos zusammen, kann man sagen. Also es lief ja auch so mit, du bestellst auch sozusagen auch gleich deinen Schal so schön mit Matte-Muster und jeder kriegt einen anderen und kein Schal ist wie der andere. Pipapo, dann kam so viel Geld dazu, dass ihr dann irgendwie noch eine Zusatzfarbe auch hat noch mit dazu kaufen können. Das hat finanzielle Auswirkungen, weil sie halt nur so die beste Wolle, die man sich vorstellen kann, kauft. Das kann alles gut sein. Sie hat da irgendwie alles Mögliche getestet. Und ich gucke jetzt gerade, weil sie hat in letzter Zeit viele Fotos getwittert von dieser Maschine in ihrem Raum. Also das Ding hat sie sich in Deutschland gekauft, ist dann letztes Jahr nach Deutschland gefahren, hat dann zwei Wochen in diesem Unternehmen vor Ort quasi auf dieser Maschine erst mal stricken gelernt oder erst mal glaube ich sogar mit einer anderen Maschine aus diesem Fuhrpark manuell stricken gelernt und dann auf ihrer Maschine das ganze Automatisierte stricken gelernt und dann ist halt dieses Teil irgendwann aufs Schiff gekommen, über den großen Teich gefahren und jetzt steht es halt so in irgendeiner Halle in Seattle. Wie das immer so ist, wenn man mal nach einem Foto sucht, findet man natürlich keins. Ist ja nicht Slack.
Wo man jetzt suchen könnte.
Ja, na gut, bei Twitter, lass uns nicht über Twitter reden. Scheint noch eine ganze Menge anderer interessanter Sachen zu passieren zu sein in ihrem Leben. Aber ich werde es gleich finden und dann nochmal hier in die Show Notes geben. Ah ja, hier. Das Coole Fotos. Ja, genau. Stoll heißt die Firma, das hatte sie glaube ich auch schon erzählt. Und hier gibt es sogar schon Sachen in Action. Ich haue mal hier kurz was in die Chat. Und ja. Da kann man sich dann demnächst wahrscheinlich auch was anbieten, wenn dann erst mal ihre Initialproduktion dann auch gestartet ist. Also das ist für dich super. Einen habe ich noch. Genau, so heißt das Projekt. Also eine Monster-Maschine, die irgendwie Tonnen schwer ist. Gratulation, Fabienne. Du bist die Beste. Ich finde es bemerkenswert. Natürlich wird sich das Ding komplett automatisiert, von außen per Computer anweisen, Dinge zu tun.
Aber das kannst du halt beim Stricken auch. Das ist halt der Unterschied zum Nähen. Also Stricken kannst du selbst im normalen Zuhause ja diese Strickmaschinen haben, was früher viele hatten.
Ein Ding war ja auch riesengroß, da konntest du ja gleich vier oder sechs Farben direkt gleichzeitig einspannen und dann legt dir das Teil da los.
Aber das kannst du halt beim Nähen nicht machen. Also du musst trotzdem die Sachen zuschneiden, du musst die Sachen zusammenheften und die Nähte nähen. Das wüsste ich nicht, wie man das automatisiert.
Ich hab von einer, da hab ich jetzt bestimmt keinen Link parat, aber ich hab von so einer technischen, so einem technischen Durchbruch gehört, wo sie sozusagen diese Verzerrung des Stoffes durch das Benähen irgendwie mittlerweile auch mitgepasst bekommen. Und dadurch sozusagen diese Verzerrung, die entsteht. Also wenn du jetzt einfach ein Stück Stoff nimmst und du würdest jetzt einfach eine Kreisbewegung nähen, da machen, dann kriegst du halt keinen Kreis. Weil sich das sozusagen dadurch eben dynamisch zusammenknüllt. Genau, und das hat sie aber irgendwie raus, ich weiß nicht mehr so ganz genau.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, was sie da machen.
Wilden Kram.
Merino Schaf, genau. So kann es aussehen, wenn es zu lange nicht geschert wird.
Eine Wollmaschine.
Ich weiß nur, 27 Kilo hat das eine Mal, was sechs Jahre lang nicht geschert wurde, auf die Waage gebracht. Also 27 Kilo Wolle.
Es gibt hier übrigens auch schon gerade, wir haben das noch gar nicht erwähnt, hier gibt es ja auch gerade einen User, der heißt schon BingoBot. Ich glaube, der ist zwar eher manuell, aber man weiß es nicht. Aber das habe ich mich vorhin ganz vergessen. Wir haben ja unser schönes Freak Show Bingo. Und das Freak Show Bingo möchte natürlich auch schön integriert werden in diesen Chat. Und da sollten sich auch nochmal ein paar Freiwillige finden, weil es ist dann doch irgendwie eher lustig.
So, waren wir jetzt eigentlich mit Blackberry fertig?
Jaja, das haben wir durch.
Nachdem wir 23 Themensprünge gemacht haben, du hast ja sicherlich alle Kapitelmarken korrekt gesetzt und alle Verschachtelungen und Vernestelungen.
Meinst du, wir sollten jetzt mehr über Macs reden?
Gespeifte Klammer zu und so? Ne, müssen wir überhaupt gar nicht.
Aber über iPhones müssen wir reden. Nein, Champions League.
Das sind wieder die besten vier aller Länder, die spielen gegeneinander oder so?
Genau.
Wirklich vier?
Das hängt davon ab, wie viele.
Verdammt, das kann nicht sein.
Das heißt, es sind acht.
Ja, aber eigentlich stimmt es. Es sind die besten der Länder. Und wie viele Teams aus dem jeweiligen Land in die Champions League kommen, entscheidet...
Die größtes Landes und so blablabla.
Nee, der Erfolg der Teams in den letzten Jahren. Das heißt, umso mehr deutsche Mannschaften weit nach vorne kommen, umso eher wird irgendwann mal das Kontingent um eine Mannschaft erweitert oder bei Misserfolg entsprechend eingeschränkt. So läuft das. Aber jetzt haben wir auch unsere Grundisempflicht, was Champions League, was ist das, Viertelfinale betrifft, auch gerecht geworden. Irgendwas wollte ich doch gerade ansprechen. Wir hatten da eine Keynote letzte Woche.
Oh, na also das.
Vorletzte Woche.
Das nennst du Keynote?
Na ja, wir hatten ein Event.
Das nennst du ein Event?
Wir hatten gar nichts.
Also ich hab zwischendurch echt abgestaltet. Guck das freiwillig? Früher, als dieser Steve noch lebte, da war das ja durchaus eine Show. Also das war durchaus eine Show. Dann kam dieser Tim Cook, dann gab es jetzt schon ein paar größere Announcings zu seiden, aber es ist einfach wirklich tote, also schlafende Füße, eingeschlafene Füße. Und der letzte Event war wirklich die Krönung der eingeschlafenen Füße. Also wenn es jemals eine Goldmedaille und Preisverleihung Champions League der eingeschlafenen Füße, das war letztes... Also jetzt mal ehrlich, war ja ganz nett mit dem Ökostrom und dem Recycling und so. Aber dafür holt man doch jetzt nicht Millionen Menschen vor den Bildschirmen, um diese Message zum Beispiel rüberzubringen.
Es gab einen Robot, der iPhones auseinanderbaut.
Hier im Slack gibt es Tumbleweed, glaube ich, als Emoticons. Hat er nicht freigeschaltet. Du musst mal die Skype-Emotikons freischalten, weil die haben echt gute Sachen. Tumbleweed und so.
Wie die Skype-Emotikons?
Du kannst bei Slack so Emojisets freischalten.
Ach so, echt?
Mach mal da die Skype-Emojis noch frei. Aber, ja, also ist ja auch ganz schön, dass jetzt dieses Telefon da in altem Formfaktor mit mehr Features und so bauen, aber...
Das fand ich ja sehr beeindruckend, dass sie von den Milcherschokoladen wieder weggekommen sind. Ich kenne einige, die das ganz gern...
Ich weiß nicht, wo man das freischalten soll mit diesen Emojis.
Das können wir ja später nochmal gucken.
Gut, aber grundsätzlich müsste doch diese Keynote dein Ding sein wegen dem SE. Das ist doch deine Zukunft, das ist gerettet. Das ist doch so, als wenn Blackberry sagen würde, sie bringen wieder eins mit Tastatur, oder?
Na, für sie wäre das so, als würde Apple ein iPhone mit Tastatur raus.
Ja, und eine SD-Karte vielleicht noch. Aber da erwartet man vielleicht zu viel.
Medien sind irgendwie, ist vorbei. Medien, also USB-Stick, SD-Karten, alles, was irgendwie so physikalisch ist, ist vorbei.
Na, ich nutze auch noch Papier, sagte man ja.
Also ich weiß, dass es nötig ist, weil, wie meine Freundin ja auch schon immer sagt, hier ein iPhone kann ja nicht mehr per Bluetooth-Dateien durch die Gegend schieben, also jedenfalls nicht so im offenen Standard.
Geil!
Eigentlich SD-Cards ist durch. Aber jetzt zurück zum iPhone SE. Du musstest das doch richtig gefeiert haben, oder? Weil du hattest doch schon Angst, dass dein 5S, du hast dir doch schon schnell eins gekauft, bevor du hast einen 5er vor, bevor sie irgendwie alle weg sind, weil die gab es ja auch schon nicht mehr richtig, du hast das ja gut, als das schon eigentlich, als das 6er schon da war.
Genau, als das 6er rauskam, habe ich mir einen 5S gekauft.
Genau, weil du wusstest, das ist ja das, der letzte V8, wie sagt man, also das letzte geile Telefon.
Das vorerst letzte geile Telefon.
Was jetzt dann auf dieser Veranstaltung abgelöst wurde durch das SE. Alles drin, alles modern, aber kleiner Formfaktor. Und dass der Touch-Dings da so ein bisschen langsam ist, ist geschenkt, das Schnelle ist eher fast hinterlich, weil man kann nicht schnell mal Uhrzeit gucken, ohne dass man immer gleich eingeloggt wird, und dann hat man die Uhrzeit nicht mal gesehen, weil es so schnell geht. Und Apple Pay hat es auch. Hatte das Film bei ja auch nicht. Schnellerer Prozessor, schnellerer Grafik.
Alles das Gleiche außer Force-Touch.
Genau, was kein Schwein braucht. Hast du es jemals benutzt?
Nur versehentlich.
Kannst du mir das mal demonstrieren?
Es ist wirklich enthaltig fest. Es ist der Brüller.
Ich fände es ganz fancy, aber ich habe auch noch kein Telefon.
Kann man das eigentlich benutzen? Nodes kannst du länger drücken. Wenn du richtig draufdrückst, dann kommt hier so ein Kontext.
Du musst das mal selber machen, weil das vibriert.
Das macht so einen Klick quasi. Force-Touch auf die Nodes.
Das vibriert nicht.
Das macht so ein kleines Schnucki. Mach nochmal.
Das ist auch kein Vibrieren.
Das ist ja auch so ein kleiner...
Nein, das ist kein Vibrieren.
Das kann wirklich vibrieren. Das schnuckt nur halt so ein bisschen an.
Und dann kannst du halt hier so, wenn du auf Webseiten gehst, dann mach ich mal irgendwie so eine Webseite auf. Cancel, cancel, Webseite hier, bla, bla, bla, spiegel.de und dann kannst du jetzt hier Force-Touchen auf den Link und kriegst ein Preview. Und wenn du loslässt, ist der aber wieder weg. Und das ist das sinnloseste Feature von allen. Wie ich das hasse.
Ja, mehr ist eh auch nicht drin.
Du kannst es dann so irgendwie hochziehen und dann sagen, ja, jetzt will ich es doch ins Tab, aber...
Ja, das braucht man überhaupt alles gar nicht. Das ist voll für den Arsch.
Das Einzige, was das SE nicht hat, was ich gerne hätte, sind 128 GB Speicher.
Du hattest vorher aber eins mit 128 mal, oder?
Nein, ich hatte noch kein zwei. Ich hatte bisher nur ein 5S und das hatte noch nie 128. Das gibt es erst seit der sechster Serie.
Aber es gibt doch iCloud, hast du doch selber gesagt vorhin.
Nein, nein, nein, er kann ja nicht alles in die Cloud laden, weil dein Handyvertrag wahrscheinlich nicht so zulässt.
Der Handyvertrag hat damit der Cloud nichts zu tun. Ach so, doch, da musstest du es ja auch da durchschieben. Also wenn man es mal so sieht, kassieren ja doppelt. Also Apple kassiert, dass du das da reinschiebst und die Telekom kassiert, weil du es da reinschiebst.
Hier wird übrigens gerade gefragt, ob denn niemand Force-Touch benutzt, um den Cursor zu bewegen.
Nee, das geht auch überhaupt gar nicht.
Wieso?
Es ist zu fummelig irgendwie.
Du kannst auf der Tastatur Force-Touchen und dann hast du so Cursor-Movement.
Was du noch nie benutzt?
Auf der Tastatur?
Ja, wenn du was schreibst.
Du bist hier drin und jetzt drück mal unten doll drauf.
Auf die Tastatur irgendwo.
Erst mal deinen Cursor setzen, also ein bisschen Text musst du ja drin haben und dann drückst du ein bisschen doller jetzt mal in der Tastatur. Genau, und jetzt bewegen. Ich kenne das auch und habe das auch noch nie benutzt. Vielleicht auch, weil man es einfach vergessen hat, die dann natürlich, aber ich glaube auch nicht.
Ja, seit 1993 geht das super.
Na, vielleicht haben sie es besser gemacht. Ich wollte es doch mal üben, kann schon sein.
Sagen wir mal so, das wäre eventuell ein, aber so wie sich das jetzt hier anfühlt, also ich weiß nicht.
Ich glaube, das ist nur für dich ungewohnt. Ich habe so eine ähnliche Funktion auf dem Blackberry, nutze sie total häufig, weil ich es aber auch von da kenne. Ich mittlerweile halt relativ viel wieder, genau.
Ja, aber gut, man kann den Cursor mit Force Touch benutzen.
So oft macht man das aber nun mal nicht. Selbst wenn das Feature cool wäre, was ich noch nicht genau weiß, benutzt man es halt so selten, dass es irgendwie nicht so spannend ist. Man vermisst da nichts, wenn man das nicht hat, finde ich.
Ja, also ich weiß, warum das nicht drin ist. Das passt da halt einfach nicht rein. Das braucht ja auch Platz und so. Und dementsprechend alles super. Also ich werde mir dieses Teil einfach kaufen und fertig ist.
Und das Schöne ist, es ist scheiße billig.
Ja, das habe ich auch gesehen in den USA. Es ist super günstig.
Also zu so einem Sechser, wenn man lauter Features, die man eh nicht will, auch nicht bezahlen muss, ist schon cool.
Also du kriegst es mit 64GB für 589 pro Tor in Deutschland. So und das ist okay. Also 500 netto.
Das ist 300 weniger, als wenn du das gleiche als 6S kaufst.
Genau, dann nochmal irgendwie Apple Care oben draufschmeißen. Für dich.
Die Front-Face-Kamera ist halt nicht so schön, aber gut.
Ja, aber ich bin eh nicht so eine Selfie-Queen.
Er hat ja auch keine Front-Face-Kamera, sondern wird es ja auch nichts. Was?
Ich hab keine Front-Face-Kamera.
Na ja, keine geile. Da sieht man halt aus wie so ein Schnittchen. Also nee, nicht wie ein Schnittchen, sondern...
Stulle.
In der Fleischerei-Auslage.
Wie eine Schmierwurst.
Mensch, du siehst aus wie eine Leberwurst.
Tja, also ich kann da nicht sehr viel mehr zu sagen als well done. Das ist irgendwie, glaube ich, das Telefon, was ich haben wollte und gut ist. Jetzt gucke ich gerade mal, wie ich das möglichst günstig irgendwie kriege, so mit Vertragsverlängerungsklimpen vielleicht. Und dann schauen wir mal weiter. Ja, und dann haben sie noch dieses iPad Pro vorgestellt, das finde ich ja so ein bisschen strange. Oder? Also ich fand das irgendwie strange.
Was haben sie vorgestellt? Ich habe ja abgeschaltet.
Na, das iPad Pro, das kleine, also das mittelgroße, wie auch immer. Also ich weiß, iPad Pro macht euch jetzt auch nicht so feucht, oder?
Was?
Also ich kündige schon mal einen Gast an für eine der nächsten Sendungen. Hab ich gestern ausgecheckt. Einen glücklichen iPad Pro-User.
Der den Stift hat und es zu zeichnen nutzt, kann es sein.
Ich sage auch nicht, dass das überhaupt gar keinen Anwendungsfall hat, aber mich persönlich interessiert das halt.
Ist schon klar, aber ich sage nur, es gibt da interessante Use-Cases, die ich auch selber so noch gar nicht gesehen hatte. Und natürlich kommt diese ganze Stiftnummer auch noch mit dazu. Und ja, was ich halt absurd finde, ist, dass sie halt diesem komischen iPad Pro auch diese Kamera spendiert haben. Und du weißt, was das bedeutet?
Nee, es gibt größere Selfie-Sticks.
Da stehe ich jetzt auch nicht den Übergang.
Wie beim iPhone 6 steht die Kamera hervor, bei einem iPad. Weißt du, das heißt...
Es kippelt.
Ich meine gerade, also unbenommen, Telefone jammern deswegen haben die Leute eine Hülle drum.
Ja, manche wollen aber eigentlich auch ohne Hülle.
iPad hast du auf dem Schoß, sitzt auf dem Sofa, keine Ahnung, Second Screen, was auch immer, spielst irgendwelche Spiele so. Aber wenn man irgendwas flach auf den Tisch legt, dann doch wohl so ein iPad Pro, wo man mit einem Stift drauf malt. Und dann kippelt das Ding.
Da gibt es da bestimmt einen richtigen Adapter dafür.
Ich meine, da gibt es doch gerade richtige Stände dafür.
So eine Filze, die du auch unter den Stuhl machst und dann gehts dir die unten drunter.
Bei dieser Präsentation hat doch wahrscheinlich Steve in der Mitte des neuen Rings mehrere Megawatt Energie erzeugt, oder?
Guck mal, die Leute im Chat sagen, es kippelt nicht.
Wieso soll es nicht kippeln? Wer es vorsteht, dann kippelt es.
Es kippelt nicht laut iPhone-Blog. iPhone-Blog ist eine verlässliche Quelle.
Das ist ein Propaganda-Magazin.
Die andere Seite guckt halt auch ein Stück raus.
Wir wissen nicht, was da rausgucken sollte. Und dann muss ja auf allen vier Seiten was rausgucken.
Guck mal, da sind sogar Augenzeugenberichte, liegt hier und kippelt nicht.
Echt? Es schwebt.
Wo ist denn die Kamera? Ist die in der Mitte? Weil drei Punkte zum stabilstehen reichen.
Dann erklärt mir mal, warum es nicht kippelt.
Jetzt kommt's.
Weil das iPad ein wenig nachgediecht ist.
Also ich meine, wenn da an einer Stelle etwas tiefer ist als an der anderen Stelle, warum kippelt es dann nicht? Also ich meine, es kann ja noch gar nicht sein, dass es nicht kippelt, oder?
Ja, also ich hab's halt nicht.
Also ich muss sagen, ich finde so die Chat-Response ist einfach mal deutlich agiler als...
Die haben ja immer noch diesen fetten Rahmen.
Naja, also man müsste es halt, da die Hörer das vor sich haben, ist es halt vielleicht...
Oder unter sich.
Oder unter sich, müssen wir den Hörern jetzt wohl erstmal glauben. Du kannst ja im Apple Store... Ach nee, da kann man die ja nicht aus der Haltung nehmen. Da kippt es auf jeden Fall. Ach so, und die haben ja hinten irgendwie so einen Blöppel dran.
Drei Punkte sind stabil. Naja, okay. Also, das muss ich mal auswählen. Hätte ich neulich sogar machen können, hab ich ganz vergessen. Wobei, im Apfelladen, da klippen ja dann alle ganzen...
Hat Vogel grad gesagt.
Ja, dann reden wir doch über was anderes, was wir von der Ahnung haben.
Ausnahmsweise. Ja.
Zum Beispiel könnten wir uns über JavaScript unterhalten.
Oh ja, davon haben wir ja alle sehr viel Ahnung, genau. Na ja, war ja immerhin mal eine meiner Lieblingssprachen.
Letty schon.
Weil du willst oder weil du musst, weil es da so viele tolle...
Der Kopfenzwang, nein. Nein, danke. Ich bin schon, sieht man vielleicht nicht, aber auch schon ein bisschen älter jetzt.
Aber hast du doch gesagt.
Ja, aber ich komm nicht direkt von der Uni. Ich hab's in der Uni auch nicht gelernt.
Wo meint ich das nicht?
Nee, in der Uni hab ich's nicht gelernt. Nee, Uni ist Java, reines Java.
Ja, Uni macht keinen Javascript, also wirklich.
Nee, ich hab's später erst mir angeeignet.
Da gibt's halt was man...
Freiwillig also, ich wollt dir ja schön eine Ausrede unterschieben, aber du hast ja nicht...
Der Gruppenzwang ist meine Ausrede.
Aber im Javascript-Land, das muss man halt sagen, gibt's halt einige ziemlich gute Graphic Libraries, die es einem sehr einfach machen, so Visualisierungen zu machen im Vergleich zum selber hacken und auch wenn man in R sehr viele Module zur Verfügung hat, um prinzipiell ähnliche Sachen zu machen, ist das halt ein ganz anderer Zoo und ganz andere Dichte oder ein ganz anderes Dickicht, wo man da durch muss.
Stimmt, ich hab halt vorher noch OpenGL genutzt mit einer Java-Anbindung. Das war echt nice, aber JavaScript kann das da schon ein bisschen einfacher gestalten.
Performt da nicht so gut, aber...
Es gab da ja so ein Incident, ich hab das mit einem Auge verfolgt, also damit ich auch jetzt nicht zu vorbereitet in dieses Gespräch gehe.
Sicher, besser ist das.
Aber wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe, korrigiert mich, wenn ihr besseres Halbwissen habt, gab es da diesen einen Developer, der halt so diverse Pakete schon für JavaScript hergestellt hat und unter anderem als NPM-Pakete bereitgestellt hat.
NPM ist ja ein Note-Package, ja, das ist der Note-Package-Manager, aber es gibt ja noch viele Ebenen.
Package-Manager gibt es da viele, oder unterschiedliche zumindest, und das ist halt einer davon. Und dann hat er irgendwie ein neues Paket rausgebracht, von dem ich jetzt nicht genau weiß, womit es sich überhaupt befasst hat, aber es hieß irgendwie Kick, KIK, und dann gab es irgendwie von irgendeiner Firma, die meinte auf diesen Namen ein Markenrecht zu besitzen, eins auf die Nuss, das hat die mir dann irgendwie nicht interessiert und hat gesagt...
Nee, hat gesagt, glaube ich, das......gibt mir aus der Sonne. Also er würde den Namen bereitstellen gegen Geld.
Achso, das hat er auch noch gemacht.
Das war, glaube ich, auch noch...
Das fand ich aber auch nicht so geil, weil die dachten einfach, da klagen wir jetzt einfach durch.
Na, die dachten, es ist irgendein kleines Arschloch, das wir einfach mal über den Tisch ziehen können.
Ja, kann man ja auch verstehen, weil die wollen ja irgendwie wahrscheinlich selber Geld verdienen. Oder zumindest sind sie der Meinung, dass irgendwie so ein komisches Tool in irgendeinem JavaScript-Wald da irgendwie störend ist. Ich meine, die sind ja dann auch teilweise so ein bisschen immer so hinterher, weil sie immer Angst haben, wenn sie nicht alles in Grund und Burgen abmahnen, was weit rein nicht auf den Bäumen ist, dass sie dann Probleme kriegen, wenn sie die Ansprüche auf ihre Markenrechte machen wollen in irgendeinem Feld. Und jetzt im Software-Bereich ist natürlich potenziell irgendwie alles im Konflikt, was drei Buchstaben lang ist. Dann sind sie aber irgendwie zu diesen Leuten, zu dieser Firma gelatscht, die halt NPM managen. Und das ist halt, das wusste ich zum Beispiel auch nicht, dass da so eine Company ist, die irgendwie NPM macht und dass das irgendwie kein Community-Ding ist.
Wie war denn das nochmal?
Ich bin mit Namen schlecht.
Ich hab das jetzt auch nicht parat. Und die haben das dann irgendwie gepullt. Die waren irgendwie der Meinung, sie müssten da irgendwie compliant sein. Und das fand dann der Developer irgendwie nicht so geil. Und hat dann so in der Reaktion alle seine Pakete von NPM irgendwie gepullt. Was natürlich das Problem macht, dass ja ein Package-Manager-System andere Software auch darauf dependent, diese Pakete benutzt, deswegen sind die ja da drin. Und in 0,0 nix brachen halt so diverse Deployments around the world, von nicht ganz unnamhaften Projekten auch, weil sie halt super mega wichtige Module auf einmal nicht mal fanden.
Ihr musst aber auch natürlich, wenn jetzt schon mal super wichtig bist, erzählen, was das Modul getan hat, was so weltwichtig war.
Ja, das ist sozusagen die Architektur der Zukunft. Oh ja. Es handelt es sich glaube ich um 20 Zeilen JavaScript oder so etwas?
11.
11 Zeilen, wobei das auch schon geil ist, dass man dafür 11 Zeilen braucht.
Ja, du aber, wenn man eine Sprache ohne richtiges Standard Library hat, dann...
Genau, da kommen wir nämlich jetzt eigentlich auf den eigentlichen Punkt, auf den ich sozusagen so sprechen kommen wollte. Also LeftPad hieß das Modul und die einzelne Funktion da drin hieß genauso und sie machte, was genau, sie paddet einen String.
Left.
Heißt, fügt Leerzeichen ein oder nullen oder mit irgendwas?
Du kannst halt sagen, hier mein String soll 20 Zeichen lang sein und wenn er nur 8 Zeichen lang ist, fülle halt links mit so weit bis es halt 20 ist. Klassiker der Textformatierung.
Ja, also...
Auf dem Computer.
Gefühlt war das irgendwie in Printf, in C irgendwie schon gelöst, das Problem. Und offensichtlich gibt es halt die Sprache so nicht her. Und dann hat halt jemand so ein Modul gemacht und dann haben halt alle möglichen Megaprojekte dieses Ding verwendet, weil sie der Meinung waren, dass sie diese eine Funktion brauchen. Und naja, wenn es schon da ist, dann schreibt man das ja nicht neu. Das ist ja irgendwie so diese Verlockung des modernen Internets mit Wolken und all dem, dass man so denkt, so, ah, wir holen uns das einfach rein.
Das war eine satire Reaktion, aber hier schreibt sie gerade, da gibt es jetzt als Microservice leftpet.io, am besten noch im Docker-Container, so in der Amazon Cloud zum selber hosten oder hosten lassen mit Autoscale und so. Ja, also es gab da auch so ein Artikel, der hieß dann so NPM in Left-Pet, have we forgotten how to program? Und der hat dann mal ein bisschen weiter in diesen NPM-JavaScript-Ökosystem geschaut und hat dann weitere großartige, wirklich wahnsinnig wichtige Module und Libraries gefunden, die man selber nicht implementieren sollte und garantiert als Dependency haben sollte. Und da war zum Beispiel so etwas dabei wie IsPositiveInteger, vier Zeilen, und das selber hatte drei weitere Dependencies.
Wir haben uns vor kurzem erstens Spaß im Büro gegönnt und geschaut, was es denn noch so für Node-Module gibt, die noch den freien Namen haben mit irgendwie Ist True und so den ganzen Rods und Is Not a Function oder sowas. Und es gibt in der Tat auch dafür...
Es gibt einen Package, der heißt IsArray, der jeden Tag 880.000 Downloads hat. 18 Millionen Downloads im Februar 2016 und 72 Dependent-NPM-Packages. It's one line of code.
Da hat man schon mehr Zeilen in seinen Code reingeschrieben, um dieses Modul einzubinden, als man gebraucht hätte, um diese Funktion einfach selber zu machen.
Weil es sich viele Leute lustig gemacht haben, da meinten die, da was gibt es ja alle. Ja, Moment mal, das könnte ja in jedem anderen Programmiersprachen, Package Manager, Ökosystem halt auch passieren, wenn jetzt aus C-PAN irgendwelche Pakete rausfliegen oder aus Ruby, Gems oder was auch immer. Und so prinzipiell, ja, ist auch ein Bedrohungsszenario in anderen Ökosystemen, klar. Aber so die Qualität von dem Problem ist halt so. Also das eigentliche Problem dahinter ist, hab ich jetzt so noch nicht gesehen in der Form.
Vor allem richtige Programmiersprachen haben ja für die ganzen Sachen auch einfach mal ganz normale Ausdrücke in der Sprache schon drin.
Ja, genau.
Und das ist halt ein bisschen das Problem. Was sich hier so durchschlägt, ist einfach, dass diese Unterspezifiziertheit und diese Unterkomplexität von JavaScript an sich, die haut's irgendwie hier um die Ohren.
Ja, aber ich würd gar nicht sagen, dass JavaScript Unterkomplex ist. Also JavaScript, the Definitive Guide hat meines Wissens 1400 Seiten. Und die sind nicht bedruckt, das kann ich dir sagen.
Da steht nicht, welche Module man benutzen kann.
Sagen wir mal, das ist unterdefiniert. Wo man dann halt für so viel um einen heißen Bereich schreiben muss, bevor man es halt so richtig versteht. Also es ist schon so ein bisschen Matschepampe.
Also ich hab ja auch dann irgendwie, also ich meine, ich hab wirklich, ich fand früher immer JavaScript total toll, aber das lag auch daran, dass ich damit halt im Web so einfach mal Sachen wuppen konnte und irgendwie damit so objektorientiert ist, programmieren mit was sehen und es passiert was und ich kann irgendwie auf einer Webseite was damit machen. Das hatte mir halt großen Nutzen gebreitet, als ich dann immer weiter so vom Frontend weg ins Backend gewandert bin und dann mit Ruby und jetzt mit R-Lang irgendwie zu tun, also ich kann halt jetzt JavaScript einfach nicht mehr ernst nehmen. Das ist so vom Ökosystem, von dieser ganzen, von diesem ganzen Wust und dieser verplant halt dieser ganzen Sprache, einfach, ich kann, ich, also wirklich.
Es ist einfach nicht für Erwachsene.
Ja, nee, es ist wirklich kaputt einfach, also funktional kaputt wäre an der Stelle durchaus angemacht. Und da gibt es eine zahlreiche Beispiele, wie kaputt diese Sprache ist. Und wenn dann Leute hingehen und sagen, ja, aber, äh.
Da gibt es doch ein Node-Package dafür.
Und ein Grunt und ein, was auch immer, weil da gibt es ja tausende Package-Bundle, hast du nicht gesehen, Fuh man Schuh, aber darum geht es auch gar nicht. Ist einfach kaputt. Also damit, also ich, ich fühle mich jetzt schon schmutziger, wenn ich von funktional auf objektorientiert programmieren wechseln muss und bei JavaScript da, da muss man mich hinterher dann in die Dekontaminierungskammer erst mal stecken und drei Tage in Quarantäne. Nein, Quatsch, aber es ist, es ist schon wirklich ein ganz schöner, weiß nicht, Qualitätsunterschied vom Ökosystem, Standard Library et cetera pp und wie kaputt so eine Sprache ist und eigentlich ist es halt wie in allen beim Programmieren, also zumindest sehe ich das so und eigentlich alle Leute, die ich so schätze, sehen das glaube ich genauso. Also Keep it Simple ist so ein genereller Ansatz beim Programmieren, der einfach immer für mehr Entspannung sorgt und eine Programmiersprache, die wenig Konstrukte hat und mit wenig Konstrukten auskommt, ist mir prinzipiell immer sympathischer, also sowas wie zum Beispiel Erlang hat halt nicht viele Konstrukte, so eine Sprache wie Go hat auch sehr wenig eigentlich innere Konstrukte und ist aber trotzdem ziemlich mächtig. Oder so eine Klammersprache wie Schieben oder Lisp kann man nämlich immer so, finde ich, dazuzählen, weil da halt so viel in diesem Common Lisp da so noch dazukommt. Aber so prinzipiell, nehmen wir mal Schieben, das ist halt super spartanisch eigentlich, was da in der Sprache drin ist und trotzdem hast du halt die volle Mächtigkeit und du kannst halt, du hast so eine gewisse, so der Begriff... Expressivität. Ja, nee, aber auch der Horizont, der nötig ist, um diese ganze Sprache so zu erfassen und was möglich ist. Im Vergleich, das krasse Gegenbeispiel wäre wieder sowas wie C++, wo es für jede mögliche Lösung eine Aufgabe halt, also es gibt einfach zig verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Schon alleine, wie man Variable definiert. Das ist schon eine richtig gute Metrik, ja. Also es gibt Sprachen, da gibt es 13 verschiedene Arten Variable zu definieren. Und jeder hat irgendwie eine andere Auswirkung an C++, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe. Das kann ich nur so vom Hören sagen, von Leuten, die sich darüber aufregen. Aber genau da ist zum Beispiel auch das Problem, dass sie jetzt auch im Jahre 2016 darüber diskutieren, dass man jetzt noch einen anderen Konstruktor einführen müsste, der an der Stelle noch was anders macht als der andere und so weiter. Ja, und an der Stelle ist JavaScript halt auch nicht viel besser, weil da ist einfach so viel offen und, wie du halt auch sagst, undefiniert und kaputt. Einfach wirklich total kaputt. Das, ja, weiß nicht, das kann man nicht ernst nehmen. Sorry, liebe JavaScript-Leute, ich weiß, es ist schön, weil ich bin ja auch, ich hatte es auch genau aus diesen Gründen und so weiter, aber, und gerade dann noch diese Fraktion, die das so sagt, ja, geil, endlich, die gleiche Sprache im Frontend und im Backend. So, und immer den Code nur einmal schreiben und so, und dieser feuchte Traum von schon immer. Nee, Leute, wirklich.
Ja, naja, also ich kann ja den Reiz verstehen.
Ja, der Reiz ist klar, das ist genauso wie der Reiz, dass man auch im 21. Jahrhundert irgendwie einfach so den Rechner aufklappt und drucken möchte oder Siri jeden Wunsch von ihren Lippen ablässt. Dass man das will, ist klar, aber es bleibt, wie viele andere Wünsche irgendwie so unerfüllt. Oder Java, compile once, run everywhere. Das ist zum Beispiel auch um heute, das ist halt auch total kaputt eigentlich, seitdem Oracle das gekauft hat. Weil letztens haben wir zum Beispiel nur kurzer Abschweif, wie kaputt so manche Ökosysteme sein können. Seitdem Oracle ja Java oder Sun gekauft hat, ist ja die JVM nur noch so auf Blessed Operating Systems offiziell von Oracle supportet. Auf allen anderen Plattformen gibt es dann halt das OpenJDK und da müssen sich irgendwelche Maintainer finden, die das maintainen. Zum Beispiel wollten wir letztens JDK8 oder JRE8 auf FreeBSD benutzen. Da hat irgendeine Software benutzt, irgendeine Funktion, die irgendeinen Syscall benutzen will, der auf FreeBSD nicht implementiert ist im OpenJDK. Wenn Oracle es nicht supportet, dann crasht dir halt die JVM weg.
Aber trotzdem muss man sich natürlich überlegen, was ist denn jetzt eigentlich die Zukunft? Weil JavaScript ist jetzt so ein bisschen der Platzhirsch, weil es ist halt überall so und es geht natürlich jetzt auch so ohne Weiteres nicht weg und was anderes gibt es halt nicht. Die einzige Möglichkeit, nicht in JavaScript zu programmieren und im Browser präsent zu sein, ist so etwas wie CoffeeScript, sprich, du schreibst halt eigentlich JavaScript aber ohne die offensichtlichen Unzulänglichkeiten der Syntax zum Beispiel oder du benutzt eben sowas wie ClosureScript und hast halt eine ordentliche Programmiersprache, die halt in JavaScript compilert, was dann aber auch wieder so ein bisschen diese ganze Absurdität des aktuellen Systems so ein bisschen in Frage stellt. Aber in dem Moment, wo man JavaScript eigentlich nur noch als Runtime benutzt, also quasi als VM, könnte man ja auch genauso sagen, warum greifen wir nicht einfach die Idee von der Java-VM nochmal auf und definieren so eine Art Web-VM, weil letztlich ist auch JavaScript nichts anderes. Das hat irgendwie so eine Art Bist zu seinem Browser und hat halt irgendwie Primitiven, die man zum Ausführen bringen kann. Und die sind zumindest auch so primitiv, dass man eben sogar einen Compiler dafür schreiben kann, der eine andere Programmiersprache da ablaufen lässt. Also wenn du einen Lisp in JavaScript ausführen kannst, das sagt ja schon mal eine ganze Menge darüber aus. Also könnte man ja im Prinzip auch gleich hergehen und sagen, okay, dann lassen wir diese JavaScript-Sündags einfach auch komplett weg und definieren jetzt eine Web-VM und dann kannst du mit deiner Programmiersprache auf Choice da in den Browser rein.
Ja, aber dann ist halt bei solchen Sachen ja oft immer so das Problem, das gibt's ja ganz viel, das sind halt irgendwelche Grüppchen, die sich so irgendwie mit zu viel Zeit und Motivation und so sagen, okay, wir machen das jetzt mal, ist ja alles möglich. Und dann, ja, dann hängt das aber auch davon ab, wie viel Power die da wirklich reinstecken, um dann halt zum Beispiel Bugs zu fixen, die gefeilt werden im Projekt. Und es gibt halt auch zahllose Beispiele, wo natürlich Sachen erst mal noch nicht so ganz gehen und zum Beispiel so Projekte wie JRuby oder J-Python, wo irgendwie Ruby oder Python auf die JVM importiert wurde. Wie lange die gebraucht haben, bis die überhaupt ansatzweise so feature-complete waren wie der C-Standard-Interpreter, das hat halt echt eine ganze Weile gedauert. Und ja, dann weiß ich nicht, ob ich meinen Produktionscode und weiß nicht, dass das Weiterkommen meines kommerziellen Produktes irgendwie vielleicht im Zweifel davon abhängig machen will, ob da so eine Open-Source-Gruppe irgendwie genug Manpower hat, um da so eine Meta- abstraktionssprache zu maintain und dem hinterher zu implementieren.
Ich rede jetzt nicht von irgendeiner Open-Source-Gruppe. Ich rede jetzt hier wirklich von W3C oder also ähnlich hoch aufgestellten oder WotWG oder was auch immer. Da wo sie sich jetzt um ECMAScript, also die Zukunft um JavaScript streiten, können sie sich halt genauso gut auch um Web-Vrm streiten, die dann browserübergreifend implementiert werden.
Aber da hast du wieder das Turbo-Super-Bin-Blitze-Walt- Stichwort Browserübergreifen gesagt. Die Entwicklung geht ja auch gerade wieder total auseinander. Also wir waren ja, ist so, weil der Chrome vom Marktanteil wird jetzt quasi der neue Internet Explorer oder der neue Goldstandard, nach dem sich alle richten. Und es gibt einfach diverse Webseiten. Da hast du mit Safari teilweise komische Effekte. Dann dachte ich mir, okay, nimmst du mal einen Firefox, weil ich ja sozusagen Google-Produkte gerade schon versuche, sagen wir mal minimalst möglich einzusetzen. Und dann stellst du halt fest, ey, die Seite, die funktioniert echt original, nur im Chrome, ja? Und von Opera, ich weiß nicht, die benutzen halt auch, die benutzen ja am Ende eigentlich fast alle Webkit aus der Firefox, wenn ich das richtig im Kopf hab. Aber trotzdem so dieser Traum von das Web und alles offene Standards und alles einheitlich, das ist einfach nicht so, ne? Also dieser Selbstdom-Sachen, so das, wo man denkt, das müsste jetzt bis zum letzten Bit eigentlich durchdekliniert sein. Guck dir die Style Sheets an, guck dir die JavaScript-APIs an, da ist lauter browserspezifisches Zeug drin, wenn du nicht jQuery benutzt oder irgendeine Library, die dir die ganzen Browser-Querks sozusagen abstrahiert. Web-Audio, Web-Video, all dieser Kram, WebGL ist von Browser zu Browser absolut komplett unterschiedlich teilweise, also das Horror.
Man ist aber auch auf ein anderes Modell umgestiegen in den letzten Jahren. Dieser Traum von alles ist gleich, den hat man ja auch schon ausgeträumt und den will man ja jetzt eigentlich auch aktiv gar nicht mehr so haben, sondern es ist halt klar, etwas, was zum Standard deklariert wird, muss überhaupt erst mal gut implementiert worden sein und das möglichst an mehr als einer Stelle. Und dann erst gibt man dem Segen. Das ist besser als dieses alte Modell, wo dann so in die Zukunft mehr gehandert wurde. XHTML 2.0 wird alle Probleme lösen und wir haben jetzt hier irgendwie zehn Akademiker drei Monate in Keller eingesperrt und guckt mal, was hier für tolle Ideen gekommen sind. Die Programmierer gucken sich das an und sagen so... Das war's dann. Da ist ja HTML5 in gewisser Hinsicht in seinem Ansatz sehr viel realistischer. Es gibt ja diesen Runtime-Bedarf. Alle wollen ja Vivid Web, aber alle wollen halt auch lieber das mal mit einer berechenbaren Runtime machen. Und wenn du halt sozusagen diese ganze Runtime nur so auf Source basieren lässt, dann ist es halt wonky. Ich stecke auch nicht zu sehr drin in der ganzen Ideenwelt. Ich denke mir halt nur, irgendwas muss geschehen. Es kann doch nicht sein, dass wir irgendwie nur in einer einzigen Poemiersprache...
Was jetzt ja gerade auch der total hippe Trend ist, zumindest was so ein bisschen buntere Web-Geschichten eingeht, ist ja das Unity, so diese 3D-Engine, womit jetzt alle möglichen Spiele programmiert werden. Die haben ja auch einen Renderer nach WebGL. Dann kannst du dir so einen WebGL-Schnuffi da rausrendern lassen. Und dann hast du halt so eine komplette App und kannst halt mit Unity das User-Interface auch wieder genauso auf allen Browsern gleich aussehen lassen, weil es ja WebGL und so weiter, dann ist das vielleicht die Zukunft dann am Ende. Benutzt man also doch wieder Java-Applets oder sowas in der Richtung mit WebGL. Und da kannst du ja dann wieder herum alle möglichen Sprachen auch am Ende verwenden. Aber dann ist wieder nicht mehr durchsuchbar und so. It is ein Scheiß mit dem Web. Ja, auf jeden Fall, also für Leute, die Web machen wollen und so, und sich da wohlfühlen, ist natürlich JavaScript trotz alledem nach wie vor unausweichlich, aber dann Leute wirklich, also für IsArray oder Leftpad oder so, auch mal einfach selber ein bisschen kurz grübeln, wie man das bauen könnte, weil...
Ja, vor allem scheint mir auch in dieser JavaScript-Community so ein bisschen der Prozess zu fehlen. Ich meine, wo ist denn bitte da der combined effort, um solche offensichtlichen Sprachschwächen dann auch mal irgendwie eingenordet zu bekommen? Also warum gibt's da kein offizielles Language Extention Pack, wo man das dann kollektiv reinpackt, weil man mal eingesehen halt so ja, das mit dem Leftpad, da gibt's wohl einen Bedarf und hier bauen wir jetzt sozusagen eine Library, die das mal so macht, wie man das eigentlich hätte schon in der Sprache haben wollen, aber es nicht gibt. Also hat man jetzt das und in dem Moment, wo man dann eben eine neuere Version hat, ECMA, keine Ahnung, was auch immer die Version ist, wo das dann endlich mal ordentlich ist, dann leitet diese Funktion quasi da rauf über.
Das Problem ist ja nicht, dass es so eine Libraries nicht geben würde. Zum Beispiel das Beispiel jQuery. Das hat ja einen riesigen Katalog von Features. Dann gibt es sowas wie underscore.js oder es gibt tausende wahrscheinlich Libraries, also auch wirklich große Libraries, die viel so Standard-Library-Funktionalität und auch DOM-Funktionalität zusammensammeln.
Aber das sind immer Projekte für bestimmte Bereiche. Ich rede jetzt wirklich Sprache.
Genau, aber selbst wenn es sowas geben würde, das ist ja in diesem Artikel, den ich da vorhin auch gepostet habe, sozusagen die Mentalität ist ja, ja, also man will so Komplexität verstecken. Also man will irgendwie auch gar nicht so jetzt irgendwie den eigenen Code mit so, mit so so einem Left-Pad beschmuddeln. Und also da gibt es halt so auch, habe ich in einem anderen Artikel, gab es so Auszüge aus so Diskussionen, womit gerechtfertigt wird, dass man halt is-ary oder is-positive-antiger. Das ist halt auch totales Java. Weißt du, ich habe letztens irgendwie auch mal so ein Java-Projekt aufgemacht und wollte irgendwie eine Klasse gucken, was die macht. Und dann gehst du wirklich so vom Klischee Factory Singleton, Integer, Bilder, whatever, ja, ja. Und am Ende ist in der Klasse wirklich nichts anderes außer eine Integer-Formatierung mit Printf drin. Aber du bist so durch 26 Klassen durch. Weil irgendwie muss irgendwie alles versteckt werden. Code-Lokalität ist auch ein echt großes Highlight für Codebases, wo man halt nicht mal jedes Mal 26 Klassen durchbrausen muss.
Ja, vor allem in dieser Situation, die wir jetzt haben, ist ja auch so, dass jetzt auf einmal du ziehst so ein beklopptes Paket aus so einem bekloppten Package-Manager und 20 Minuten später kriegen irgendwie diverse Projekte ihren Scheiß nicht mehr deployt. Das geht ja auch nicht. Ich meine, stell dir das doch mal bei euch vor.
Ja, wir haben alle, eigentlich so, dass es so eine Lesson learned eigentlich in den letzten Jahren. Also unsere Dependencies liegen erstmal eigentlich immer geklont auch bei uns auf dem Server, weil das ist auch bei den meisten Package-Managern, wenn du das dann halt mal neu installierst, also ganz lange Zeit war es halt zum Beispiel nicht Teil des Package-Managers, die Version festzunageln. Und dann schreibt man einfach nur den Namen und die GitHub-URL rein und dann installiert man das auf einer neuen Maschine und dann gibt es halt Versions 2.0 plötzlich und und API kaputt, ja.
Jetzt, wo ich gerade im Chat darauf hingewiesen werde, fällt es mir auch wieder ein, dass ich das irgendwie auch schon mal gesehen hatte. Es gibt tatsächlich eine, ist hier richtig, eine vom W3C angestoßene VM für Browser. In einem unklaren Zustand. WebAssembly heißt das. Das ist im Prinzip genau die Idee, die ich vorhin geäußert habe. Das ist halt so ein Abstract Syntax Tree, der halt so ein Binärformat hat, womit du im Prinzip so Code generisch beschreiben kannst. Und damit hast du halt so ein Sandbox Execution Environment. Und ja, in dem Moment, wo das halt nicht spezifiziert ist, kannst du im Prinzip für jede Programmiersprache dann auf derselben Rantime fahren. Dann musst du halt auch nur diese eine Rantime irgendwie.
Das ist ja auch cool. Was du haltest, warum ich da am Anfang noch so hier skeptisch war, war ja eben hier irgendwie, oder das so CoffeeScript oder Lisp zu JavaScript. Weil genau was hier zum Beispiel gleich als dritter Punkt steht, so Open and Debuggable, das hast du dann halt auch meistens nicht. Weil wenn du dann versuchst irgendwie zu gucken, warum jetzt dieser von CoffeeScript generierte Code irgendwie nicht das tut, was du machen willst, dann hast du da so ein Hairball-JavaScript-Wüste vor dir und verstehst halt auch die Welt nicht mehr. Also wenn du halt so eine VM hast, wo du dann auch so richtig schön durchsteppen und debuggen und so weiter kannst, dann ist das auf jeden Fall eine andere Nummer.
Da müssen wir mal ein bisschen interessieren, ob irgendjemand da einen Eindruck hat, ob das hier vorangeht oder nicht.
Kein Slack.
Ich hab letztens einen wunderschönen Java-Code gesehen, der super dokumentiert war. Derjenige, der versucht, das so zu programmieren, dass man es so wie durchlesen kann, dass du halt irgendwie von oben nach unten durchgehst in dem Code. Das war wirklich super dokumentiert. Also nicht nur so ein fitzlichen dokumentiert, war halt auch Server-Code. Ich bin direkt vom Stuhl gefallen. Das war richtig schön. Das war richtig gut dokumentiert und ein schöner Code.
Ich muss noch eine kleine Anekdote zum Westen geben, zum Thema Klischee-Java-Code. Ein Kollege von mir hat bei so einem größeren Berliner Start-up angefangen. Also jetzt mein Ex-Kollege, aber jetzt bei einem anderen größeren Start-up. Und er musste dann so beim Onboarding, das ging dann einen Monat lang erstmal alle Abteilungen kennenlernen und so mit so ein bisschen Testprojekt. Und ein Projekt war halt irgendwie, sie haben halt in diesem Start-up versuchen, sie haben sie ein extra Department mit allen Projekten und allen Sachen, die sie so machen und veröffentlichen und so weiter, irgendwie auch an einer Stelle zentral so zu sammeln. Am Ende, was es halt tut, ist es bei GitHub sozusagen in den privaten öffentlichen Repos durchzugehen und zu gucken, was es so gibt und das so zusammen zu generieren in den JSON und mit JavaScript zu render. Und deren Onboarding-Task war jetzt sozusagen das mal zu refactoren und dann hat er sich das halt so angeguckt und dann war das halt so richtig so universitärer Java-Code mit zigtausend Klassen und so weiter.
Immerhin haben sie die Klassen schon gekannt.
Er hat es aber dann am Ende halt mit dem Ruby-Skript ersetzt, was so einmal dieses Ding abscrapet mit einem Kronenjob, das in einem JSON-File schreibt auf die Platte und dann so einen kleinen Schnipsel JavaScript, der das dann am Ende ausliefert. Ich wünsche, ich könnte es euch zeigen, hat er mir leider nur ein Vertrauten vorführen dürfen, aber ja, das ist so immer wieder schön. Klischee Java-Code oder Klischee PHP-Code ist auch super.
PHP habe ich nie gesprochen. Kennst du classnamer.com?
Oh, das klingt sofort noch Spaß.
Ich weiß, in den Chat rein, weil du auch diese ganzen Factory und Singleton angesprochen hast.
Alle klicken im Chat schon drauf.
Du kennst halt diese typischen Java-Sachen. Es gab mal Singleton Girlfriend-Event, oder wie das hieß. Das hat sehr viel Spaß im Büro gebracht.
Das wird uns morgen den Tag im Backend-Channel, glaube ich, auch versüßen.
Das ist eine großartige Seite.
Und man weiß, so eine Klasse wird es auch geben. Wahrscheinlich hat er auch einfach nur irgendwie Github-Projekte gespielt und einen Katalog draus gemacht. Aber zu diesem Paketmanager-Thema, da können wir jetzt zu einem guten Beispiel kommen.
Das gute Beispiel.
Also der einzige Paketmanager, den ich kenne, der so einigermaßen die Erwartung an das 21. Jahrhundert erfüllt, ist für mich Homebrew. Für die Leute, die nicht USX benutzen. Was ist Homebrew? Also auf Mac OS X.
Das geht jetzt nicht um Bier.
Ne, genau. Es gibt einen Paketmanager namens Homebrew. Und früher gab es ja auf Mac Fink und Mac Ports.
Also Darwin Ports.
Genau. Mac Ports oder Darwin Ports, das war sozusagen das FreeBSD Portsystem, was sozusagen versucht wurde, auf Mac zu bringen und Fink war der Linux, APK, DPKG, die DPKG-Variante davon. Beides nur so mittelgeil, wobei Mac Ports da irgendwie immer so in Aktualität mehr und mehr die Nase vorne hatte. Und irgendwann kam halt so ein kleines Projekt daher und man meinte so aufmüpfigerweise, pass mal auf, wir machen das jetzt mal alles ganz anders. Und das war Homebrew und das war mir erst so ein bisschen suspekt wegen diesem Bier-Thema und ich dachte mir, okay, da saß jetzt wahrscheinlich einer wirklich mit so einem Kasten Craft Beer in den USA und so, ich mach jetzt mal, genau, hol mir mal eine Flasche, Kinder. Genau. Und das Geile an Homebrew ist, dass es halt auf Git basiert. Also das finde ich persönlich schon mal richtig großartig. Und die Pakete werden in Ruby geschnürt, was mir als Ruby-Afficionado durchaus entgegenkommt. Aber man muss auch sagen, für jeden, der nicht Ruby schreibt oder kennt, wenn man so ein Paketrezept sich so mal anschaut, das ist so einfach zu durchdringen, das kann jeder editieren. Das Schöne ist jetzt halt im Prinzip, also man installiert dieses Brew-Command und man sagt so, so Brew Search Paket und Brew Install Paket, so weit, so gut. Und die Pakete werden ähnlich wie bei anderen Paket-Managern halt auch von der Community gepflegt, soweit auch nichts Neues. Das, was ich damals schon, als es rauskam, ziemlich geil fand, ist, dass man selber Pakete sehr schnell erstellen konnte. Also wenn man einen Tarball, eine URL zu einem Tarball hatte, wenn man halt sagen, hier Brew, was weiß ich, create mit der URL, dann hat er dir so ein kleines interaktives Shell-Kommando gegeben, wo du irgendwie alle Details eingeben konntest, ob noch irgendwelche Compiler-Flex nötig sind, ob es nur Files sind, die irgendwo hin kopiert werden müssen. Hat dann so eine Formulier erstellt, also so ein Paketrezept, und dann konnte man das weitergeben und andere Leute konnten sozusagen diese Formulier benutzen. Und jetzt kommt halt der Clou. Man muss nicht, wie bei anderen Port-Systemen, sozusagen mit den Maintainern groß verhandeln und sagen, ja, aber mein Paket ist total relevant und mein Shell-Skript ist der Wahnsinn, ihr müsst es unbedingt in euren Katalog aufnehmen. Und in den meisten Fällen, wie das dann so ist, bei so Systemen mit so großem Daumen von oben drauf, das geht dann halt nicht für jeden Hans und Wurst. Und bei Homebrew ist es so, man kann einfach seine Formula auf ein Gitarreprepo legen und dann sagen, hier Leute tippt einfach BrewTap mein Gitarreprepo ein und dann wird das sozusagen in den Gesamtkatalog mit einem Wisch eingepflegt sozusagen. Das führt dazu erstens, dass wenn zum Beispiel einer überhaupt keinen Bock mehr hat, das Paket zu maintain, dass es super easy ist, einen Fork auf GitHub davon zu machen und sozusagen dann einfach an der Stelle weiter zu machen und die Convenience-Einbuße ist wirklich nur eine Zeile, die man copy und pasten muss. Zum Beispiel bei meinem Hostmux, bei diesem Shellscript, was ich da zusammen gewurstet habe für T-Mux, habe ich ja auch ein Homebrew-Formular gemacht und ein Gitarreprepo und auf der Hostmux-Seite habe ich dann halt gesagt, ok, Homebrew-User, bitte hier einfach copy und paste diese Zeile in euer Homebrew und dann kriegt ihr immer die Updates. Ja, wenn ich ein neues Release-Tag auf Gitarre pushe und ihr sagt, Brew Update, ihr kriegt das, kein Problem. Und das ist einfach so viel fluffiger und netter als auch das DPKG-System oder das Port-System generell. Bei DPKG, also auf den Ubuntu und so System, da kann man ja auch fremde Quellen sozusagen mit einbinden. Aber so, das ist einfach so einfach gemacht und so convenient und leichtgängig, großartig. Und im Prinzip ist das so, ja, weiß nicht, also mittlerweile denkt, weint keiner mehr MacPods oder Fink nach, also in keinster Weise. Und es ist tatsächlich auch sogar, habe ich jetzt kürzlich gesehen, es wurde wohl auch schon auf Linux portiert jetzt, dass man halt auch, wenn man auf die Linux-Package-Manager keinen Bock hat, kann man auch Homebrew sozusagen wahrscheinlich mit einem extra Repository auf Linux mittlerweile benutzen. Und jetzt kommt noch der richtige Brüller, habe ich letztens durch einen Kollegen rausgefunden. Es gibt ein neues Projekt, was auf Homebrew basiert und das heißt Homebrew Bundle. Und das ist wiederum eine Inspiration aus der Ruby-Welt. Wer sich mit Ruby schon mal beschäftigt hat, wird wissen, es gibt da diesen Bundler. Man kann sich da so eine Datei in sein Projekt reinlegen und sagen, welche Dependencies man gerne hätte mit Versionsnummer und so weiter, so ähnlich wie bei NPM auch. Und sagt Bundle install, wenn man das Projekt geklont hat und schwuppdiwupp gibts alle Gems in der richtigen Version und so weiter. Und jetzt hat einmal jemand gedacht, ja wieso machen wir das eigentlich nicht für Desktop-Software? Sprich, du kannst in dein Dot-Files-Folder ein Homebrew Bundle-File legen und sagen, ich brauch GPG, ich brauch Git, ich brauch ein Wim, ich brauch eine Z-Shell, ich brauch Alfred-App, ich brauch Slack-App, ich brauch Adium, ich brauch Firefox, ich brauch was auch immer. Transmission. Alle möglichen Software-Pakete, also Desktop-Apps. Und kann dann einfach Homebrew Bundle sagen, sobald man die Dot-Files geklont hat und schwuppdiwupp installierst du dir dein System so in den Zustand mit der Software, die du so haben willst. Und es gibt halt auch so natürlich weitere kleine Shell-Skripte, die du damit reinhängen kannst, wie zum Beispiel, ja, okay, geh mal jetzt noch auf die Seite und fetch mein Public Key oder keine Ahnung, ne? Solche Geschichten. Und das ist wirklich, das fand ich einfach eine saugute Idee, weil man kann sich halt ein Time Machine Backup machen, frisch nach dem Clean-Install oder irgendwie ein ZFS Snapshot kurz nach dem Clean-Install und dann den vielleicht bei einem Clean-Install wieder einspielen. Aber dann hat man halt auch das alte OS unterm Hacken sozusagen. Und ja, das fand ich echt eine saugule Idee und der Kollege hat sich, weil er durch so einen blöden, er hat sich halt so irgendein Virus eingefangen. Auf dem Mac war vielleicht sogar der Transmission-Virus und musste mal einen Clean-Install machen und hat da kürzlich von erfahren und hat dann irgendwie sein ganzes System erstmal in so einen Homebrew-Bundle quasi geschrieben, dann nochmal plattgemacht und dann mit Brew-Bundle wieder neu installiert. Und da war ich echt baff und dachte mir, das ist ja mal richtig geil. Und ich bin mir nicht sicher, aber ich glaube, das Ding kann sogar mit dem... Also jetzt bin ich ganz vorsichtig, sage ich das nur, aber ich dachte auch gesehen zu haben, dass er sogar was aus dem App-Store mit diesem Bundle installieren konnte. Hm, echt? Aber da kann ich mich auch verguckt haben. Weil ich dachte, er hätte eine App installiert, die es nur im App-Store gibt, aber das müsste man jetzt nochmal, wie gesagt, ohne Gewehr.
Und vielleicht eine, die es auch im App-Store gibt.
Vielleicht auch. Ja, also auf jeden Fall auch ein sehr cooles Projekt aus dieser Homebrew-Ecke.
Irgendwie gab es da jetzt auch ein signifikantes Release, gerade bei Homebrew, irgendwie jetzt hat auf einmal das Version 0.9.9 irgendwie so Ready for Primetime. Also macht sie den Eindruck, als ob sie gerade so strukturelle Umstellungen vorgenommen haben, die sie schon lange geplant haben. Also es wird da jetzt irgendwie in den Repros zwischen Core und anderen Sachen unterschieden.
Ja, sie haben auf jeden Fall so ein bisschen, das ist ein bisschen aufgefächert. Zum Beispiel sowas wie Homebrew Science und so. Aber ehrlich gesagt, weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht genau, was so die Motivation dahinter war. Also da habe ich nicht so viel drüber gelesen.
Ich glaube, bei dem Core ging es halt einfach sozusagen darum, erst mal so ein Core zu machen, damit es eben auch klein, dass klar ist, was sozusagen die minimale Größe ist. Hab das aber auch jetzt echt nur aus dem Augenwinkel gesehen. Es gibt ja auch diverse Repos, die hier so explizit mit Legacy getaggt wurden, umbenannt wurden. Und ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck, die sind sich innerhalb des Projekts einfach ihrer Struktur klarer geworden. Also die haben sozusagen den langen Weg, den sie jetzt gegangen sind. Wie lange gibt es das jetzt? Zwei, drei Jahre?
Schon auf jeden Fall ziemlich lange. Kannst ja mal den ersten Komit bei Gitarre angucken, aber ich würde auch mal gefühlt sagen, mindestens vier, fünf Jahre.
Wie für dich denn am schnellsten den ersten Komit?
Ah, da gab es so einen...
Weil hier kann man ja ewig scrollen.
Wollte das bei den Graphs nicht auch mit drinstehen?
Ja, könnte vielleicht bei den Graphs sein, ja. Das ist eine gute Idee.
Dass man da ein bisschen scrollen kann, meinst du?
Ja, du hast eigentlich eine Zeitreise. Nee, lass mal erstmal da drauf, glaube ich. 2009, oder?
Ja, Mitte 2009, also fast sieben Jahre sind sie da am Werkeln, okay.
Wer lesen kann, ist Klammvorteil.
Ja, was lange währt. Aber ich muss auch sagen, Homebrew war auch schon immer gut. Zumal es ja auch am Anfang so elegant dieses Problem gelöst hat, dass man eben auch einfach gegen den ganzen Kram, der schon da war, lenken konnte. Während die ganzen anderen immer erst mal das halbe Internet runtergeladen haben, bis man dann mal irgendwie...
Ja, was ja auch Vorteile hat, ist auch nicht nur schlecht. Aber mindestens die Option wäre gut. Sie haben jetzt halt den Default, und der passt halt auch in den meisten Fällen. Was übrigens auch sehr schick ist bei Homebrew, im Vergleich zu den allermeisten Package-Managern, ist so dieses automatische Environment-Linken. Du kannst halt einfach sagen, ich will jetzt diese Version in meinen Pfad gelinkt haben, oder ich will sie wieder rausgelinkt haben. Und das ist halt auch super komfortabel. Manchmal willst du halt das Homebrew Pearl oder Python oder was auch immer benutzen. Manchmal willst du halt das System Python benutzen. Und das kann so oft einfach so schmerzvoll sein, und dann sagst du einfach hier, Brew, unlink, hast du nicht gesehen, und dann ist das aus deinem Pfad raus. Und dann kannst du wieder das System Python oder was auch immer benutzen. Das ist auch ein super geiles Feature. Und wie gesagt, also so dieses Formeln editieren und neue selber erstellen ist auch super trivial. Die haben eine richtig schöne, schicke Anleitung. Wenn man die befolgt, hat man irgendwie innerhalb von zehn Minuten irgendwie seine Formel da fertig und kann die in GitHub Repo kippen und Leute können damit die Software installieren. Das ist wirklich eins-Ohr-Spitzen-mäßig und auch super, also wenn man seine Software mit GitHub schippt, das ist sowieso der allergrößte Knaller, dachte ich, weil ich habe das erste Mal diesen Host-Max, weil ich wusste, die Leute wollen jetzt nicht das in einem Homebrew drin haben, weil das viel zu futzelig ist für die, als dass es relevant wäre. Und dann habe ich halt so angefangen, okay, wie mache ich denn jetzt die Formel? Und dann steht dann gleich so ein Guide, na ja, wenn du ein GitHub-Repo hast, mach einfach ein Release Tag, dann baut ja GitHub auch einen Tabol und einen Zip dazu. Und dann musst du nur die URL sozusagen zu deinem Tag angeben und alles andere zieht er sich quasi schon von alleine, den Char1-Hash und alle anderen Informationen, die wichtig sind, um die Software zu installieren. Du musst halt nur noch sagen, okay, was sollen wir dann machen, wenn wir es gefetcht haben? Und in dem Fall war es ja nur ein paar Dateien kopieren. Und es gibt halt schon so vorgefertigte Makros in der DSL, um Mahnpages an die richtige Stelle zu kopieren, Config-Files an die richtige Stelle zu kopieren und so weiter und so weiter. Richtig gut. Das ist mal, da haben Leute mal richtig...
Nachgedacht.
Ja, oder, sagen wir mal, neu gedacht. Also, es gibt ja immer hier diesen Spruch, das Rad soll nicht dauernd neu erfinden, aber manchmal muss man es halt neu erfinden, sonst würden wir immer noch mit großen Steinrädern...
Da war so ein Bild mit den vier verschiedenen Rädern von irgendwie quadratisch dann rund heult, dann Gummi und jetzt irgendwie Full-Featured, Motorradreifen, so ungefähr.
Genau, und in der Stelle war das halt auch einfach richtig cool, so aus diesem ganzen Schmerz von diesem Fink und Mac-Ports heraus da mal loszulegen. Gibt natürlich auch ein paar Problemchen oder, sagen wir mal, nicht so coole Sachen, aber überwiegend positiv.
Heute schon in der Zukunft leben, das bringt uns zu einem neuen Themenblog.
Da will ich nur noch kurz abschließend sagen, ich wünschte halt sowas wie Ruby Gems, NPN oder was auch immer würde halt auch auf so einem GitHub basiert. Also bei Ruby Gems geht das auch so ein bisschen, aber irgendwie fühlt sich das bei Homebrew fluffiger an. Dass du halt auch einfach deine eigenen Forks ganz easy betreiben kannst. Also zum Beispiel eben für Dependency, Freezen für dein Projekt, machst du einfach Forks davon in deinem eigenen Account.
Alles wird gut.
Na ja, außer GitHub geht nicht, ne? Also wir haben, wir haben tatsächlich... Nein, wir haben...
Dein GitHub geht immer.
Ne, ne, deswegen, das ist der andere Grund, warum wir Gitmirrors haben, weil es soll halt auch schnell gehen, ne? Aber gut, nächster Themenblog, Klammer zu.
Ja, stimmt, ich war im Kino, jetzt wurde es Sargster.
Rollensound, volles Programm.
Geht so, geht so. Immerhin Leinwand, große Leinwand, also es war schon kinomäßig.
Also das hast du ja jetzt nicht ins Greener angeguckt.
Ne, die Blu-ray ist seit Montag draußen. Ach, ernsthaft? Und dann haben wir den Sonntagabend geguckt. Also ich würde mal behaupten, der JJ. Abrams hat diesen Job bekommen irgendwie, war wahrscheinlich schon Fan, hat sich die Star Wars-Filme alle angeguckt, hat seinen Rotstift genommen, hat alles weggestrichen, was er scheiße fand, was nicht wenig war. Und dann ist auch gar nicht so viel übrig geblieben. Und zwar ist übrig geblieben halt so ein Held, so ein bisschen Background-Story, viel Family-Story, ein cooler Android und auch nur noch einer, weil bei Episode 4 waren es ja zwei. Der eine Sprechende, dieser Blech-Dings, und der kleine R2D2, und der war ja nun... Genau, und der R2D2 war nun deutlich cooler. Das heißt, C3PO hat er auch weggestrichen. R2D2 hat er halt ein neues gemacht, weil es sollte ja auch ein bisschen schick aussehen. Das ist diese Kugel, die da so rumeiert. Was mir noch aufgefallen hat. Also wieder viel Family-Geschichten. Also so Bruder, Schwester, Vater, Sohn, Zeug, Zeug, Zeug.
Es geht um die Familie.
Ja, so ein bisschen schon. Dann irgendwie der New Order, ne, was war das? First Order ist irgendwie das Imperium. Spoilern wir jetzt, du hast es auch gesehen, ja?
Ist so an mir vorbei gegangen. Ich bin noch nie warm geworden mit Star Wars.
Bevor du anfängst zu gucken, hast du alles vergessen.
Du hast ganz viele Tote dann auch.
Also der war schon ganz witzig, auch Chewie hatte ein bisschen mehr Witz mit drin so, also weil er musste sozusagen, er hat im Hintergrund immer Han Solo kommentiert, fand ich witzig. Naja, auch mehr so, was der erzählt, dass jetzt gerade Scheiß eigentlich hatte, also es war im Hintergrund, wenn du auf den Hintergrund geachtet hast, dann hat Chewie Kommentare zu Han Solo abgegeben, also öfters, mir aufgefallen, so. Fand ich witzig.
Ich kann leider nicht so röhren wie Chewbacca, aber es gibt so, auf YouTube gibt es so diverse Videos, wo Leute sich da drin versuchen, es gibt so...
Also es ist jetzt, ich glaube schon immer, es ist schon auch ganz schön, also es ist besser geworden als die letzten drei Teile, die rauskamen, also mit Abstand besser. Also es war alles viel mehr spaßig und nicht so ernst genommen und...
Die letzten drei Teile, du meinst eins, zwei, drei.
Ich hab gesagt, die letzten drei, die rauskamen.
Vier, fünf, sechs, eins, zwei, drei.
Die ersten drei Episoden, die waren jedenfalls Müll und so war das jetzt ja auch nicht mehr. Kein Jar Jar Wings dabei oder keine wirklich nervende Figur eigentlich, oder? Nö, ging. Was ich nicht ganz verstanden habe, ist warum sie sich Max von Südl einkaufen für zwei Minuten Screentime. Ist ein bisschen schade, der Mann kann ja mehr so. Welchen?
Den aktuellen.
War er Schuhi? Das war der Original-Schauspieler in Schuhi. Und in C3PO glaube ich auch sogar, oder? Es waren ganz schön viele Original-Leute von damals.
Hab ich auch gehört, aber das kann ich mir fast gar nicht vorstellen, dass da immer noch derselbe C3PO-Mensch drin ist. Der muss auch mittlerweile am Stock gehen.
Wenn er damals 20 war, dann ist er jetzt 50.
Wahnsinn, das Kostüm.
Aber dieser einen Name, irgendwas mit Mayhew oder so was?
Wie heißt der nochmal? Bond?
Wen hat der gespielt?
Na, der hat den Stormtrooper gespielt, den Rey dann beeinflusst hat. Nein, man hat ihn nie gesehen, aber er war in diesem Kostüm, also wird behauptet.
Wird behauptet.
Ja, ich hab jetzt auch nicht so...
Aber bei der IMDb in die Cast...
Der, wo das zuerst nicht geklappt hat und der so, ja, ich mach jetzt mal die Fetzen fester.
Also der ganze Film ist voll mit Cameo, was du nicht merkst. Also es gibt da sozusagen...
College-Cameo, wenn es nicht mehr ist.
Das ist sozusagen ein Geschenk an die Community, die haben sozusagen die ganzen coolen Leute damit natürlich auch auf dem Set gehabt. Also das muss schon mit das geilste Set gewesen sein der letzten Zeit.
Er steht in der IMDb als Stormtrooper, uncredited.
Weil die wieder viel Spaß hatten.
Ja, aber das kann ja der JJ. Abrams im Prinzip ganz gut. Das hat er bei Star Trek, hat er das ja bei den Filmen im Prinzip genauso gemacht.
Was?
Na so die alten Werte bestelliert.
Hat sich angeguckt, was bei den Leuten ankam. Ja, ich glaube, das ist schon gut gelungen.
Ja, aber ich finde er hat nicht nur alte Werte, sondern er hat halt auch neue Werte gebracht. Na, ich bitte dich, Star Wars 7. Wer sind die Stars in diesem Film?
Na, die kleine Kugel, das Mädel.
Na.
Warten noch?
Wie hieß er noch gleich, der mit der Nummer, wie hat er sich genannt?
Ich habe es nicht gesehen.
Na, der konvertierte Stormtrooper. Eine Frau und ein Schwarzer sind die Stars des erfolgreichsten Films aller Zeiten.
Ist das so?
Na ja, wer denn sonst?
Nee, also das ist der Film der erfolgreichste aller Zeiten. Echt?
Das ist sozusagen das Neue.
Echt, ich dachte nur die Frau der Schwarze, der kam noch.
Die letzten 30 Jahre war das die, das war sozusagen die Kernaussage so, du willst einen erfolgreichen Film machen, dann brauchst du einen weißen Boy, der da irgendwie einen Helden spielt. Und jetzt ist das einfach nicht da.
Du hast Chef nicht gesehen, oder?
Chef war nicht der erfolgreichste Film aller Zeiten. Das war ein cooler Film. Es gibt viele coole Filme. Das ist keine coole, es gibt sehr, sehr hervorragende.
Wie hieß der Typ nochmal?
Schwarze Schauspieler, es gibt hervorragende weibliche Schauspieler. Aber wenn ein Blockbuster konzipiert wird, der das Ziel hat, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes zu zielen, war das bisher nicht das Erfolgsrezept. Und genau das hat er halt gebracht. Und es ist ja nicht nur so, dass es jetzt nur eine Frau ist. Das ist ja eine fantastisch coole Rolle, die sie da spielt. Rey und Finn, ich meine, die spielen einfach hervorragend. Und die ganze Rolle von der Rey ist doch einfach von vorne bis hinten ein Traum. Letty, das musst du dir angucken. Du wirst es geil finden. Die ist einfach mal der Hammer. Also die Rolle in diesem Film, wie das schon anfängt. Ja, wie sie sich damit geilt.
Du steigerst dich ja da mal so rein.
Nein, aber eigentlich muss man den Film nicht sehen.
Der Film ist hervorragend.
Auch den kann man schon sehen. Auch wenn man es nicht toll findet, kann man ja sich mal den anscheinend meistgeschauten, oder meistgeschauten nicht, aber am meisten eingenommen.
Die hat den Rekord ja schon mit Vorbestellung geknackt.
Auch schon inflationsbereinigt, das ist besser als von Wendel Verween. Da gibt es so eine Liste, wo das inflationsbereinigt gelistet wird, und dann sieht es ja noch mal ganz anders aus.
Ich habe jetzt die Buchhaltung nicht dafür gemacht, aber es ist auf jeden Fall klar, dass dieser Film nicht erfolgt geworden ist.
Ich finde, die Olle Fynn war jetzt nicht so mega spannend.
Und mit Rey wird ja natürlich ihre Family-Geschichte, kann man ja so richtig spoilern. Also dann haben sie am Ende ja noch gezeigt, sie trifft ihren Papa, würde ich mal behaupten.
Nein, das ist überhaupt nicht klar.
Ich sage das aber jetzt.
Ja, das ist eine pure Vermutung.
Ich vermute jetzt hier, dass sie da ihren Papa trifft, weil sie hat ja auch die Macht anscheinend, wo soll die sonst herkommen? Sonst wäre sie ja wohl die Schwester von dem Ben, heißt der Bösewicht, der Han-Solo-Sohn, oder? Habe ich jetzt nicht aufgepasst. Doch, genau, und den gibt es ja noch. Und das wird dann so, sie ist ja dann auch ein, wenn das so stimmt, ist sie ja ein Cousin, oder ja, Cousine von dem Ben, richtig? Wenn sie die Tochter von Luke ist.
Ja, wenn, vielleicht ist die Geschichte ja auch viel komplexer und entfaltet sich erst im nächsten Teil so. Aber darauf wollte ich jetzt gar nicht hinaus, was da irgendwie die Familien und wie sich das entwickeln kann. Das ist alles, das ist so...
Na boah, was fandest du denn so großgeil?
Das ist die erste Blockbuster Frauenrolle, wo die Frau null Stereotype verfolgt.
Oder die, hier, Panem, Retribute, Jennifer Lawrence.
Ja, jetzt kommst du mir mit, jetzt kommst du mir mit den beiden irgendwie. Da hast du natürlich...
Na, Ripley, schon vor 30 Jahren war das über. Dann hier letztens erst, was war es hier? Die haben so viele Oscars gekriegt, wo alle sich schon amüsiert haben drüber. War ja fast nur die Frau, der ganze Film. Ja, der vierte Teil jetzt.
Ach so, den hab ich nicht gesehen. War der irgendwie wichtig?
Nee.
Star Wars ist wichtig.
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Das ist die Movie, wo die immer mit ihren Enkeln hingehen können.
Das ist die Movie des fucking Star Wars, man.
Alter Schwede. Du musst das schon nochmal ein bisschen...
Ja, du weißt ja, das ist jetzt halt...
Durch die Realitätsbrille.
Auf jeden Fall ist sie einfach mal top Nerd. Sie hat einfach das mit den Raumschiffen raus, sie repariert, sie macht und tut und ist irgendwie alleine auf diesem Planeten und zieht das Programm durch. Ich find's einfach grandios.
Ich hab ja eigentlich schon mal Doctor Who gesehen. Also da ist jeder Weib... Doctor Who, jeder weibliche Companion ist Wahnsinn.
Ich kenn nur eine.
Ja, aber es sind ja eigentlich die wahren Dokoren, kann man schon sagen.
Ein weiblicher Companion?
Ja, er hat immer Companions, die mit ihm reisen.
Immer?
Immer. Selten alleine.
Ich kenn nur einen, wie nennt man das? Season? Eine.
Von den wieviel? 60 Seasons?
Was denn, wieviel?
Reicht schon nicht von den neueren.
Ich fand die auch ganz gut, dann hab ich irgendwie glaube ich kurz in einen anderen reingeschaut und dachte mir so, oh, ist ja ein anderer Schauspieler, den fand ich ja gerade so toll. Und dann war ich irgendwie so... Irritiert. Ja, dann hörte es auf. Also, den hätte ich mir jetzt noch eine Weile angeguckt. Keine Ahnung, wo der so im Ranking der Doktoren so steht. Ich frag mich jetzt, welcher das war. Keine Ahnung. Aber ich gebe zu, dass ich bei Dr. Who... Wir haben ja auch Dr. Who-Fans natürlich im Chat, ist ja klar, jeder Charakter ist der Wahnsinn. Ich muss mich dem glaube ich noch mal ein bisschen nähern.
Ja, weil da hast du wirklich gute Frauencharaktere dabei.
Guck dir Star Wars an.
Ganz ehrlich, sag mir noch, da kommt irgendeine komische Liebesgeschichte drin vor, dann...
Nein, das ist auch...
Ja, aber wie die deutet, sieht das schon an.
Großes Kino.
Ich glaube sogar, dass dieser... Wie heißt der Test? Wechteltest?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich hab meine Begriffe nicht zusammen.
Er sucht den mal raus.
Aber das Ding ist halt, Dennis, jetzt wo Apple nicht mehr Religion liefert, sondern nur noch biedere, öde Dinge, da muss sich Tim jetzt halt eine Ersatzreligion suchen.
Ich meine, um die Story mal zusammenzufassen, die müssen vor dem First Order flüchten, irgendwie Lux aufenthalts, die Lux suchen, wissen nicht, wo der ist, aber irgendwer, so ein alter Mann, wo man nicht genau weiß, wer es ist, nämlich Max von Sydow, hat irgendwie das auf so eine Art USB-Stick. Die geben das, der Kugel, die flüchtet, der Finn findet den, crasht irgendwo, findet dann auch gleich dieses Mädel, bum, bum, bum. Also das alles schon passiert ja in den ersten 15 Minuten. Und dann flüchten sie nur noch die ganze Zeit vor dem Empire, würde ich mal sagen, vor dem First Order. Und ja, schaffen sie halt, davon zu kommen. Und am Ende trifft sie halt dann noch Luke irgendwo. Also die Story ist schon auch ganz schön dünn, finde ich.
Das ist alles nur die Vorbereitung auf das, was danach kommt.
Evans ist aber nicht. Ist es der, der Lost gemacht hat?
Und Hanrem, ja.
Und weißt du, was bei Lost passiert ist am Ende? Also was alles aufgeklärt wurde von den gigantischen Anfängen, so wie jetzt bei Star Wars, nichts wurde aufgeklärt. Du bist raus.
Das Ende?
Und das Ende? Du warst nicht enttäuscht?
Du hast wahrscheinlich das Ende nicht gesehen.
Ich hab's Ende gesehen. Ich hab's wirklich komplett gesehen. Das ist wirklich eine der wenigen langen, ich glaub sogar die einzige lange von diesen ganzen...
Serien.
Aber Millionen Serien, die es mittlerweile gibt, die einzige, die ich wirklich komplett gesehen habe.
Und warum? Weil du wissen wolltest, was dieser ganze Scheiß jetzt eigentlich sollte, weil man halt die Auflösung wissen wollte. Und was ist? Es kam keine.
Oder irgendein pseudo-schwulstiges, wir sind jetzt plötzlich alle in der Kirche und ach so.
Genau so gleichbekloppt wie Shattestar Galactica.
Schalten sie auch das nächste Mal ein, wenn es wieder heißt, es geht weiter. Ja, weiß ich nicht mehr. Ich war da glaube ich nicht so emotional.
Und jetzt bitten wir sie zum Gebet. Wir halten uns an den Händen am Podcast-Tisch.
Ich war da nicht so emotional, nicht so investiert.
Ja guck, wenn die da so lauter Storys sind, der hat ja eine Story nach der anderen eröffnet bei Lost und mit diesen Background-Geschichten und hier und da und weiß nicht was alles und Zeug und hast du nicht gesehen. Und nichts wurde aufgeklärt.
Nichts.
Passt nichts.
Aber man muss sagen, der JJ. Abrams, der hat auf jeden Fall in den Filmen, Lost ist auf jeden Fall ein krasses Beispiel. Dann gibt es noch einen Film, ich glaube, der heißt Super 8. Ich glaube, das war der. Da hat er das auch so gemacht. Das ist so ein bisschen so ein Gruselmonster, hast du nicht gesehen, Film. Dann kommt auch so dieses Döst-Ex-Machina, also hier eine Superkraft, die alles erklärt und alles, was vorher da war, an Mystery und komischen Fragen.
Super 8 war doch Spielberg, oder? Wo der Zug dann einen Unfall hat.
Das war doch Spielberg, oder? Nee, der hat ja mitgemacht. Also End Producer. Also er war Producer und JJ.
Das war halt so ein Alien-Tralala-Movie. Da find ich das dann auch nicht so schlimm.
Dann bei Lost hat er das halt auch gemacht. Und ansonsten, also so die Klassiker, also auch bei Star Trek hat er zwar viele Storys so noch ein bisschen verwurstet und aufgesprungen. Ah nee, Cloverfield war das, glaube ich.
Ja, sowas hab ich noch nicht geguckt.
Egal. Auf jeden Fall, er hat schon so ein Kleinfabel für so diese übernatürliche Erklärung. War das nicht auch Fringe? War das nicht auch von JJ.
So und Timme kann in der Zeit jetzt seinen Bechteltest machen.
Doch, genau. Fringe war auch davon. Und Fringe war auch so eine super abgefahrene Time Travels Freak Agenten-Serie. Hast du das niemals gesehen? Die hatten auch so einen Professor, der die auch teilweise auf LSD getrippt hat, damit sie irgendwie ihre multidimensionalen Missionen lösen und so weiter. War alles sehr geil eigentlich. Aber auch da war halt immer mal wieder so dieser JJ. Abrams-Moment, wo man dachte so, Alter, mach doch mal eine coole Erklärung und hol nicht immer so den billigen Erklärlöffel raus. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass er das bei diesen...
Die schwere Arbeit ist, dass das, was sie sich alles einfallen, am Ende auch logisch ist und irgendwie alles zusammenpasst und das habe ich so die Ahnung, dass der Typ da irgendwie nicht so seine Priorität ist. Aber jetzt mach doch mal diesen Bechteltest, wenn du meinst, das Mädel ist da...
Ja, also Star Wars besteht den Alien-Uris auch.
Nee, das ist jetzt ein bisschen leicht für unsere Zuhörer, die den nicht kennen.
Aber, was?
Den Test mit den Punkten, da kann man doch so...
Du kennst den Test nicht.
Ja, nicht aus dem Kopf jetzt.
Ach so, also Bechteltest ist, nimmst halt einen Film und dann guckst du halt, ob es irgendwie zwei Frauen gibt in diesem Film, die auch einen Namen haben.
Bei Star Wars?
Zum Beispiel, ja. Die dann auch miteinander reden?
Ja, sie sagt am Ende Tschüss zu ihr.
Dann haben wir noch mehr Frauen da. Weiß nicht, wie heißt diese neue, diese Kleene, neue mit den Club-Showern?
Ach die, die Kleene da mit den Club-Showern. Ach so, ja, genau. Wie hieß er doch gleich hier? Irgendwie, äh...
Na egal, der Film, der Film besteht offenbar diesen Test, deswegen muss ich jetzt nicht aufzählen. Und die dritte Bedingung ist, dass, wenn sie sich unterhalten, dass sie sich nicht über einen Mann unterhalten.
Das ging die ganze Zeit im Look.
Schaut euch den Film an, bildet euch eure eigene Meinung.
Also ich fand den ja gut, der war schon witzig und so, aber ja, ist halt Unterhaltung.
Aber welche zwei Frauen gibt es denn bei Alien, die dir mit Namen einfallen?
Da war ja nur eine Frau.
Nee, da war noch eine zweite.
Stimmt, die ist auch gestorben relativ schnell.
Vorher haben sie sich noch unterhalten, aber nicht über einen Mann.
Ach so, und das kleine Mädchen gab es auch.
Das ist schon wirklich krank.
Aber was ich nicht gedacht habe, ich dachte, Ola Han Solo hat auch nur so einen kleinen Cameo-Effekt, damit er noch mal irgendwie in vorne mit aufs Plastik-Cover mit raufdrücken kann. Aber nee, der hat ja schon die ziemlich tragende Rolle eigentlich. Und ich meine, der Mann ist 72 oder so.
Ja, aber jetzt spoilern wir nicht noch mehr.
Das ist ja eh schon vorbei. Wer den jetzt noch nicht gesehen hat, der guckt den auch noch nicht so schnell.
Ich bin auch nicht so schnell und totaler Star Wars Fanboy. Und ich will einen Ray-Poster haben. So, Leute, wir könnten jetzt unsere Androhungen warm machen und nicht so eine lange Sendung machen. Oder ja, ich hab mal alles, was irgendwie...
Na, den kleinen Kram können wir doch mal jetzt schnell runterreißen.
Ja, na, weißt du, wie das ist mit diesem kleinen Kram?
Der kleinen Kram ist der gefährlichste.
Ich bin ja nicht so wie ihr, weißt du, bei mir geht das immer schnell. Also zum Beispiel hier, FreeBSD 10.3 ist gerade rausgekommen, jetzt mit EFI und ZFS-Support. Das heißt, da müsste man eigentlich den, wenn man da bei FreeBSD sich so ein Memory-Stick-Image runterlädt, ich glaube 70 MB oder so und sich das auf einem OSB-Stick installiert, damit sein Mac irgendwie bootet oder installiert, irgendwie auf eine externe Platte. Das müsste jetzt alles super easy gehen, wenn man mal FreeBSD probieren will. Weil früher ging das ja nicht so richtig mit dem Uefi-Booten und so weiter. Jetzt können die das alles schicken mit ZFS unten drunter und so weiter. Also wenn man sich mit den Fingern mal so tief eintauchen will, ist jetzt die Chance.
Also was ist da jetzt noch mal anders als vorher?
Der EFI-Bootsupport, der auch ZFS kann. Das ging früher nur mit UFS. Und noch vor einer Weile ging es gar nicht, weil FreeBSD keinen EFI-Support hatte. Und das kommt jetzt Schritt für Schritt. Und jetzt kann es halt auch richtig ZFS. Und 10.3 ist jetzt gerade vor ein paar Tagen rausgekommen, der neueste Release, und kann man mal testen.
Wird alles gut jetzt sozusagen.
Wird alles gut und besser und schneller und so. So, dann das nächste, was ich hab. Ich glaube, ich hab hier schon mal von so einem Tool erzählt, das ist so ein Stammbaum-App, die heißt Ancestree. Und da kann man zwar all sein Zeug eingeben, aber irgendwie wollen die auch immer Kohle haben und die Features sind beschränkt und irgendwie so richtig. Das ist schon alles ganz nett gemacht, aber so richtig, richtig will ich mich da nicht committen und schon gar nichts bezahlen. Deswegen hab ich ein bisschen weiter gesucht und hab so ein Projekt gefunden, das heißt wikitree.com. Also wikitree und da macht man nicht seinen eigenen Stammbaum, sondern aus deren Sicht ist die ganze Welt halt ein Stammbaum und du machst halt deinen eigenen Bereich und irgendwann, wenn halt keine Ahnung, deine Uroma mit der Uroma eines anderen sich übereinstimmt, dann verbinden sich die Bäume so und dann gibt's da so Connections zwischen den Personen. Wer da Bock auf sowas hat, ist ja auch so ein Privacy-Ding, der kann das hier benutzen. Was sie schon per Standard haben, ist Leute, die leben, sind automatisch nicht public. Also wenn du da eine Person eingibst, die noch lebt, dann ist die für andere nicht so richtig zu sehen, außer vom Namen her. Und selbst wenn du da mit dem Namen auftauchst und dir gefällt das nicht, kannst du da hinschreiben und sie nehmen dich sofort raus.
Aber wenn sie nicht public ist, dann siehst du sie nur in deinem Account oder was? Aber in dem Moment, wo du sie als Tod markierst, dann tauchen sie automatisch?
Naja, nicht so schnell. Die haben da auch verschiedene Privacy-Levels. Du kannst die minimal sichtbar machen, ein bisschen mehr sichtbar und komplett sichtbar. Aber wie gesagt, du kannst das auf jeden Fall nicht machen für Leute, die nur noch leben. Die sind grundsätzlich immer closed. Und Leute, die länger als 200 Jahre tot sind, sind grundsätzlich immer komplett offen. Da kann jeder rumeditieren. 200 Jahre. Ja, das heißt, alle alten historischen Figuren sind da offen. Natürlich kannst du da auch so ein bisschen, wie bei Wikipedia, da wird dann auch schon so ein bisschen geguckt. Wenn du da einen Eintrag an irgendwie Mozart oder irgendeiner anderen Figur machst, dann kannst du da auch natürlich auch nicht einfach rumfuschen, sondern musst dann schon irgendwie genug Punkte haben. Also du musst da sozusagen ein bisschen Credits bei denen haben. Aber es ist halt cool, dass so halt die wollen dich irgendwie kohlemäßig nicht abzocken und dass halt alles ein großer Baum ist und so weiter. So, ich habe da mal so ein paar Family-Members eingetragen. Von denen bin ich jetzt sozusagen der Manager. Also ich bin jetzt der Manager von meiner Mom, ist auch mal was Neues. Ich bin auch der Manager von meiner Oma und noch von den Leuten von davor. Und wenn mein Baum jetzt, was auch schon passiert ist, mit dem Baum von einem anderen Typen übereinstößt und zwar irgendwie 1812 gibt es da eine Connection und die trifft auch wirklich, habe ich den jetzt angeschrieben, dass sich unsere Bäume da kreuzen und dass wir die doch mal connecten können, weil er ist halt Manager von seinen Figuren und deswegen muss ich ihn erst fragen, bevor wir das zusammenkleben. Und eigentlich ist das ganz cool. Macht irgendwie Spaß. Also das bringt jetzt wirklich nicht so viel Spaß.
Hast jetzt deine Filme alle gemapped, jetzt sind die Familienmembers.
Ja, nee, ich hab das ja vor ein paar Jahren schon mal gemacht.
Wie viele Leute hast du da drin?
Da jetzt noch nicht ganz so viel, weil ich hab halt vorher mit diesem Ancestry gearbeitet und da hab ich so knappe 70 waren das.
70, okay.
Und durch meinen Familienhintergrund, so meine männliche oder väterliche Seite ist nicht so ausgeprägt und deswegen eigentlich hab ich nur, ja, das ist ganz schön dünn bei mir, aber dafür sind es ganz viele. Also ich hab nach hinten, ich hab Oma lange gelöchert und Fotoalben geblättert und gemacht und getan und immer Oma gefragt, ey wer ist denn das, wer ist denn das? Und Oma kann sich gut erinnern und ist auch schon nicht mehr die Jüngste. Das heißt, auch Oma geht ganz schön weit zurück und kennt sich noch ein bisschen aus. Und Omas Eltern waren eine Großfamilie, es waren zwölf Leute, also zwölf Kinder. Und da geht schon ein bisschen was.
Und wie weit geht es so zurück?
1812. Und die Eltern davon hab ich jetzt auch schon gefunden. 1798, der älteste. Aus Holland. Wenn das stimmt, bin ich mir noch nicht so ganz sicher. Aber es macht auf jeden Fall Spaß.
Ich hab auch so einen Stammbaum auf Ancestry.
Jetzt wird es doch wieder so ein Thema.
Aber in deinem Namen müsste das doch easy gehen, oder? Also, den gibt es ja wirklich nicht so oft. Dann müsste man doch schnell viel finden. Also, oder was heißt viel finden. Aber wenn es da was gibt, müssten da sich schnell Connections...
Das ist ja nicht nur mein Name. Also, irgendwie dieser Stammbaum ist jetzt 1494 Personen reich und geht zurück.
Meine Fresse, den hast du aber nicht komplett eingemessen. Der ist schon mit vielen anderen verknüpft, oder wie?
Also, ich hab den nicht vor allem vorangetrieben. Da ist sicherlich viel verknüpft worden und alle möglichen. Du kannst ja über Ancestry, kriegst ja dann auch mal so...
Hast du einen bezahlten Account, oder was? Oder ist dein Account public? Ich hab meinen Stammwurm halt closed da.
Ja, der ist... Ich glaub, das kostet nix.
Nee, das kostet nix, aber ich hab meinen trotzdem halt auf closed da gesetzt und vielleicht hat da keiner sich rangeknüpft.
Ja, aber es gibt ja so öffentliche Archive, die man da sozusagen tappen kann. Und da halt meine Linie nach England geht und da halt sehr viel vorliegt. Also diese ganzen britischen Geburtsarchive, die sind wohl ganz ordentlich digitalisiert, war da einfach eine ganze Menge zu holen. Und das geht hier irgendwie zurück bis, ich weiß gar nicht, bis, was ist das hier, 1600, irgendwas.
Ja, ich glaube auch, ich weiß nicht, ob das an Deutschland oder am Zweiten Weltkrieg liegt, aber auch die Amis sind mit ihrer Anforschung ganz schön hinterher. Die enden dann meistens hier in Deutschland vor dem Krieg oder irgendwie letztes Jahr, vorletztes Jahrhundert.
Ja, der Krieg hat natürlich reingehauen. Also mütterlicherseits sind diese ganzen alten Aufzeichnungen, die gab es irgendwie auch 500 Jahre zurück, die sind leider im Krieg komplett zerstört worden. Das ist natürlich immer so ein bisschen das Problem. Also, mich gab es irgendwie auch schon vor 300 Jahren in gewisser Hinsicht.
Einen mit deinem Namen?
Ich gucke gerade mal hier so die Prit Loves.
Oder meinst du, deine Gene kannst du so weit zurückverfolgen?
Also das Älteste, was ich hier mit Prit Love habe, ist irgendwie 1730.
Aber du predigst ja auch zu den Massen oder sprichst zu den Massen und so.
Ja, na klar.
Gerade zu hochschieben jetzt.
Hast du noch ein Thema, das du unbedingt unterbringen möchtest? Ne, ne.
Doch, du hattest doch was. Eigentlich, das war doch der Grund, weil wir dich hier quasi gefördert haben.
Ja, aber ihr macht doch die Announcement eher zu Schluss oder zum Schluss?
Sie baden gerade ihre Hände drin.
Ja, wir gehen jetzt zu den Endsport, dachte ich mir mal so und...
Also du hast noch ein Thema Zeit, was zu suchen. Noch ein Projekt, was ich über meinen Kollegen, der den Homebrew Bundle Dingsbums da gefahren hat, ausgefunden hat, ist, dass es quasi ein Fork von Vim gibt, der sich da nennt Neo Vim. Und das Ziel hat viele Funktionen, die so Plugins oder wie auch immer man das Bundles oder so Extensions von Vim nochmal anfangen. Ah, Neo Vim macht eine Sache besser, nämlich diese ganzen Extensions, die so sowas wie Autocompletion, Fuzzy Search, Syntax Highlighting, die sind halt im normalen Vim alles Single Threaded und dann dauert es halt mal, also dann blockt die UI, wenn man halt mal so ein Plugin fährt. Und Neo Vim fährt das halt in Multithreaded, also lagert das sozusagen alsynchron aus und dadurch wird dann der Vim ein bisschen flotter. Und der Neo Vim kann halt auch so 24 Bit True Color und irgendwie so Leute, so Zeug, was man eigentlich nicht braucht. Aber checkt das mal aus, wenn ihr Vim-Freunde sein und mal vielleicht einen etwas moderneren Vim haben wollt. Neo Vim. Sprudelt sauber, sprudelt frisch.
Ich hab ja den Emax so ein bisschen für mich entdeckt, seitdem ich diesen Org-Mode da drin gefunden habe. Großartig. Das ist so ein bisschen wie eine bessere To-Do-Liste. Ich hab jetzt das grad gesehen bei Tim, er nutzt ja Workflow. Ich fand das am Anfang total schön, aber es ist eben irgendwo die Daten und nicht lokal bei dir. Und damit habe ich ein großes Problem. Nein, der Org-Mode ist schon mal nicht schlecht. Also hast du auch so eine Tree-Mode, so ein Tree dann.
Org-Mode.
Ich dachte auch.
Irgendwas so mit Herr der Ringe mäßig.
Org-Se-Mode?
Jaja, keine Ahnung.
Nee, es ist so ein bisschen eine Extension für den Emacs.
Was heißt das?
Du hast die Funktionalität ähnlich zu Workflow, wie mit, dass du so geschachtelte... Ja, also da hast du halt alles schön lokal auf deinem Rechner und kannst dann durch die Bäume durchgehen. Das ist natürlich nicht so ins Extreme geschachtelt, wie bei Workflow, dass du auf einen Knoten klicken kannst und dann dieser Knoten irgendwie als deinen Head da oben erscheint. Das kann es nicht, aber wenn du halt eine nicht extrem...
Man muss ja diese Begriffe auch mal in die Landschaft kriegen, damit... Nein, ich finde einfach... Also es kann einfach nicht sein, dass Leute nicht wissen, die sechs Basis-Elemente einer Outline. Ich meine, das ist einfach mal... Wie sechs? Man weiß ja auch, dass ein Punkt am Ende eines Satzes ist und man kennt ja auch, was weiß ich, Markdown und andere Sachen und man weiß, was ein Text-File ist und Binary. Und man weiß, was eine fucking Outline ist.
Echt nicht.
Naja, das ist doch das Drama.
Ja, das wird sich auch nicht ändern, weil es benutzt keiner.
Das wirst du noch mal sehen, hier Outlines, die werden dann mal eine komplette Wohnung durchwischen irgendwann. Ja, so kommt es nämlich. Ja, ja, das haben wir beim Podcast auch gesagt.
Aber du könntest das auch trotzdem nicht in den Zombie-Org-Modus da kriegen, weil wir ja auch hier alle mitgucken und du brauchst das ja online und geshared.
Da gibt es auch eine Emacs-Extension.
Es gibt ja auch auf GitHub von Workflow das für den Vim als Extension, dass du halt den Vim dann auch dazu ein bisschen ummodeln kannst.
Ja, also ich hatte schon vor Jahren der Mensch, der mich eigentlich in den Chaos Computer Club gebracht hatte, der hat auch immer Emacs benutzt und hatte dann irgendwann auch das Ziel, sozusagen Emacs als seine primäre Benutzerüberfläche für alles zu verwenden. Also der hat gechattet in Emacs, der hat Emails gelesen, der hat gebraust, der hat gecodet, der hat compiled, der hat alles halt mit Emacs gemacht und seine eigenen Extensions auch geschrieben. Und das hat er natürlich nicht lange durchgehalten. Aber so ein paar Monate oder ein halbes Jahr, sag ich mal, war das halt schon Programm. Und da dachte ich auch, Holla die Waldfee.
Also ich nutze es halt wirklich nur als To-Do-List. Ja, es ist halt ganz nett, weil du auch so ein paar Funktionen drin hast wie Deadlines. Das ist irgendwie ganz hübsch. Aber ich muss es nicht ins Extreme treiben. Zur Not tut es auch Zettel und Papier.
Das sieht ganz cool aus. Also ich meine, hier steht Org ist build on top of Outline.el. Das handelt sich hierbei wohl ein Outliner.
Ein handelsüblichen...
So heißt es.
Outliner erzeugt eine Outline. Und eine Outline ist halt eine Liste von hierarchisch verschachtelten Punkten, die kann man expanden und kollapsen. Damit klappst du aus und klappst wieder ein, kannst sie häusen. Damit sagst du halt, ein Unterpunkt wird zu deinem aktuellen Betrachtungspunkt und dann machst du anhäustigen und dann bist du halt da wieder raus und dann kannst du halt irgendwie in der Hierarchie hin und her schieben. So und das ist eigentlich alles, was man im Wesentlichen verstehen muss. Also so wie der Feind das schon immer macht, mit den Files. Nein, im Feinder kannst du vor allem nicht zwei Elemente mit demselben Inhalt haben. Also im Prinzip ja irgendwie schon, aber das Häusling hast du in dem Moment, wo du halt sagst, dieser Ordner in seinem eigenen Fenster und dieser Name auf deinem Reißkorn. So und deswegen benutze du... Was war das nochmal? Den EMAX, den Org-Mode?
Im EMAX, ja genau.
Deswegen benutze überhaupt EMAX, ist klar. Ja ja, Wim versus EMAX, das wird sich glaube ich nie so richtig entscheiden können.
Da bin ich auch nicht irgendwie religiös.
Nicht?
Wozu? Also ich meine, ich kann mir über bessere Dinge Gedanken machen, als welchen Browser ich nutze, ob ich Spaces oder Tabs nutze. Entschuldigung, ich hab halt...
Du hast ja eine festen Überzeugungen an deinen Bereichen.
Richtig. Dinge, die mir wichtiger sind, richtig.
So, jetzt dein Thema.
Genau. Am 22. April bis zum 24. April wird in der Seabase die Space App Challenge der NASA stattfinden. Wir haben uns darauf beworben und auch die Zusage bekommen, am ersten Tag ist irgendwie ein Freitag. Wir werden das ganze Wochenende durch coden, mehr oder weniger. Seabase ist offen für alles und jeden Spezies des Universums quasi. Ob Designer, ob Hacker, das ist uns relativ egal. Wir wollen irgendwie coole Leute zusammenbringen, um die Daten, die die NASA bereitstellt, für diese Challenge halt ein bisschen zu bearbeiten, zu schauen, ob uns da schöne Ideen kommen. Genau, also 22. April bis 24. April in der Seabase. Wir haben auf der Space Apps Challenge, auch Berlin, das kannst du ja vielleicht in die Show Notes packen, Tim, auch den Link zu der Seite davon, wo man sich registrieren muss.
Machs einfach in den Chat und dann wirds gepinnt.
Super, genau, da muss man sich halt kurz registrieren und Freitag kommt auch einer von GitHub, der wird über ein Tool von GitHub berichten, welches ich schon wieder vergessen habe. Das GitHub Hub, glaube ich, heißt das. Es ist ein relativ unbekanntes Tool, was aber scheinbar den Arbeitsablauf eines Entwicklers sehr zum Positiven steigern soll.
Nochmal GitHub was?
Ja, jedenfalls, es kommt ein Mensch von GitHub und wird genau über dieses Tool halt auch berichten. Also wir haben GitHub irgendwie angequatscht, ob die uns nicht. Das scheint wohl irgendwie sehr, sehr mächtig und cool zu sein. Da wird dir halt so ein bisschen was dazu erzählen und danach werden wir auch hoffentlich eine Idee haben, was in den Daten drin sind, dass wir da noch ein bisschen was machen können. Aber ja, es ist ein Hackathon und meldet euch zahlreich an. Kommt zahlreich. Ich hab jetzt noch nicht geschaut, ob die immer spezifische Themen haben. Space Station war glaube ich auch dieses Jahr eine, wo sie halt so ein bisschen die Richtung, ich will es nicht sagen vorgeben, aber in eine gewisse Richtung lenken wollen für die NASA. Ich muss nochmal auf die Seite schauen, aber die Space Station war eine, ich glaube auch Mars war so ein bisschen die Mars-Mission glaube ich als Ziel auch für die. Die Frage ist halt, was sie für Daten bereitstellen.
Alles am Ende eine Frage.
Also es geht um Technologie, Aeronautik, Space Station, Journey to Mars, Earth and Solar System. Und Daten sind aber noch nicht dahinter.
Sag nochmal Datum.
22. April bis 24. April.
Also Soon. In zwei Wochen ungefähr. In der C-Base in Berlin. Und wenn ihr irgendwie Bock auf geile Apps, also nicht Apps im Sinne von Mobile Apps, sondern Apps, die sind von Running Code. Das ist mehr so ein Hackathon generell. Space-Daten, okay.
Einfach irgendwie Leute, die auch interessiert sind an dem ganzen Thema NASA an sich, sind herzlich willkommen.
Bestens. Super. Nicht gut.
Ansonsten NASA ist übermorgen wieder ein SpaceX-Flug mit versuchter Landung.
Naja, jetzt wird's aber langsamer Zeit. Jetzt kriegen sie ja von den Amazon-Haini die ganze Zeit da landende Raketen vor die Nase gesetzt.
Na gut, aber gelandet haben die ja auch schon eine.
Ja, eine. Aber die haben jetzt irgendwie drei oder vier schon und vor allem keinen Crash.
Ja, aber es ist ja auch nur eine Touristenrakete.
Sie landet und es sieht auch sehr cool aus.
Aber irgendwie interessiert es keinen.
Ist halt...
So nennlösnäßig geht das immer ein bisschen unter, wer das so macht.
Ja, ist halt kleiner.
Ja, und die kann halt keine Last hochbringen. Außer einen Touristen.
Ja, ja, ich bin auch ganz bei dir, das ist definitiv...
Aber das stimmt schon. Die Technik am Ende muss schon auch so ein bisschen ähnlich sein. Also ich meine, beim Landen spätestens ist das ja nicht so doll anders.
Genau. Die haben da auf jeden Fall für das selbe Problem eine eigene Antwort gefunden, die relativ zuverlässig funktioniert. Und das ist ja auch gut so. So, heute machen wir mal 20 Minuten früher Schluss, oder? Ich muss auch morgen wieder früh ran. Und ich finde, das Chat-Experiment, was würdet ihr sagen, hat ganz gut funktioniert, oder?
Sie haben auch jetzt nicht doll geändert, im Gegensatz zu dir, außer dass du die ganze Zeit dabei bist, unbeliebsame Beträger zu entfernen.
Nee, also das, man kann halt auch, das finde ich halt auch noch so ein Vorteil. Man kann halt, wenn man was falsch geschrieben hat, kann man es halt auch ändern. Man kann auch seine Beiträge löschen, oder auch mal andere, aber auf jeden Fall... Ja, man kann ordentlich Zensur ausüben, aber im Wesentlichen geht es mir um dieses, also ich finde allein schon mit diesen Previews, dass es irgendwie cool ist, einfach ein bisschen spielerischer. Und von daher bin ich dabei. Ich finde das jetzt erstmal noch nicht unbedingt gescheitert, sagen wir es mal so.
Nee, davon sind wir weit entfernt.
Davon sind wir ganz weit entfernt. Weil es ist ja auch ein Qualitätspodcast hier.
Ja, mit ordentlich Slack am Stecken.
Ihr hört schon, der Zeitpunkt ist gut gewählt. Wir fahren das runter. Und wir sagen Danke an Letty. Darf es wieder kommen?
Witz und Heidigkeit.
Ich muss mir erstmal neue Ausreden ausdenken. Mach mal.
Und damit leiten wir dann auch das unvermeidliche Ende ein. Mit Kling-Bing und Tra-la-la. Vielen Dank an David für die immer wieder geilen Intros. Vielen Dank an die Community für eure Mithilfe hier. Und generell die Unterstützung von allem. Wir sagen jetzt Tschüss. Bis in zwei Wochen.